foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun oh my God
he's gone for it Knight eated G5 was a
new serious choice
once again Vicon say starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back there it is the world champion once
again proving that he indeed has the
best technique in the game
the world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
championed here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
Joe leave out those poised to capture
their first Tata title he's like the
nicest person on the planet when it
comes to his chest you just don't want
to mess with it
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps the win
for black Notre back continues his hot
streak the Dutch refer to Tata steel as
The Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
it's day four round four at Tata steel
chess 2023 you see the many players and
fans wanting more chess and they are
going to get it I am bread Master Robert
Hess alongside me is my friend
International Master Tanya Tanya we've
had three excellent days of Chess thus
far what do you think is gonna happen
today before the rest day
all of that and a lot more Robert I
think the fact that we've got a rest day
coming up the players are all pumped to
go all in today because it's really just
about going all out getting that action
in they know they can rest tomorrow it's
going to be about opening preparation
who gets the momentum going I'm really
looking forward to what the players
bring on the board as I'm sure is
absolutely some players have a longer
days than others yesterday we only had
one decisive game but that was not for
lack of trying or lack of fighting
because it was a marathon end game
between Lavon aronian and Arjun era
Garcia as well as pragananda and Vincent
kheimer the two uh matchups that you see
in the bottom of yesterday's results but
Tony it kind of was all about Fabiano
caruana yesterday
a hundred percent but I think the
results that we have in front of us are
not reflective of the chest that we saw
the big fights that we saw as you were
pointing at Arjun and Winston saving
some Marathon games being under pressure
for the most part of it showed
resourcefulness and we had amazing chess
all throughout with complex and games
that we all loved watching it was just
one decisive result which actually put
Fabi at the top of the leaderboard
it certainly did he joins four other
familiar faces at the top Magnus Carlson
Anish giri dingley Ren and no dearbeck
Abdus atarov all share first place with
Fabiano caruana and yesterday Fiona
caught up with Fabiano to talk about his
win which was the only decisive result
of Monday's action
be unclear like it's the kind of
Advantage where this tiny tiny bit of an
advantage throughout the middle game and
at some point it seemed like he was
misplained a bit
and I had a serious Advantage but it was
also extremely unclear like it's the
kind of Advantage where you can easily
imagine losing it
um if you make one inaccuracy
and then people under the g-pawn that
was that was basically the entire game I
mean he the position was unclear maybe I
was a bit better and then he just
blundered G4 I didn't see the computer
evaluation but it looked like a very
difficult position for him yeah
like after I'm done in exchange for two
pawns and his King is super weak it
wasn't easy but it felt very bad
we heard from Fabiano himself I Tanya
would always strike me about his
interviews is not just how professional
he is but how objective about the chess
like he said oh maybe I was slightly
better but it was not going to be easy
it was tricky the type of vans that you
could slip up and lose so I really
always note that when I hear a five
minute car one interview
he definitely keeps it real but I think
that was a shocking moment from day
three with Jordan pretty much just
giving the game away as a gift to Fabi
with G4 the one move blunder and that
really puts a big question mark to
Jordan's shape and form in this event
completely agree with you uh Fabi very
objective evaluation there we had the
eval bar say that Fabi played a Flawless
game on day three but the players just
have no idea the kind of advantage that
they have he kept it under control all
throughout he certainly did on the other
side of things we say Jordan van four is
dropping down in the standings one point
out of three games and he's kind of
fortunate to even have one full point
those two draws that he had were from
much worse positions with the white
pieces so as we tune into day four we
have a rejuvenated Fabiano caruana he
won that game to tie the leaders and as
we see he takes on Richard report so
report ever the fighting player is the
question is will Fabiano be able to
bring that momentum today
this is a great matchup Richard will
come in with some Innovative opening
ideas so I'll be showed yesterday he's
ready for all of that a huge match here
coming on will Fabi be able to keep up
the momentum is the big question
certainly isn't up the top Wesley so
gets Lavon aronian Tanya your thoughts
about the All-American Derby
this is the All-American match up but of
course we've seen these two fight it out
over the chessboard so many times Wesley
so has won the Tata steel Masters once
before Levon aronian has been the
four-time champion of this tournament
both have been having a solid start and
yes they haven't won a game yet but I
think we can easily say that they have
been showing good form in the tournament
so far it's going to be all about who
gets the kind of position that they want
out of the opening certainly the case in
the matchup between Vincent kymer and
Arjun eragisi teenagers duking it out
they have never played in classical
chess they have split their matches in
the Champions chess tour in 2022 but
Vincent he recently swept Arjun at the
2022 World rapid and Blitz and Vincent
he is the silver medalist in Rapid chess
that was an amazing accomplishment Arjun
himself gained 90 rating points in the
year 2022 In classical chess that's
unbelievable so in the each player's
first appearance in the Masters division
of Tata steel we'll see who continues in
better form will be Vincent who was able
to draw that long end game yesterday or
is it Arjun who's had three very
impressive games he has been sound
throughout most of it and when he was on
the edge of losing that first game he
still managed to draw yesterday
the other matchup that I am super
excited about is ding lyron taking on
pregnant that's world number two ding
with world number 52 Prague but don't be
fooled by that because we've seen Prague
take on Madness and the way he does it
he's established himself in these faster
time controls against the world number
one what will he bring in his first ever
encounter against the world championship
Challenger dingler and this is a super
exciting matchup it is The Clash of
generations it's certainly is and while
they haven't played in classical chess
ding did defeat prognanda in the finals
of the chessable Masters so perhaps
pragnana has Vengeance on his brain but
as we move forward in this list of
pairings the big matchup of today is
co-leaders Anish giri and Magnus Carlson
so Tanya the head to head it's all
Magnus except in vikon Zay that's the
interesting part is that Anish giri
holds his own when playing in the Dutch
territory
a hundred percent he loves playing over
there but take a look at their match
scores it is Magnus Carlson who's had
six wins while Anish giri has just won
one game against him and that was also
back in 2011. in fact fun fact here
Robert that was the first time they ever
played a classical game against each
other and the last time in waikansea in
2022 Magnus Carlson took on Anish giri
once more it was Magnus who came out on
top a huge lead there now this has
actually come on to be one of the big
rivalries of modern chess and Robert I'm
not just talking about over the board
stuff here but even we've seen the
Bromance go through its different phases
on Twitter whenever we've got this
matchup it's fun time it certainly is
and yes uh not yester excuse me last
year's match was unbelievable where
Magnus played that Catalan sacrifice
material and he really blew a niche off
the board so they may have a bromance on
Twitter but when they play over the
chessboard they are no longer friends
they're more Frenemies
chess is now we've also got two players
who have who has so far been a
struggling in the tournament Jordan van
first will face off against gokish in
this one they've had a shaky start in
the event so I think they want to come
out on top get that leaderboard going an
important match for currently the two
players who are at the bottom of the
board we also have NADA back taking on
Parham
yeah that matchup will be so fascinating
Abdus atarov and maksudu very
adventurous and attacking players and
it's the Uzbek the former World rapid
Champion The Olympian gold medalist and
Parham who was the last second invitee
to this field so let's remind everybody
that this is a 13 round event uh 14
players take part they each play another
opponent once 30 players were invited
one player Arjun airgasi qualified by
winning the challengers tournament last
year scoring is standard one point for a
win a half point for a draw and as is
natural the player with the most points
out of the 13 games wins the
championship
absolutely Robin and once again let's
also take a look at the time control
this is as classical as it gets it is
the long time format The Wimbledon of
Chess really brings out the best in the
players in the opening middle game and
end game and that's because they've got
the time to navigate through the
complexities you've got a hundred
minutes that's an hour and 40 minutes
for the first 40 moves once they reach
that they get an additional 50 minutes
to make to make it to 60 for the next 20
moves and of course they get a 30 second
increment every time they make a move
every time they press a clock and
finally after move 60 they will get an
additional 15 minutes on the clock
yes it's a long time Patrol and the
players they're just getting seated
right now so it's the start of what
could be a very long game you see Wesley
so he's writing down the name of his
opponent and we see that opponent by his
fashion Choice Tanya that is a levada
roadian shirt if I've ever seen one
fashion game strong you just need to see
that Visual and you know it's Gotta Be
love somebody asked him once where does
he get his shirts and he actually said
that's the secret that he's not gonna
let out uh so Levon that we see him with
his signature style and his signature
cup of the he's ready to start with the
black pieces he had such a long game
yesterday against Arjun some missed
chances there by Lev and it's going to
be all about whether he's got the energy
to create that kind of uh well that kind
of a position that he had yesterday
Wesley also extremely solid and now on
our screen we can see the big matchup
that we're all waiting for Anish waiting
for Magnus to arrive with the white
pieces an Easter looking sharp
representing some of his sponsors you
know optivia that's been a long time a
sponsor of Anish Geary and chessball of
course he has made many Great Courses on
chessable and there we see it a
handshake between two familiar foes uh
they go at it on Twitter they've gone
over the chessboard and while Anish giri
has a losing record head-to-head as most
players do against Magnus Carlson in
Vikings a they are even and that is
something that allows a niche to feel a
sense of confidence he performs so well
in vikon Zay and even though it's Magnus
Carlson the highest rated player in the
world the world champion and all three
disciplines classical rapid and Blitz
somehow in Vikings a Anish giri holds
his own
he sure does Robin but he's playing
against somebody who's won the event
eight times here we are talking about a
matchup between these two players who
have phenomenal performances in wike and
it is go time as a niche starts wow
that's a surprise I was actually
expecting the King's Pawn opening from
him but he starts with one D4
okay he decides to move the Queen's Pawn
against Magnus Carlson not the first
time Magnus has seen that pawn push
that's for sure but we've talked about
this pretty much every day what does my
opponent expect of me that is the
question that Magnus is asking himself
uh because Magnus has thousands of games
that you can look up and see is today
going to be a gruntfeld day like he did
against Vincent kymer is it going to be
a queen's game it accept the day I don't
know Madness to play the qga but why not
today is a new game so let's play a new
line so that's what happens in the
opening you see Magnus adjusting his
pieces before he makes his first move
what do you expect to see from the world
champion
this is a classic Magnus start of the
game style he comes in regardless of
where the clock is but the games have
already started or not he always adjusts
pieces uh puts them in the way he likes
it and then he makes them first move
before I could answer it Robert he
answers it himself he starts with the
Knight to F6 and he is hinting towards
going for a Queen's Gambit decline
potentially so no grunfels this time
right D5 could be his next move and he
no he plays Queens Indian a queen's
Indian this bishop goes to B7 to
challenge the bishop that's going to G2
and perhaps because magnet oh out to a
sick all right this is old school so
your attack upon on C4 uh White has
options of how to defend it you could
push your Pawn to B3 simple defense a
Pawn's best friends another Pawn you can
bring this queen all the way out to A4
after which black often will bring his
Bishop back to B7 and push the pawn to
C5 the claim is that while the light
Square Bishop has moved twice the queen
is offside on A4 and Tony I'm going to
pass it over to you because you're a
queen's Pawn player uh you have
undoubtedly faced the uh Queen's Indian
defense here and here in this case it's
kind of BOGO system so what's your
experience like and what do you like to
play with the white side
this is a fun Line This is a fun line
usually you want to take the bishop out
to B7 which you were pointing out which
leads to these positional strategic
battles but Bishop A6 often becomes a
mess in the middle game as you were
pointing out the black is threatening C4
the move that I like with white is Queen
to C2 you defend the pawn with your
queen you place the queen anticipating a
middle game where to be nicely placed on
the b1287 diagonal but it leads to a lot
of fun Robert and complicated lines as
black can immediately strike in the
center with the move C5 which involves a
lot of long Theory white ghost D5 trying
to break in into Black's uh defenses in
front of the king and it is a messy
Theory but I would love to see the game
progress this way just a couple of weeks
ago the two actually played against each
other in the world rapid and Blitz
Championship Ani started with the white
pieces Magnus had black there but Anish
chose the kingspawn opening it was a
crazy crazy French and again one there
as well we had an absolute mess out of
the middle game so even though Anish has
chosen a most strategic approach in this
one starting with the Queen's Pawn
opening I like that Magnus has made the
move Bishop A6 it means he's in the mood
for a bloodbath here he certainly is you
see any scary thinking we know that when
he's prepped he moves very quickly and I
just want to show some of the variations
in the line that you presented because
this has been played hundreds of times
if not way more than that if black goes
ahead and Scoops up this Pawn on D5 this
is a big mistake Queen E4 check hits the
knight in addition to checking the king
and if that Knight moves back you say I
save my knight down goes your rook in
the corner so this would actually just
scoop up material for white and so if
you take on D5 in a position like this
black will play Bishop to B7 back and
the problem for white is that you want
to make this move E4 but after Queen E7
not only is this Pawn under attack it's
pinned to the king so while you may
protect the E4 Pawn now the D5 Pawn is
also hanging so there are tactics Galore
in the early stages of this opening and
so you have to be very very careful for
both sides because the pawn sacrifice
has serious bite but it also could
backfire if you're not careful
you've got to be really prepared if you
want to give up that bond for the
initiative and with the amount of time
that a niche is taking currently one
gets the feeling that of course he's
prepared for the match but perhaps he
wasn't expecting Magnus to one choose
the Queen's Indian defense with B6 and a
step ahead of that to make the last move
this bishop to A6 go for this extremely
combative line that the two have played
on the board and we see Anish there
trying to think of his approach now
we've pointed out what happens in this
Pawn sacrifice line the other way that
white can approach this position which
is extremely theoretical as well is the
move B3 as you were mentioning a pawn is
a Pawn's best friend and you can play B3
defending that C4 Pawn the line
continues Robert with black taking out
that Bishop with the tempo you give a
check on B4 and the whole idea is that
you provoke white to put his own Bishop
on D2 to intercept the check because you
don't want him to put that Bishop on B2
where it's the strongest placed piece
and now after Bishop d do you can just
fall back Bishop E7 and this is a more
strategic approach to the middle game it
continues a lot slower I'm hoping that
Anish chooses Queen C2 and we see some
crazy fireworks I just like the way
you're illustrating this position the
bishop is better placed on B2 so it
seems like you're handing your opponent
a Tempo by giving the check and moving
back but you're putting a piece on a
square doesn't want to be on so it's
always interesting to see players in the
opening figure out what they want to do
Anish seems completely unsure he was not
expecting this uh so he is calculating
here he's just trying to think what does
Magnus want from me and he has no idea
he has no idea and Robert I am looking
around on our boards let's get a bird's
eye view let's just zoom out from this
position while Anish get takes a thought
on how he wants to approach this middle
game will he go all out sacrifice upon
or will he play it safe right now but
take a look at what is happening around
the board and what catches my attention
is that bottom left Port one of our
tournament leaders Fabiano caruana with
the black pieces taking on the most
imaginative player in modern chess
Richard rappo and what is this position
fabi's already gone for G5 H5 expanded
on the king side it at first thought
when I saw this I thought Richard was
the one playing from Black
well let's Dive Right into that game
between Richard report and Fabiano
caruana
um that way we can see is this a worthy
aggressive play from Fabi or is it kind
of a bluff I don't believe Bobby Bluffs
in the opening so as we head to the
board here we see the last couple moves
we can start from the beginning it was
a position with a Queen's Gambit decline
via transposition Richardson with C4
just like he did against Wesley so and
after this bishop came out to G5 Tanya
we saw black do the same with Bishop B4
and after white tries to develop look at
this H6 G5 breaking the pin and H5 so we
it makes sense how we got here but now
that we're here help me out I don't know
if I uh like it for black but because
Fabiano's doing it I sort of trust it as
preparation
this is incredible stuff from Fabi you
know Fabi is one of the most principled
players who's so well prepared in
openings and we expect these theoretical
battles for him where he's got these
Amazing Ideas that he comes out with but
this is aggression sabi is actually
playing in the style of his own opponent
that he faces today he's gone all out
with G5 H5 and Robert as far as I can
tell there are all of just four games
that have happened in this particular
position after H5 if we just back up one
move when Fabi took the call to go all
out with G5
this position itself gets pretty rare
but after the move G5 where you kick the
bishop out black usually does that to be
able to unpin his Knight and jump
forward immediately with Knight E4 and
the game continues in many different
ways here but in fact H5 this is
relatively a super new position Richard
is the one who usually surprises Us in
the opening this time he's on the
receiving end of that and we see him
having a thing you're asking how should
one respond to this uh Robert I am as
lost as you are one thing is clear that
this is a critical moment you need to
take a call do you want to push that H
Pawn do you want to immediately Target
Black's play with a move like H4 asking
him to decide asking him to take a
decision what he wants to do create more
weaknesses because yes you can go G4
after H4 but take a look at that H4 G4
you create so many dark squared
weaknesses and this is not what Fabi
want what Fabi wants to play here is to
go for Knight to E4 come on and attack
that Knight on C3 attack that Bishop on
G3 it is terribly tricky for white
right because you would like the pawn to
capture back the H Pawn if The Bishop's
capture on G3 but now your knight on C3
is under attack twice and you defend it
so if you make a defensive move Knight
G3 Pawn G3 you see a pretty ugly Pawn
structure so for now it might be
acceptable for black it says it's just
assuming for white just a slight
disadvantage but in general this is not
at all what you want E3 is weak G3 is
weak they're going to be targets so uh
it's a really clever opening Choice H5
not exactly hiding his intentions to
push his Pawn to H4 and if you make some
kind of quiet movie A3 attacking the
bishop then black takes on C3 and after
this plays H4 the bishop is not trapped
it goes into E5 but then a simple move
like Knight to D7 or C6 I think Knight
D7 makes more sense because the Knight
C6 will be pinned by Bishop to B5 so you
put Knight D7 that way if you try to pin
I block the pin and I'm just threatening
to take this bishop on E5 so I don't
think black really has huge problems if
you get this dark Square Bishop off the
board because those weaknesses you're
highlighting Tanya are on the dark
squares
really astonishing opening here by black
and I am loving it absolutely I just
wonder if it's fabi's result from
yesterday against Jordan that has
brought about this Innovative play in
the opening where he's making his
intentions super clear he's ambitious in
today's game
it certainly is and maybe he has
Confidence from the win yesterday maybe
he just knows that sometimes Richard he
himself claims that he doesn't know
openings very well that despite the fact
that he's creative he sometimes is
creative because he's not sure of what
to do and he's a superstar player one of
the best in the world but here he took
his time and in fact played the move H4
so for Fabi it's time to jump that
Knight into E4 and white does have the
move Knight to E2 that defends both the
Knight on C3 and defends the bishop on
g3s you could take back with a piece
rather than the F Pawn so uh going to be
interesting to see how this one
continues here but I would be worried if
I were five in a car want his opponent
and he is just blitzing out moves
I'll tell you one thing about Richard
he's Fearless a yes US male models would
be shaking right now saying fabigo G5 H5
out of the opening but Richard will take
it head on and that's what he shows with
his approach he took a little bit of
time but he went for what appears to be
the most logical way to handle Black's
over aggression on the king side he went
for H4 and Fabi uh has replied with the
move he hasn't has he yet played Knight
E4 yeah 94 92 and Bishop G4 is all moves
that the players are making and we can
see why Bishop G4 is played pinning this
Knight on E2 so Fabi continuing with his
preparation showing his aggressive
intentions here your let's make the move
A3 for example this is a huge blunder
you see uh the eval bar going Black's
favor because after Knight takes E3 your
Queen's under attacks you have to deal
with this and after Pawn takes there's
Bishop takes C3 check as if your only
move it doesn't lose all the pieces
Knight takes C3 here is where the pin is
exploited Bishop takes D1 wins the queen
for a couple minor pieces and then black
would have a winning advantage
this is already getting so scary for
white with all these pieces pinned the
Knight on C3 spinned with the King on
you one the Knight on E2 is spin with
the queen on D1 black having a knight on
e4 Bishop G4 Bishop B4 it looks like
massive play here with the black Army
but take a look at our eval bar it says
very clearly that white does have an out
here and White's doing fine and that's
simply because white hasn't done
anything wrong out of the opening white
also has played logically but Richard
needs to find the accurate move here now
to my eyes Robert one of the moves that
I would consider in this position is F3
because it looks like wait a second
you're hitting the Knight on e4 you're
hitting the bishop on G4 you're asking
black to take a decision on how you want
to respond what do you think Fabi has in
mind after that I think he's just gonna
take this bishop on G3 and after Knight
takes G3 back he can Retreat his light
Square Bishop if he wants let's say the
E6 and the claim is E3 is tender you
want to have this Pawn back on F2 you
want your Pawn chains because a pawn
chain is only as strong as its base Pawn
here the e3d4 chain has the E3 as the
base whereas the F2 part is much harder
for black to approach so the G3 Knight
is loose the E3 Pawn is loose black is
the one with a dark Square Bishop this
doesn't look very pleasant for white so
F3 is the move that I would play in a
Blitz game I would just make that move
because that way I save material another
option is to move your queen away to a
square like B3 we talked about it
yesterday that when a bishop leaves the
queen side the B7 Pawn or B2 for white
will be a loose but there are tactical
issues here what happens if say black
takes on E2 clearly it doesn't work out
I'm making a mistake but the point I was
trying to make is that the Knight on C3
is pinned and if that's the case and you
take back with your Bishop on E2 and
that's not the best move apparently
Knight takes G3 if you take with the
pawn on G3 the pawn structure looks bad
it's clear based on the engine's
reaction that white is just almost
winning here and it's because of Black's
lack of development the queen is putting
pressure everywhere in the center the
problem on the H5 Pawn the G5 Pawn so
that would be the reason why white has a
huge Advantage here despite the fact
that White's Pawn structure is the one
that looks bad the lead in development
is too much
and we see that Richard with his head in
his hands completely focused on the
position he is he does realize the
importance of this moment it looks like
he's under pressure but he does know
that he has to find the correct way
forward it can get worse for white
really quickly also he needs to evaluate
these things that you're mentioning that
you double up the pawn but you're still
fine you have the initiative and of
course once again Richard not shying
away from these combative ways of
meeting your opponent's opening ideas
goes for the move that you were
suggesting Queen to B3 and Fabi goes on
blitzing a witch is also an indication
for Richard that he's on the right path
because let's let's just zoom out for a
bit from what's Happening Here uh Robert
if your opponent comes with opening
preparation and you have no idea about
it you're taking your time making your
move slowly but your opponent keeps
playing fast at least you know that this
is something that he's checked and he's
checked because it's perhaps the best
line possible I think it's something to
worry about when you go into a game your
opponent makes makes these incredibly
fast moves and then you play something
and it puts your opponent in a think
tank that's when you need to start
worrying that I haven't made the best
response in the position
it's absolutely true and these two
players are friends they know each other
very well and Richard he's often his own
harshest critics he will win a game and
then put himself on blast be like oh I
didn't play well I don't I got lucky I
don't know what happened he's a very
modest person uh with that kind of dry
sense of humor that I really appreciate
and I it's very clear he knows way more
than he lets on sometimes and he still
knows the position but after Knight
takes G3 he's thinking here my automatic
reply my sense would be well I don't
want to ruin my Pawn structure so let me
take with my knight but yet he's
thinking and I believe Fabiano it's move
11 right now he has a bunch more moves
up his sleeve and his preparation has
not ended here he's still in the realm
of his prep and he'll probably developed
this night out to C6 to keep this bishop
defended and this tension by the way
between the G5 and H4 pawns it won't
last forever especially because the
bishop has been removed at some point
black will will threaten GTX H4 so I'm
curious to see how Fabi responds after
Richard finally makes his move
and Richard has to decide whether to
recapture with the pawn or the Knight
because that just completely changes the
Dynamics in the position it is one of
those critical moments which will go on
to Define how the middle game is played
out and how it progresses now Robert
with your analysis you have really
broken down a fabi's position and his
thought process but we have to ask you
we have to address the elephant in the
room here what's your breakdown of
fabi's haircut
you you know at first he was almost
unrecognizable to me and I've known
Fabiano for a long long time and he
usually you see the image that's on the
left hand side of the screen right there
uh you know he has the poofy hair but
now his hair is gone it's a close shave
to his head and maybe with the new year
he wanted a new Fabi but I just have to
save fabi's looking fresh he's looking
good he won that game yesterday so he's
playing well and you know for Richard he
is the opposite hairstyle he's growing
that out he looks good he was very
fashionable at the candidates different
uh Blazers the salmon colored uh attire
so this is going to be a clash I'm very
excited to see how this game develops
but if I'm Richard report right now I'm
not thrilled by the fact that Fabiano
has not just moved instantly he's gained
time you start with an hour and 40
minutes Fabiano has an hour and 44
minutes he has not thought once because
he's in his preparation
all right so there you have it chat
Robert approves of fabi's haircut and
Robert you will also approve of
Richard's recapture decision he finally
did go for the night capturing back on
G3 not ruining his Pawn structure
because if you do that you have to have
something concrete tangible to justify
it otherwise it just becomes a long-term
forever weakness so a good decision
thereby Richard capturing with the
Knight and Fabi of course blitzing it
out so it feels like he's still in prep
he knows what he's doing but for Richard
news is that it's a sign that he hasn't
gone wrong yet
that's true although the more time he
spends the you know more I have to
question is he still familiar with the
position and there's already a threat of
G takes H4 so if you're playing a bullet
game you'd probably rush out the move H6
G5 he wants to make sure this is good
because when the queen gets to G5 black
is ready to Castle long that king is not
going to cheat ever since Fabiana pushed
his Pawn to G5 and then to H5 over here
it was a clear indication that his King
will be vulnerable if he did Castle
short so he is likely to Castle long and
taking on G5 only helps the queen get
out the way so the king can go to C8 and
on the other side where is the white
king going to go it can't Castle
queenside except for the fact you're not
allowed to Castle through check and the
D1 square is covered and to Castle
kingside I don't think that's a good
idea because Black's pawns are already
forward and more pieces will come into
the attack so I feel like white will
have the less safe King and what's
interesting Tanya is we have the engine
evaluation off the side we don't have
the moves but we have the eval bar
suggesting that white is better do you
think Richard knows that white is
slightly better because he's thinking
which means he's likely not in uh very
extended preparation so I've I don't
know to my eyes it looks like black is
very active creating threats has the
bishop pair but the eval bar speaks the
truth right it doesn't lie so what do
you make of this dynamic
it's a tough one whether Richard knows
how good his position is or that he's
done everything right of course the
answer to that is he has no idea about
that but the one thing I feel about this
is that Richard is enjoying this opening
outcome these are the kind of positions
that Richard thrives on so even though
he is taking his time he isn't playing
super fast he doesn't need to you've got
so much time on the clock what are you
going to do save it and take it back
home this is the moment he enjoys
playing these kind of positions he
relishes them and I have no doubt that
despite Fabi playing fast and yes there
can be these psychological games where
he gets up after every move walks around
it can put pressure on your opponent but
I think Richard is unfazed by all of
that he is liking this opening outcome a
lot more than playing something that
would be a lot more strategic coming to
how does white respond that is
definitely a huge question here as you
mentioned the king is still in the
center the H4 Pawn is attacked Robert I
would didn't care with white if you took
on H4 you take my Pawn on H4 but what
kind of a pawn is that to start with you
double your pawns you also give my
knight a really sweet spot on F4 and I
would love to get that with the white
pieces so one of the approaches that
Richard could have here is to continue
with development and the move Bishop B5
comes to my mind I got a nasty little
trick if you're not careful for example
let's say you try to push my Bishop
output A6 you might be attacking it but
then I pick up your knight with a check
I go Bishop C6 and your bishop and B4
hangs after that so you don't have time
to play so slow moves and of course this
is not going to happen but let's say
after Bishop B5 you go become greedy and
take my Pawn on H4 I'm once again super
happy and I will just come back with my
knight take it to F4 Knight E2 comes to
mind
again I don't know if I want to start
with Bishop C6 but just to show my point
that I don't care about that H4 Pawn I
want to go on id2 I want to put my
knight on F4 and I am a happy camper
that's a really good point for the F4
square is probably more valuable than
the cost of a pawn that also puts
pressure on D5 so if this bishop comes
to B5 it's likely that you have to part
with your dark Square Bishop if you're
Fabiano and after Bishop takes C3 check
the queen can take back and there's
something useful about this setup for
Black The Rook can slide up to H6
defending the Knight on C6 and we see
the evaluation bar is like it's hovering
towards the middle saying it's about
even but nobody looks at this position
and say yeah this is just equal like
what is going on here it is a true mess
where now the H4 Pawn remains hanging if
you bring your knight to E2 this bishop
can even take it off the board so you
don't get that Knight to the F4 square
but at the same time Black's King is in
the center just like whites there is
pressure down the C file if hg5 happens
this H5 Pawn is isolated it's just a
position double edge chances for both
but I love an early Rook lift time you
don't get to see that very often
protecting the queen side all the way
from H6
that's a really cool move and especially
once you know that you're never going a
king-site gasoline because you've
already expanded that side it's a cool
way to develop your pieces while
defending them at the same time uh
Robert we are going to come back to this
while Richard's having a think how he
wants to progress in this position uh I
have to say that I love fabi's approach
it definitely promises to be a fiery
game but meanwhile there's also action
intense opening action on on the other
boards as well so let's let's just zoom
out for a second and take a look at what
the players are up to well the top left
Magnus Carlsen did go up a pawn just
like you were saying Tanya the queen is
on C2 for a niche and he gave up a Pawn
on D5 so nice you know we can dive into
that some more in a minute but as we
look around the horn at all the games we
have some closed positions some open
positions top right that position look
at those pawns doubled e-pawns for both
sides between ding the rent and
prognanda it's going to be about
jockeying for positioning with your
remaining pieces in the bottom right we
have a sicilian between Jordan Von
forest and gukesh and so we'll see some
fighting chests on that board for sure
every Sicilian is a good time right next
to them second from the right Vincent
kymer against arjunera geisi it seems
like a closed position Connect Four if
you will because Black's pawns all the
way towards that C4 Square it's a nice
Pawn chain but Vincent is going to try
to break down that chain in the future
and Wesley and Lavon that's in the
middle down there it looks like a
position where it's not a symmetrical
Pawn structure that promises a fight
all the boards that we're looking at
right now we know that today is going to
be a day of Fighting Chess just looking
at the the mindset that the players have
come in we saw Fabi with his crazy
opening of G5 H5 and we see Anish has
chosen the most dynamic approach in that
position against uh against Magnus
sacrificing a pawn I also really like
arjun's approach in this one but of
course you were mentioning The Connect
Four pawns but the drawback of that as
we can see the second board to the right
is that your Bishop is always dead so
arjun's got a little development
problems there but I think the one game
we should Deep dive into is the Prague
versus dingler and match up it's such a
clash of generations and I think it's a
huge opportunity for Prague he's never
played against ding before so it's going
to be interesting to see how he
approaches this game against one of the
greatest players of modern chess yes so
why don't we dive into the game between
dingly Ren and prognananda uh that
position is an interesting one where
both sides have doubled Pawns in the
center and the e-file is very clogged so
that's interesting to note so let's talk
about the pros and cons for each side I
guess we could just show how we got here
it's from the Italian game where white
put a bishop on E3 and then black put a
bishop on E6 so we see that this is all
stator that's why I'm fast forwarding
these moves have been played many many
times Bishop came to E6 we saw a trade
and white put a bishop on E3 to shut
down the bishop on A7 so Tanya in the
live position uh what I was about to
get at and ask you in fact is with Queen
B3 the pawn on B7 is not under attack
just to show that if you make some
random move that the queen just gets
trapped over here so it's not about
individual threats so much as is finding
a plan what is it you like about ding's
position what do you like about prog
station because to me if I just saw this
position for the first time I feel like
I would think it's very equal because
the pawn structure is the same
and it is probably equal but you know
very often in chess terms when we say
equal
we might think that this will end in a
draw but this position is anything but
that it still has so many factors to
play for as you mentioned this Pawn
structure makes it super unique the
reason why players are happy in this
Italian to trade off the Bishops and get
these double pawns is because of the
squares that they control in the center
Robert the for black to be able to
control the F5 and the D5 square and for
white to make sure blacks Knights never
get into F4 are important points what I
like is like already on the open file on
f8 and why it always has to be careful
of keeping that Knight defended out of
nowhere we've often seen sacrifices like
imagine Knight H5 Rook F3 coming in if
white ever got rid of that Knight on F3
and it can be very dangerous for white
to handle this position with the King
open the other point to note as you
pointed out is that the B7 Pawn cannot
be picked up because your queen gets
trapped and one of the big ideas for the
players in this is to try to break in
the center now that you've reinforced it
with the spawn structure you want to get
in D5 white wants to get in D4 at the
right time so even though the eval bar
currently gives an equality it's a very
dynamic position and once it opens up
it's anyone's game
as far as how would we conclude the
opening outcome
I would say that proc should be happy
with the way the opening is gone I think
he's feeling comfortable in this
position it's a long game also ding has
no reasons to be not pleased with it
because the game is what he wants and it
is uh it's gonna be fun to watch this
one but this is going to be slow to
develop it certainly will be and well
Prague now that he's been leaning in
that almost like hurts me to watch I
feel like he's a contortionist there uh
he's really trying to dive into the
position almost literally uh but there
are so many nuances that Tanya was just
highlighting who's going to strike in
the center first it is almost definitely
going to be white because if black
starts with the move D5 here that's part
of the plan right but after he takes D5
e takes D5 both sides have undoubled
their pawns but there's this move E4
which is just frustrating to see because
the pawn on D5 is pinned and not just
that the Rook honey one now is perfectly
placed because it's going to stare at
this Pawn on E5 so you have to be
careful before you push in the center
like this and for ding on the other hand
let's say black plays the move H6 to
take away Knight G5 jumps you are ready
to play D4 you have your Center under
control your knight protects the E4 Pawn
you have a nice expand ended Center and
there may not be a threat at the moment
but at some point you could take on E5
and then both sides will have double
isolated pawns but white may be able to
jump with a knight to C4 and things of
that nature and
you need to keep an eye on B7 we keep
saying you can't capture right away your
queen gets trapped that is true but if
you stop looking at it and you you know
Keep Your Eye Off it forever you may
just lose it at some point if you're not
focused
so it might be equal but it's probably a
little more equal for white than for
black simply because white is able to
strike in the center first with D4 and
we see Prague having a think at this
moment he doesn't need to defend B7 but
he still has to make a move and how does
he improve this position that he has
unable to play D5 which would be ideal
as you pointed out due to the reason of
the pin along the A2 G8 diagonal Prague
is having a thing and uh Robert while he
does that we also see a huge crowd there
behind him having a look at the games
and that is the Festival of I can say it
is we've got the amateur section the
Challenger section the best in the world
playing in the Masters and the playing
arena is always bustling with Spectators
it is and some of those Spectators are
also players themselves and they might
be competing in one of the amateur
sections this is a huge Festival in
Vikings a year in and year out since
1938 they have had this tournament in
vikon Zay featuring the best players in
the world and I love the mix of young
players the rising stars and the
established players uh we've been
discussing this game right here dingley
Wren number two in the world prognanda
may be number two in the world in a few
years but right now just a teenager with
many successes to his name and he's
proven himself over the last couple
years especially in the online format
dingly red beat him in the chessful
Masters finals but just to get to the
finals of the Champions chess Tour event
that means you're taking down the likes
of Anish giri or Shakura mamajarov or
Lavon aronian or Fabiano caruana you
name them that's you have to get through
to make a final in a knockout bracket so
pragnanda he is really strong and right
now he is extremely concentrated so I
will leave him to think about this
position because he's trying to to
figure out is D4 coming when can I get
D5 and myself should I do something
about this Pawn on B7 should I push the
B6 it now we're in the future so there
are a lot of small details here that
play a big part and so let's go to our
bird's eye view look at all seven games
because Tanya in the bottom left I see a
rook on H6 for Fabiana caruana
and this is what you wanted I've been
saying it throughout the event that you
just know Fabi so well you're able to
predict his moves and call out his
action well in advance and this just
goes on to show that you were on point
with this idea of The Rook lift super
interesting and also just above that
take a look at our big featured matchup
of the day with Anish with the white
pieces taking on Magnus playing
fearlessly he's already sacrificed upon
that the queen has gone all the way to
F5 and this is a position that is going
to be
a thrilling middle game uh to watch and
to analyze a Robert and I think we
should
we should jump to that uh we see Anish
there on our screen
completely focused there a big moment
there in this game he has made the move
E4
yes he made that move uh E4 and he is
down a pawn is Anish giri uh he is going
to have compensation because he is
leading in development Black's King is
still in the center but this still is in
the realm of a theoretical discussion I
think we exited the main lines uh we are
in a position that hasn't played too
much but if we go back in time Tanya you
called it with Queen to C2 that was
anisha's choice and you said that
there's this move D5 it did happen in
this game black is able to take here
because after Queen E4 check the Knight
is defended by the bishop on B7 so you
don't have to move the Knight away
you're not going to lose a piece after
Queenie for a check well I can simply
block with the queen as well offer trade
trades favor the side with more material
typically so instead we saw Castle
Bishop E7 normal development Rook D1 and
this clever move I've always liked this
move in particular Knight C6 because it
looks like it blunders a piece on D5 but
after Rook D5 Knight B4 thank you very
much for the material
yeah that's a nice little trick that
gives black the tempo to develop his
pieces without having to return the
Knight on D5 and a very thematic idea in
it that of course Anish is aware of and
he made the move Queen to F5 immediately
jumps out of that [ __ ] radar on B4
now the Knight on D5 is under pressure
Magnus falls back taking it to F6 and
you want to take it to F6 because
imagine if you went Knight to C7 one you
take it away from the King side and
don't forget that D7 weakness you still
can't go shock Castle because the Rook
on D1 and the Queen on F5 really
pressure that pawn so Knight F6 makes a
lot of sense a good Retreat there
bringing the Knight closer to the king
side defenses unleash Unstoppable goes
E4 with a huge idea if Magnus does go
shot Castle he wants to keep advancing
that pawn put more pressure on black E5
would come in and this is bad news for
black so Magnus has to still waste
another move before he can get his King
to safety and D6 has been played now
this is not a new position Robert it has
occurred before these are thematic lines
and once again lots of options here for
white to proceed one of the critical
moves that Anish is thinking about is
the move E5 immediately striking in the
center when you've sacrificed upon time
is of the ascent you have to make the
most of your momentum you can't give
black the opportunity to just do
everything as and when he pleases and
get coordination with the pieces so
Knight C3 is not a bad move I think but
the critical line here that we need to
look at and that I know is going through
anisha's mind is striking in the center
with the movie five E5 looks very he
reaches out he reaches out and he makes
a draw but he goes for it yeah I I
didn't make that move I was about to
grab the pawn and then it left my hand
and went to E5 so that was a niche
playing E5 so the knights under attack
the pawn on D6 is pinned if you take on
E5 you simply lose your queen and you're
going to lose the game so instead black
okay I was about to say it and we'll
just let the players do our jobs here
Queen D7 and this is magnus's point the
queen stares at the queen on a five
which is undefended if you take on D7
the Knight that is under attack gets to
take back it's not the end of the story
because white takes on D6 gets that pawn
back the bishop slides out to F6 so the
question becomes is this a strength this
Pawn on D6 uh at first it looks like a
healthy past Pawn with a rook protecting
it that's great but if you gave black
one turn so I'm gonna make some move
like H3 you see the evaluation turn in
Black's favor the king castles to the
queen side this Knight can come to D4
and this Pawn is not a strength anymore
it's actually a liability it's isolated
it's foreign enemy territory it's
overextended and with some trades this
Pawn will fall just like Richard reports
Pawn against no deer Beck Abdus atarov
in the first round so Tanya if we get
this queen Swap and E takes D6 I believe
white needs to throw in a check on E1 so
the black king can't Castle but it
doesn't change the dynamic white may be
doing well for the moment but this Pawn
on D6 it's either a great Pawn a
potential queen or it's going to fall
victim to Black's pieces and then black
may even be able to go up material
this is an amazing position an
incredible
striking with E5 and we also see on the
clock that Anish has taken a lot of time
already he is down to an hour and 18
minutes while Magnus has kept up the
pace he has uh he has taken less time
than a nation that's because he was the
one who came up with this idea of going
for Queens Indian then this bishop A6
line I do really like that Anish went
for the dynamic approach but the
drawback of that is that he needs to be
super precise and even though it's a
classical format and the players have
enough time they need to be careful
Robert because they've often seen in
critical moments somehow when the clock
goes low mistakes happen and those are
super decisive the players currently
have got 1 hour and 40 minutes for the
first 40 moves if we just take a look at
the time format of the tournament and
hour and 40 minutes for the first 40
moves after which they get and
additional 50 minutes
for the next 20 moves and then 15
minutes for the rest of the game they
also get 30 seconds per move Robert but
still it might seem like a lot of time
but we've seen this again and again that
at that very end when they're trying to
reach time control things can go wrong
when you're playing on seconds and
you've just got a few minutes left so
Anish needs to be aware of the clock
right now yes and he is trying to figure
out if the queen trade is going to be
good for him he knows he'll get his Pawn
back but as we were just discussing
that's a pawn that is far in enemy
territory and it could actually be one
that will slip away from you so let's
zoom out from this game we still have
all seven games just hitting up getting
underway and as we look across our
screen here uh we see that Brooklyn from
Fabiano that's fun uh Parham and Nordic
Abdus atarov that's the second from the
left and the bottom row uh that position
it's quiet not a single piece has been
traded so I think we can stay away from
that for the moment but it will get
spicier as the game continues but for
now it's just a little bit too early uh
I think we should go to the game in the
middle there between Wesley so and Lavon
aronian because I just saw that Queen
slide into A3 uh for Lavon here and it's
one of these positions Tony it where I'm
almost wondering if we'll see an early
draw by repetition the eval bars has
white is only a smidge better and the
last move was Queen A3 and this bishop
just went to C3 to attack that Queen so
would you be surprised if Wesley goes
Bishop B2 then Queen to B4 and Bishop
back to C3 and queen back to A3
Wesley is a really practical player if
he feels himself uncomfortable in any
situation he does not mind going in for
that repetition bailing out of a
position
he doesn't enjoy getting into a mess if
he doesn't have that Clarity of the
evaluation of how he feels so it really
just comes down to how comfortable he is
but Robert answering your question I
would not be surprised if we see a quick
draw here while the players have a think
let's just take it from the top it was
an English opening and see how we got to
this point
it was in English with the Four Knights
and G3 so you can feed and Cato get your
Bishop to the longest diagonal D5
striking in the center while white plays
toward the flank and then we see a swap
and after Bishop C5 castles castles D3
we just have this reversed Sicilian
where instead of white playing E4 and
black playing C5 it's close reverse
which means an extra tempo for White and
the move was played H6 by Lavon we're
still in a normal looking position but
H6 itself you know this getting a little
bit rarer because D3 as well I don't
know if that's the main line so tell me
they're playing a very solid game thus
far with little moves here and there but
when we see B3 and E4 was played I feel
like it allows black to sort of uh show
his hand first
really nice that with the central brake
and one just gets the feeling that
blacks pieces have more activity after
E4 Levon took the decision sorry Wesley
took the decision to trade on e4 doesn't
want to keep that pawn alive Queen takes
E4 and Bishop B2
let's keep going black attack the queen
on D1 you move it to C1 the bishop on C5
is hanging Levon decided to save it with
the queen and queen came to be four
Bishop C3 this is the position that we
have Robert I have a question for you
let's say Wesley does feel that Black's
pieces are really active and in his
heart he's okay to play the move Bishop
B2 and repeat
but it's also a bit awkward right I mean
you're playing with the white pieces and
you want to create your chances and
you're at this stage where the world is
watching nobody wants a quick draw the
common data is the Players The
Spectators just no one wants them
how would you feel in Wesley's situation
would you would you say that you know
what the position looks equal it's
unclear I'm gonna play a long game or
would you have the approach tomorrow's
the rest day
I think black's gotten out of the
opening without a problem I'm just gonna
bail out of this one and I'm not playing
for the spectators I'm playing for
myself here yeah just to go back to when
B3 was played in move 10. E4 seems like
an impossible move there's a bishop on
G2 and a queen on D5 so in most
situations like instead of H6 uh or
sorry instead of B3 if I make the move
A3 and you play E4 You're simply just
losing a pawn right I move my knight
back and the bishop pins the pawn to the
queen so B3 actually allows E4 because
if you play Knight D2 your Rook on A1 is
not defended so when the queen moves out
of this pin to a new diagonal The Rook
on A1 is loose and that allows black to
get out of the pan and then take on D3
next or play to move Pawn to E3 so
that's what
Wesley Allowed by playing B3 and once we
see this trade and a rook coming to the
open file I don't think I would blame
Wesley for repeating moves and the
reason why in the end game let's say we
get this trade black has this three on
two Advantage here and not that black is
better you see it says zeros but white
Advantage pawn veg is in the center and
that's usually good when many pieces on
the board when you're restricting the
enemy pieces but black can start
throwing pawns up on the queen side and
have an eventual advantage over here
with a pass pawn and that distracts
White's pieces to that side the bishop
on A3 keeps a rook out of C1 controlling
important squares of course this bishop
Run state will develop next so I feel
like black has the better chances in
this end game and that's why if I were
Wesley I would seriously consider making
a draw and to show you what that draw
looks like everybody's Bishop B2 Queen
B4 Bishop C3 back and forth I don't
think it's unreasonable I don't think
Wesley came into this game wanting a
draw with the white pieces but you have
to play the position in front of you and
I'm the biggest critic of draw offers
this is different this is making the
best moves in the position and that just
so happens to lead to a draw so uh
Wesley he is a person who is objective
he has a ton of respect for Levant by
the way because at the Olympiad he saw
Lavon as the leader of the team he said
that Lavon with his experience playing
for The Armenian Squad winning a bunch
of gold medals he sees Levon as just
this kind of historic figure of Chess
and he's not going to just make a random
move to play on if he thinks he is best
served by repeating moves he will do
just that
I completely agree with your analysis of
Wesley's approach in this position that
said if Wesley wants to continue I don't
think that he should consider trading
the Queens because that definitely ends
up in an unpleasant end game if I was
playing with the white pieces here and I
want to continue playing I would look at
options like moving the queen away from
a queen trade I think every ending would
be great for black given the peace
activities and the queen side majority
so move like Queen F4 comes to mind here
you want to get out of the queen trade
and make your queen active also
somewhere the bishop on C3 attacking G7
might give me some some possibilities to
continue the game let's just point out
that Queen F4 can be met by black
actually pursuing this queen you can go
Bishop D6 attack my queen on F4 and I
want to say that I still want to attack
you so I go Queen to H4 keeping my queen
on the king side and this could be
another way to end the game Robert
because here Wesley's not the one who
might repeat but Levon with the move
Bishop to E7 back to D6 back to E7 so
here we are finding all kinds of
repetitions on the board
yeah not something you see every day
early repetitions that uh just happen
this is spontaneous and for Wesley I
really don't think he's a player who
likes to take risks uh he has played in
so many top level events and he is a
player who makes early draws and
sometimes that's because he uh repeats
moves like in the Berlin against hiccard
Nakamura in every single rapid Chess
Championship event that they played but
also he doesn't want to risk too much
that's just how he plays he uses usually
maximizes his chances when he has the
edge and if he feels like he might
become worse he doesn't just say let me
make a speculative decision so I do
think that we could be heading towards
an early draw of this game allowing the
players to go to the rest day with two
points out of four games but for now as
Wesley Ponders his options we are going
to go to a break but before we do I just
want to give a shout out to in Civic who
gifted 500 Subs to to the channel so
that is super generous thank you so much
for that and well more chess is to come
on the other side of this break
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
hopes to have the answer he's been
moving very quickly in the early stages
of this round four game after winning
round three against Jordan Von forest in
today's action against Richard report
Bobina carwana has the black pieces he
sports that new haircut and Tanya I'm
loving his position with black I mean
just look at this activity with a queen
on G5 a rook on H6 protecting this
Knight on C6 and Richard's last move so
we left off after Rook H6 we saw that at
the corner of our eye he took on G5
which was a mistake it allows the queen
to get out to G5 and then Queen C5
played but he's trying to prevent black
from castling Queen side I think that's
the clear plan so if Castle's Queen side
Bishop takes Rook takes Queen takes a
seven at the very least you need to
calculate it but to my surprise it still
says black is much better
I feel like you're seeing a Fabi 2.0
version not just the haircut part Robert
but also this opening approach that he's
had against uh Richard the whole
position is just super weird if you look
at it and Fabi going all out with G5 H5
it does look like for now that it's
paying off now Richard's move Queen C5
is quite tricky as you're pointing out
it stops black from long Castle but not
just that one of the big threats that
Fabi has in the position is to go H4 and
make that G3 Knight super uncomfortable
notice how the queen from C5 even pins
the pawn on D5 because of Black's Queen
on G5 so the point is that now if black
does make the move H4 which would be
super tempting white has a really active
night jump with Knight to E4 and you hit
the queen and there's just no way that
black can capture on e4 because the
queen hangs and after this move white
can
because this would just lose the game on
the spot so you don't capture the the
Knight and let's say you move the queen
somewhere Queen to F5 or queen to H5 is
just not a move that you're comfortable
with especially I want to point out a
tactical trick with Queen H5 Robin if we
just go back
here you can take Bishop takes C6 which
would actually Force black to recapture
with the pawn because if you take with
the Rook to C6 you have a brilliant blow
tactics Galore here you pick up the Rook
with the check sacrifice your queen but
win it on the next move with the Falcon
F6 Knight F6 wins the queen so Queen C5
is such a tricky spot for the queen I
love how Richard is handling this super
weird position and I love the tactics
that you're showing us today it seems
like you were induced a puzzle Rush
beforehand because you're spotting all
these cool geometrical sequences and
Knight E4 is very nice uh the queen is
hanging on G5 so the pawn can't capture
so your instinct your first idea then
Queen F5 does look better because if
Bishop takes C6 that's a blunder Now The
Rook can successfully take back there is
no Knight F6 check at the end of any
variation so Queen C5 big choice for
Fabi does he play H4 allow the Knight to
E4 and then over to C2 three that's
where the Knight Will land or does he
try to Castle queenside we just showed
that Cass and queen side it may look
like Bishop takes C6 is a problem but it
turns out it is not a problem because
Rook C6 Queen takes A7 black just plays
H4 pretends like nothing happened you
hang upon on A7 who cares if you give a
check the king slides out to D7 it is
safe and sound we typically do not like
like our King in the center but that's
only if the enemy can attack us the King
on E1 on the other hand Rook will come
down to C2 this G2 Pawn will be loose so
castling kingside doesn't seem like a
good option either this doesn't look
like a good position Tanya for white so
I think if fobby Castle's Queen side
Richard will have to come up with a
different move maybe it is your knight
E4 anyway
tough tough position here for both
players just because of the kind of
opening approach that we've seen and
Fabi just seems like in this tournament
he's not a guy you want to mess with you
know Jordan gave him one chance
yesterday and there was no coming back
from it he sacrificed an exchange and
flawlessly beat Jordan took that only
decisive win from game three and look at
the kind of position he has with the
black pieces coming out of the opening
as you're pointing out and who can
forget the phenomenal run that he had at
the Tata steel Masters in 2020 a massive
score Robert of 10 points out of a
possible 13. he finished the tournament
two points ahead of Magnus Carlsen
that's not something you get to see in
the Chess World it certainly isn't and
he hopes you regain the form of 2020
because in 2022 he stumbled quite often
in the Olympia he lost many games you
don't see that from Fabiano caruana at
least the Carolina that we know and now
become accustomed to however he did have
some good events at the end of the year
in the world rapid Championship he
finished with the bronze medal tied for
second place with Vincent kymer third on
tie breaks got the bronze he had some
great Blitz tournaments getting his
rating over 2 800. he won the American
Cup and the U.S Championship two
classical events so there were some
positive signs but of course the biggest
heartbreak of all was the candidates
tournament we were talking about that
yesterday so Fabiano when he's informed
when he's motivated when he's getting
the prep that gives him exciting
adventurous positions he is somebody you
do not want to mess with and I think
Richard report is finding it out the
hard way right now look at the Clocks
Richard report is down to 58 minutes and
change it's only move 16 and this game
will remain complicated and Fabiano has
almost as much time as he started with
hmm and look at that we've got uh we've
got our audience saying Fabi has said in
the past he likes to go for these
sometimes objectively worse but trickier
opening this is definitely a tricky
opening and as far as we can see with
the eval bar that Richard has gone
slightly inaccurate and with that it
looks like it does favor Fabi so the
opening has paid off but don't be fooled
by the evaluation bar because this is
the kind of position that can jump
around super quickly we've been talking
about Fabi and wanting to make this
comeback the one thing that has stood
out as well uh Robert has been his
performance in Faster format just
recently finished the world rapid and
Blitz with two medals he won a silver in
the rapid a bronze in the blitz once
again correct me if I'm wrong but it was
just amazing to see him play that I was
playing there as well and Fabi was so
informed there and I think he comes to
Tata Steel
really feeling good about his chest and
of course we've been discussing uh the
legendary haircut I've still got mixed
feelings about that Robert this position
is not only a tactical battle but uh
yeah it's uh it's interesting to see
Richard on the screen and then Fabi on
the screen with their two polar opposite
hairstyles I'm kind of loving the whole
vibe here yeah I really didn't recognize
Fabiano at first like I I know that it
has he's a name tag there right we see
Carolina but in previous days when I
first saw it I was like whoa what
happened to him like you know did he
lose a bet and have to get the haircut
but it's just a different Fabiano and I
think he wants to take a new approach in
2023 he I mean he struggled in 2022 yes
no denying it he's been honest about it
he has his podcast with Christian uh
Trilla as the c squared podcast so he
has been vocal about you know needing to
improve his play and this would be a
great start to a new calendar year but
these players they're deep in thought
about this tricky position it's going to
be a tactical Affair so why don't we
zoom out as Richard is he's on the clock
once again he is down on time but we
have six other games that are very
interesting so Tanya I see in the top
left that magnus's King is on a f8 and
he's curious Pawn is on D6 so we do have
that queenless middle game that we're
anticipating
I think we should rush into it because
right now black is threatening a devious
Fork on the board night before has been
the last move the previous move by
Magnus and he's got a tricky idea that
Anish needs to watch out for and if we
just pull up that board rabbit I want to
take it from that moment where we left
it last because we were talking about
how black should not be allowed to bring
his gift King to safety with long castle
and let's just back up a couple of moves
when the queen trade happened and this
is a critical moment here Queen D7 a
nice choice by Magnus in a position that
can be super dangerous for the king
offers a trade Anish goes for it takes
the queen on D7 and after Queen decent
seven Knight captures it back white wins
the pawn back he wins that pawn on D6
and we were talking about this is this a
strength or is this a weakness in
White's position and I think the answer
lies in how energetic white plays again
if black is allowed to cast muscle to
bring a knight on D4 Black's going to be
super happy which is why I really like
anisha's next move he moves The Rook
from D1 gives a check saying that sure
I've got a weakness on D6 but it's not
going to be easy for you to coordinate
those Rooks it's not going to be easy
for you to finish a development but
there is a slight drawback to this move
which we find out just the next move
Magnus played King to f8 the Knight
comes out in development to C3 white is
threatening to jump in with the Knight
to D5 but Magnus comes in with a strong
response to this move jumping in with
his own Knight to B4 and now we see
because the Rook is on E1 Robert there
is a fork threatened on C2 so once again
whitecon simply developed the bishop and
get the harmony between those two Rooks
and look at how quickly Magnus is
playing so he started off with
preparation he slowed down a bit and he
steals ahead in the clock he's
threatening a huge fork with Knight to
C2 so you have to deal with that you
can't just play A3 and hope the Knight
runs away no that Knight's going into C2
then I can also go into D3 if you want
to Fork The Rook on E1 and the bishop on
C1 so even if you save uh The Rook by
sliding the A1 Rook to B1 to avoid this
fork and I just want to show that fork
on the board so everyone is clear about
it the Knight hits both Rooks at the
same time and so if you slide The Rook
to B1 to avoid that fork black can
consider going Knight D3 hitting the
Rook it slides to D1 which hits the
Knight and Knight C1 Rook takes C1 we
get a position where black has the pair
of Bishops a white has his Pawn on D6
and it's remains to be seen is black
going to play Rook d8 you made a very
good point Tanya the Rooks are not
connected you know it's a way to develop
a rook playing H5 Rook H6 just like
Fabiano caruana and then go after this
Pawn on D6 so you can learn from your
fellow competitors get a rook lift going
bring second Rook to d8 and I wonder if
that D6 Pawn is just going to drop and
if that pawn drops of course black is
much better but Anish is gonna do
everything in his power to keep that
pawn
Robert Anisha just made the craziest
move I mean if you would have asked me
to guess five moves in this position I
don't think that would have been one of
the moves that I would have taken up
take a look at what he's done here after
night before black is threatening a folk
and Anish ignores it jumps in with his
own Knight to E5 the whole board is
hanging the bishop on B7 hangs the
Knight on E5 hangs Knight C2 is still in
the air 95 this is a shocker and look at
Magnus there I don't think he was
expecting it either he's gone into a bit
of think there are so many things
possible in this position and my first
question is let's take a look at what
happens if black grabs that Knight if
Knight E5 white wants to pick up that
Bishop on B7 hit that Rook on it so you
still don't have time to go Knight C2
but now you can simply come in with the
Rook to d8 attack that pawn on D6 you're
threatening Knight D3 you're threatening
Knight C2
where is the niche going with this move
Knight E5
I think he's gonna have to slide his
Rook over to D1 if you continue the
variation to protect the pawn and avoid
the fork on C2 but the story doesn't end
there what if this Knight now comes into
C4 and attacks the pawn you would love
to play Bishop F4 to defend D6 but uh oh
down goes the B2 Pawn uh you don't want
to lose that one and if you play Knight
E4 try to protect the pawn as well and
attack the bishop you see the eval bar
drop and the reason why the pawn on B2
is hanging and black would steal this
Pawn the pawn on D6 looks like an
impressive passer it is not going
anywhere if it goes up to D7 great you
moved up a square your Rook is hanging
on D1 you don't have time for that it
means you have to take care of your Rook
where is it going to go if it goes up to
D2 to stay behind your pass Pawn the
Knight simply drops back to C4 with
another Tempo Against The Rook putting
pressure on the pawn on D6 an eventual
F5 may be in the cards or H5 Rook H6 to
develop your Rook this way black is up a
pawn and is thrilled to be in a position
like this so I would be very concerned
in that sequence and one last thing to
point out Tanya before you know I asked
you your thoughts about what we're just
looking at Bishop takes G2 would be a
huge blunder because white is not going
to take on G2 First Take on D7
Intermezzo with check the king can't
approach the e-file anyway goes to G8
then white takes the bishop and is up a
full piece
this is absolute Madness Knight E5 it
feels like a really creative way to cut
to this position and once again it's
just so nice to see Anish make these
choices we were looking at how you can
defend against the folk you know you can
go Rook to D1 Rook to B1 he says none of
that he's going to go for the most
combative approach in the position the
most enterprising move 95 literally the
board hangs here and Magnus with his
head and His Hands knows that this is
not something he was expecting has to
Now navigate through these variations
does he take on G2 he can't do that he
loses a piece as you're pointing out
does he take on E5 which piece does he
take on E5 with or does he go on to
maybe play Rook d8 maybe Knight C2 a lot
of interesting options here this is such
a critical game that we've got going on
and it's an absolute mess on the board
Robert for a niche this match means a
lot he's playing with the white pieces
against Magnus Carlsen Anish is an
ambassador of the Tata steel Chess
Masters he's come so close to winning
the event several times he's finished
second five times but the championship
eludes him and if he's able to create a
mess here Muddy Waters get Magnus in
them that would be a huge Victory on his
path to try and score the first
championship look at that graphic on the
screen you see Anish Geary the runner-up
five different times Magnus Carlson's
name is there three times as the
champion levonne Roni in 2014 Jordan Von
forest in 2021 and I think the most
impressive stat that I see is that since
2014 when he was runner-up for the first
time he has lost only seven out of 115
games in Viking Zay that is
extraordinary because Magnus Carlson
plays every year we were talking earlier
how the only time invite can say that
Anish lost a Magnus was in 2022 so
Anisha doesn't lose often in Vikings a
five-time runner-up that well you may
say he didn't win it he is gaining
rating points outperforming his
expectancy a score and he just he is
thriving in Vikings including this
tournament but 95 that last move I
understand the eval bar off to the side
says we're at zeros it's an equal game
but this is a dynamic position where I
feel like the biggest eyesore is this
Pawn on D6 and with Knight takes E5 as
we're talking about Bishop B7 Rook to d8
I just want to point out as well that
Rook B8 is remembered Bishop E4 it
covers the fork on C2 and you see the
eval creeping up in White's favor that
Rook DHS go for the pawn immediately
this Knight C4 jump I feel like it's
causing white so many issues on the
queen side and this Pawn D6 so I would
prefer to have the black pieces here
Tanya I'm not sure if we're missing some
easy find that a niche can have to
lessen his problems but I like this
position from an active standpoint from
Magnus
I'm still getting my head around the
fact that out of 115 games Anish has
only lost seven and why can't say that
is it that is insane just to even think
about it and uh I think the reason he's
not won the event many times he's been
unlucky on tie breaks in the playoffs a
couple of times but perhaps having too
many draws and that's been an issue for
him but still such consistent
performance finishing second at the
strongest event of the year five times
coming so close he's fought for the
Championships made it to the playoffs
twice it's been amazing to see him on
the stage this is where he shines this
is where he thrives and he is playing
against the world's best player today
and he's not backing down I think this
game is an answer to all Anish critics
who say that he plays for a draw and
that is not true at all that is such
surface level analysis I feel Robert
when you just focus on the result of the
game but not the way he's played the
game and just the way he's approached
this one 95 is the messiest possible
move that you can play against Magnus
here
it is yeah Knight to E5 it is you know
offering this Knight on E5 directly but
he's getting that important Bishop on B7
so we understand why he's going for this
variation Magnus is thinking but I don't
think he is calculating is he gonna play
Knight takes E5 Bishop takes E5 has
Merit as well but he's definitely going
to play Knight takes E5 and Rook d8 I
think he wants to play a quick uh series
of moves and then put a niche back on
the clock so while Magnus is really
calculating the future of this position
I think we can zoom out look at our
other games we have spent a lot of time
here deservedly so this is a matchup of
co-leaders and the world champion Magnus
Carlson and so as we look across the
screen here the game that catches my eye
itanya is the one in the bottom right we
have yet to dive into the game between
Jordan Von forest and goo cash but we
have a sicilian and only one side is
Castle that would be Jordan
and Gucci's King still on E8 the pawn on
D6 is loose so I feel like it's worth
diving into that one
let's check it out whenever we see a
king in the center we've got to go Gotta
Go have a look and see what's really
going on and why has black not managed
to Castle there it's of course a big
game for these two players they have
been struggling in the event so far
gukesh has been out prepared in most of
his games uh until now while Jordan has
been showing Amazing preparation but has
been missing small tactics out of the
opening we saw him blunder a pawn in a
move against Wesley then the same thing
happened against Fabi so if they want to
climb up on the leaderboard currently
these two are in fact targeting each
other
that's right you have to beat somebody
to climb the leaderboard and for Jordan
Von force with the white pieces playing
against gukesh who has struggled
mightily thus far he wants to get a win
with white he played E4 we're in a
sicilian and the pawn D6 was targeted
good cash defends it immediately with
Rook to d8 and when I look at this
position Tanya uh you know we can go
back and look at how we got here but the
thing that sticks out to me the most and
it may seem very inconsequential is this
Pawn on H6 people be like what are you
talking about who cares about this Pawn
on H6 but the reason I'm pointing it out
is because white often wants to attack
on the king side which is where black
can castle and with the pawn H6 when I
play G4 and G5 I am forcibly prying open
the king side you there's contact
between pawns I'm using as a hook and
the reason I mention this now is if we
backtrack and start from the beginning
we had a sicilian with D4 and at this
moment here the move Bishop G5 was
played and after simple Pawn pushes H6
the bishop ends up moving back so it
seems like you lost a Tempo in a sense
because black just kicked your Bishop
out and you went back to F4 but what
you've gained is this possible hook
forward attack D6 is threatened you
don't easily take it in many positions
because a rook comes the d8 but the
point is where is Black's King going to
go if you Castle kingside White is just
gonna throw all these pawns at the board
open the files of the Rooks
very nice way of illustrating how you
need to provoke your opponent to make
pawn move so that you can have hooks in
the middle game to blow up the position
open and put an attack on your
opponent's king now the position that
we've got with us the live board Rook d8
has been played so kukesh going to
centralize his rook and my first idea
that comes to my head for white which I
would be super worried to face is that
what if white does the same Robert you
want to also develop your piece let's
say you put the H1 Rook on E1 I want to
get it on the e-file and I've got an
I've got something Sly that I'm coming
up with let's say black plays the move
B5 here a very thematic way to try to
improve your queen side put some
pressure and I don't care I'm just gonna
jump in with my knight to D5 and tell
you that you know what you should have
thought about King's safety because if
you take my knight on D5 with the pawn
you open up the e-file I take e takes D5
hit your Bishop wherever you go with the
bishop let's say you go Bishop B7 I'll
have a check on G4 or a check on F3 your
king is in massive trouble and this as
we can see the eval bar does confirm is
something that black needs to watch out
if the king is in the center and I've
been saying this over and over Robert
that gkesh has been in trouble in the
openings so far in this event and I just
hope that that's not the case in this
game because this game is so important
for the two players who are currently at
the bottom of our table the case has got
half a point while Jordan has got one
point so so a win would really help them
and it also is what you need for your
confidence it's a long tournament every
game is going is only going to be
tougher and more difficult than your
last one so a win would mean a lot for
either of these two players and we've
got to Sicilian on our hands that means
that draw is the least likely result
that's true and in the line that you
were just talking about I came up with a
beautiful Checkmate so if this bishop
goes to B7 or A8 Queen takes B5 check
leads to check wow because you're in
check here your idea what my Queens take
a Queen Bishop takes B5 is not just
check once Queen takes B5 ah it doesn't
work because the Rook on E1 delivers a
second check and that is Checkmate so
the line that you were you know getting
us to with rook hce1 and Knight D5 a
thematic sacrifice in the center the
reason you sack is to go after that
exposed King and this would be one of
the best checkmate it's ever not from
kukesh's point of view but just From
chess's perspective
this is such an amazing line for
pointing out uh and Robert it doesn't
matter whether the bishop goes to B7 or
D7 the King on E8 would be badly placed
uh probably he has to go to D7 if we
just back up so that you don't have this
stunning idea with Queen B5 but this
still looks like bad news with the
bishop F3 check coming in and the only
way to fight it is Bishop to E7 and if
nothing else you can just grab the pawn
on D6 and win the piece back and go on
to win the rest of the game so rookie
one is definitely something that Jordan
is thinking about right now needs to
watch out for it after that move I think
the most sane way for black to play
would be to continue with development
you make the move Bishop to E7 and say
you know what I need to make my king
safe before I go after your own King
with the move B5 that can come later on
what's interesting about Bishop E7 is
Queen G3 there still is problem for the
black king because if you Castle you
walk right into a pin down the G file
Bishop takes H6 thank you very much I
I'm winning material so the attack you
know is going to rage on the board
Robert is on the board Rook hu1 so we
know what he's setting up it's very
clear he wants Knight D5 so Bishop E7 as
Tanya was suggesting it blocks the E
file so Knight D5 no longer is very good
you can just take this Knight and after
Pawn takes back you have no discoveries
because the bishop blocks the check in
advance so Knight D5 will not be played
but Queen G3 is an option Pawn pushes H4
and G4 look appealing as well but after
Queen G3 in particular you're hitting D6
in addition to G7 so gukesh has a lot to
figure out here there will be tactical
shots as king is in the center so Jordan
he's playing some enterprising chess but
if gukesh is accurate we can see based
on the evaluation bar he should be okay
it's just not an easy position to figure
out so there could be dynamic equality
but keyword Dynamic you're going to be
on the edge of your seat for the next
bunch of moves
even though the eval Bar says that black
is fine it is super scary to be in this
position the error of margin is so
little you could end up just completely
dead lost busted if you don't play the
accurate moves here you're pointing out
all these ideas with queen G3 after
blocking the E5 they still look super
scary and once again I'm worried for
gukesh look at the clock as well he's
burnt so much time navigating this
opening once again makes you feel that
he's not in familiar territory and has
he been surprised has he been taken into
troubled situations with the opening
itself and that would be something that
would be disheartening to see uh Robert
also difficult psychologically for him
he needs he needs to keep his cool he
needs to keep his calm and he has to be
super precise right now with that King
in the center all of White's forces
develop Knight D5 in there Queen G3 in
the air this can be difficult for black
going into the middle game while gukesh
navigates these complex like cities
let's zoom out take a look at the other
action because Robert we've got such big
matchups and there's fire on the board
in so many of them and look at that
bottom left with Richard against Fabiano
that Bishop on G4 he's just captured
he's just traded a piece there fabi's
gone for the idea with long castle that
we were pointing out right now so much
in the air with the Knight jumping on to
E4 this is a fun position on top of that
we've got the Magnus Anish game where in
fact the line that we were discussing
has happened Magnus did decide to take
the Knight on E5 and currently pieces
have been traded but look at that pawn
on D6 it feels more and more like a
weakness Black's piece activity looks
massive here
yeah it does I think we should go to the
game between a niche and Magnus because
we got some good information about this
game uh the position after rookie one
check Bishop F uh King to fa excuse me
Knight C3 night before this exact
position Magnus Carlson has had in his
game before from the year 2008 the big
thing though is Magnus was white in the
game we see the feature chat thank you
so much BMN for that information uh this
magnus's experience in it but he was
white and when you're preparing for
somebody you may not look at their games
with the color that you have versus the
color that they're going to have so
Anish has probably seen that game before
especially when you study an opening you
look at the best players who play it
surprise surprise Magnus Carlsen is the
best player uh but in that game Bishop
G5 was White's choice and after Bishop
G5 I guess the point is 9 C2 can be met
by Bishop F6 and after Knight takes F6
you give up the rook in the corner with
Rook E7 because if you get this bishop
Knight E5 the F7 Pawn it's a very tricky
position where you know a lot is
happening so many pieces are on pretty
wow that is an amazing piece of
information that our chat has given us
that Magnus had this position back in
2008 that's more than 14 years ago and
that's uh that's very fascinating to
know I wonder if Anish was at all aware
of this is 95 something that he might
have looked at at some point or is it
over the board inspiration
but whatever it is it does feel like
Magnus is doing fine in the current
position that we have after Knight E5
Magnus decided to take on E5 Bishop G5
which was what happened back in 2008 did
not happen Anish came up with this idea
uh to go 95 the trades happened Magnus
moved the Rook to the d8 square to
attack D6 a niche saving himself from
the fork and defending the D6 Pawn makes
the move Rook to D1 now I see our eval
bar it seems to say that things are
still fine but from an from a practical
perspective I really like these two
knights but once again it's all about
timing black has to play energetically
here because don't forget that King on
f8 and The Rook on h8 is just completely
out of the game you have to keep
creating threats to win that pawn on D6
and how are you going after it Robert
are you considering a move like Knight
C4 right now absolutely and I think you
know we're looking at some positions
before Knight E4 doesn't work because
the B2 Pawn is hanging the bishop will
be happy to see the Knight leave the
diagonal Bishop F4 hangs the pawn
directly with Knight takes B2 so D7
process of elimination but I was
thinking can blood just bring the king
up to E7 and win the pawn and now that I
look at it Bishop C8 is available to
White you protect your past Pawn by
bringing your Bishop to the eighth rank
you don't get a promotion you don't get
a new Queen but the bishop and pawn are
connected with one another and that
looks annoying because how are you gonna
get that Bishop out of there Knight D6
would be the way to attack the bishop
here but it's not the end of the story
because you can check this King back to
f8 and you're pointing out the problem
with having the king and the Rook
disconnected over here let's say I give
this check the King goes back to f8 I
think white can get away through Knight
E4 getting rid of this pesky Knight
which just trying to take the bishop
because if you take the bishop after
Pawn takes Rook takes Knight F6 gf6
Bishop H6 check uh this King this Rook
they're never getting out and it's
probably just a Checkmate if I can get
my Rook over the G file so or Rook to
the eighth rank this is just completely
hopeless for black
Bishop land on eight six that is game
over let me show you another fun line
how it can do that Robert let's just
back up to show the kind of dangers in
Black's position with this King on f8
the moment that often Knight E5 let's
say you go Rook D1 which is on the board
right now if Knight C4 is played we are
looking at D7 and you were pointing out
that the drawback of these seven is that
it allows black skin to come out connect
the Rooks hit the pawn on D7 but then
This brilliant move that you spotted
with Bishop C8 defends that pawn on D7
and if Knight D6 I love the idea of
rookie one hitting that King King f8 you
were showing this line Knight E4 and now
you mentioned this move Knight C8
because obviously if you trade on e4
you're never getting to that Bishop
you're never getting to that pawn on D7
so that's not what you want Knight C8
and instead of taking that Knight on C8
as you were saying why does the
alternative to pick up the bishop on F6
and take a look at this it is super cool
if you grab the Knight back on F6 I
still don't care about your night I
don't see it I go Bishop 86 check King
to G8 come in with my rook and give you
a mate on it rookie it rookie it I
promote who cares about promotion
because I'm gonna make a rook not a
queen under promote and give you a
checkmate
wow that is a beautiful see you guys and
you know we're looking at beautiful
checkmates can white play rookie one
does that work no uh I was like I was
like okay pushing it if you take and I
go King G2 I'm threaten you both to take
and promote but I guess there's the move
like Knight D6 wow and then when you get
the queen there's Knight E8 The Rook
survives it protects and his Knight
defense F6 and G7 so I was just you know
trying to be too clever for my own good
it would appear so it doesn't look like
white isn't you know do it too badly
because this king is almost gonna get
checkmated but it clearly doesn't work
out the evaluation Bar says Robert go
away let's go back to the position
because none of this has happened likely
none of this will happen but then it
begs the question is Knight C4 actually
a good decision because D7 Bishop C8
looks kind of annoying now that we've
been analyzing it
that was a stunning line that you showed
it may not work but these ideas exist in
these end games where you sacrifice and
you're promoting and hitting the night I
love it Robert and maybe maybe you know
we've been talking about Black's piece
activity but if Knight C4 runs into
these lines with D7 and you're not
winning the D6 Pawn
I think we've been underestimating
anisha's play
I think so as well I mean Anish now is
playing more confidently the clock is
about even so Magnus is aware this is a
critical moment he needs to find the
right way to stop this Pawn uh White is
the side with the pair of Bishops you
have two Bishops here there are no more
Forks Knight C2 The Rook just slides
away and while this Knight can go to the
D4 Square to shut off this Rook on D1 I
think the problem is that white is going
to open a new flank The Rook on B1 moved
here just to avoid a fork but now you
have this move B4 please take me on
before that loosens your control of the
D4 square if you just take a Pawn on D6
that's what you'll be going after I
think at some moment there's gonna be a
bishop A3 the B file opening looks
terrible for black as well and just
simple chest at this point is King on a
f8 this Rook on h8 you've been correct
to call them out they are not in the
game the pieces are not coordinated and
that's a big problem for black
wow is Magnus Carlsen in trouble we look
at him on the camera he definitely looks
a little
a little worried about his position he's
been having a long thing so far he's
taken about 13 minutes we're on move 20
here and both players have burned about
the same amount of time on the clock uh
Magnus though knows it's a critical
moment for him because
yes he has peace activity but no
development white has a Pawn on D6
anisha's got the two Bishop Advantage if
Magnus isn't able to navigate into some
complex variations where he can win the
Deep on back he might just be a lot
worse in the next few moves and there we
see Anish not on his chair walking
around
comfortable with what he's achieved out
of the opening and it all comes down to
taking the approach of sacrificing a
pawn and not fearing against the world
champion
nice approach there seems to be working
out while Magnus has a think in this
important decision we will come back to
see what he makes up his mind to do but
let's zoom out and take a look on our
other boards that we've got going on
Richard rapper versus Fabi is the other
big game with Fabi currently one of the
five leaders and uh of course we've all
been amazed with fabi's opening approach
as well in this one let's take a look at
how the game has progressed because
we've had quite a bit of development
there yeah we have but before we go to
that game we're going to look at one
game almost certainly for the last time
the game between Wesley so and LaVon
aronian in the middle on the bottom row
there it's an end game opposite color
Bishops so we'll just pull the game up
for you all so you can see where we're
at and it is just very level maybe black
is even slightly better because of the
extra Pawn on the queen side White
having an extra upon the center but the
players know that this is a draw they're
on move 27 so I expect the next few
moves to happen relatively quickly and
for the players to split the point Lavon
with the black pieces yesterday against
Arjun Eric icy he spoiled in a sense a
chance to win that game
yeah
you know wrong
um excuse me the he just let it slip
away from him and a tough end game but
he had his chances and now here with the
black pieces he's had no problems
against Wesley
and both players so far have had a solid
start but obviously I'm not super
surprised Robert with the way that this
game has gone it's been even from start
to finish after that move B3 uh which we
saw Levon was able to break in the
center with E4 and equalize out of the
opening the players have played each
other so many times this is a matchup
that we've we've seen happen several
times and take a look at their score uh
Head to Head
if we can pull that up we see that
they've had 16 draws so far and
currently
Levon leads we just with three wins and
two wins for Wesley so extremely level
match up this one very often we've seen
them play against each other but not get
much out of the opening Wesley is such a
solid player it's kind of hard to get
anything against him and very pragmatic
in his decisions as well when he thinks
things are going out of control he does
tend to bail out and go for the solid
approach as you were mentioning the
position that we have it's a narrative
we've seen between them plenty of times
I think we're heading for their 17th
draw
we are indeed but both players would
love to win the tournament overall they
have won the tournament in the past
Lavon four times Wesley so once in 2017
and it's just one of those games where
Lavon showed good preparation he was
able to strike in the center and then
liquidate and Wesley to his credit he
didn't just make the draw when the
opportunity arose if we go back to this
point with the queen coming to A3 he
decided to swap Queens but there wasn't
much of anything here black develops the
White Knight dropped back and we saw in
uh Levant go forward with his Knight
attacking this Pawn on E2 with a check
and a fork so we just got a series of
Trades now the pawn on B7 cannot be
captured as The Rook comes a d8 with a
pin and a win of a piece so we saw the
Knight come out to C4 and that's where
we got our opposite colored Bishops we
see it trade on C4 we see a trade
happening on D6 and then it's just even
material Bishops of opposite color so
there's no real way to press because
black controls the dark squares white
controls the light squares and now that
the Rooks are coming off they will it
will be accompanied with a draw for
and there we see that happen as you
speak Robert King died a pure opposite
color Bishop m game equal pawns this one
will end in handshakes really soon and I
think it works out for both players
they've they're currently on one and a
half points a draw would mean a 50 start
in the first segment of the tournament
going into the rest they uh and as you
very well know that Lavon had such a
marathon game last evening against Arjun
so nothing to be displeased about both
players can take some happiness from
this draw well at least they get an
early evening to enjoy meanwhile a lot
of enjoyment on the other boards as well
so let's zoom out and bring some of the
action that we've got going on once
again for me I do notice by the way that
Richard rappo has just retreated with
the queen currently Knight has gone to
E7 so this position Still Remains very
much live very much kicking and I think
we should deep dive into that one uh wow
we've had a queen trades already
yes we actually have so uh we'll pull up
the game between Richard and Fabiano
because that game also has liquidated
and we may be heading for a peaceful
result that's a bit surprising given the
uh what was happening earlier but we saw
the move A6 and the bishop retreated to
E2 and then black Castle Queen side so
we saw a trade on G4 the queen took back
just trying to be menacing kick this
Knight out hit G2 but what Richard did
is
give himself the opportunity to trade
Queens if H4 were played that would be a
bad move because Queen F5 is check
forcing the queen trade and with a fork
of Knight and actually have rook and
pawn with the Knight on F5 so instead of
H4 it's a 97 stopping the check here but
Queen E2 forces the Queens off in a
different way H5 is loose so if you move
the queen away The Rook can capture on
H5 that's why the Rook move to the H
file the queen trade happened we see
trades The Rook comes to C1 the king to
D7 and so when all is said and done when
the smoke has cleared it's moved 23 King
D7 as the last one played we haven't
even end game right both sides with a
rook Knight and six pawns but that
doesn't mean the game should necessarily
be a draw black has an extra Pawn over
here on the queen side there's four
against three white has an extra Pawn on
this side of the board with three
against two but it's harder for white to
move the pawns I believe and black
position just feels very sturdy I don't
see a way in for either side but perhaps
these pollens can Venture up the board
and you can play on if you'd like but I
would not be surprised if this point is
split in the near future
I won't be surprised at the point to
split but I'll be surprised if it
happens soon Robert because I still
think there's something to play for in
this position the points that you
mentioned with black spawn structure
having more Mobility than white Also
let's not forget the Rook on 86 on the
open file sort of ties down White's King
you can't get too active with the King
because there are always threats like
group H2 G2 is a potential weakness in
White's position that can be attacked
now fabi's played a nice little move
night to see it it's a retreating move
and what he wants to do is he wants to
reroute the Knight to D6 where you end
up controlling more squares you're
threatening more more ideas with the
move Knight C4 attacking B2 if white
isn't careful the Knight might jump to
E4 imagine Knight D6 F5 the pawn comes
down the board you get 94 in at some
point it can get tricky for white I
think Fabi isn't done trying yet it
might not be enough and our eval Bar
says it's even it again I I feel it's
more even for black than it is for white
black can enjoy playing it easier than
white can it feels White's forces are
not coordinated the king is stuck to
defending G2 the Knight on G3 on one
side of the board The Rook on C3 on the
other side of the board the knight from
G3 can currently jump to F5 but what
does that get you Robert you go Knight
F5 I hit that Knight and you'll just
have to come right back
yeah you gain a whole lot of nothing
because you attack The Rook you can make
a repetition but play on you just said
black has nothing to risk the Knight
comes out to D6 I agree with you the
more I look at it the more I think that
Fabiano can play on there is zero risk
in his position tomorrow's a rest day he
could play eight hours if he wants and
then get some sleep tomorrow so this
position still has life in it I think
that Fabian is the type of player who
looks for uh possibilities no matter the
position so he will try to objectively
tackle this position and while he does
that and Richard's on the clock we can
zoom out to all of our boards the game
between Lavon aronian and Wesley so is
about to finish uh they have made a
number of very quick moves and we see in
the bottom row in the middle there we're
just left with a bishop and a bunch of
Pawns and while black is a pawn a head
it doesn't really matter Wesley
and Lavon I believe you know are very
clear that this game is going to be a
draw so who's up upon Who's down the
pawn that's not really of any importance
it's it's a clear draw with the Bishops
of opposite color
100 this is going to be handshakes very
soon this will be the first result of
today we see uh there are a couple of
moves where Czech has been given the
king comes but it doesn't matter in the
opposite color Bishop uh end game
because the Bishops control different
colors of the board it's very difficult
to make progress so this one ends soon
Robert and if we see the top uh the top
left
Anish was his Magnus the big matchup of
the day very similar lines to what we
were discussing have happened it's still
a rich position that we have a lot of
complexities a lot of lines to calculate
uh we see that black did jump in with
the knight uh and Anish sidestepped with
the Rook we can take a look at that and
also there's an end game in the Frog
board the top right if we see Queens
have been traded off and white did get
that Central break I think that's pretty
even as well the one game where I see
the bar has shot up is the bottom left
the second board if you see nordeback
against Parham and it seems to say that
noribbeck has an advantage over Parham
let's take a look and try and break that
down
yes let's do that I mean Wesley and
Lavon they will shake hands very shortly
so we'll keep an eye on that and well in
in general here uh the players they're
you know duking it out they're trying
their best to uh get on the scoreboard
if you're abusive tariff in particular
you're tied for the lead before today if
you can win and all of your Rivals do
not then you will be in clear first so
in this position the last moves have
been played here were
uh striking in the center not a single
piece had been traded as a move 13 and
then D5 happens and the white doesn't
take Microsoft D4 so Tanya the board
explodes at this moment if you take on
D4 white doesn't just take back because
then a lot of caption E4 white throws a
pawn forward with E5 attacking in the
Knight into Intermezzo taking back on D4
with the pawn just establishing these
pawns on D4 and on E5 and that's really
bad news for the bishop on G7 it's bad
news for the C file which is only open
to White whereas Black's open file with
this Rook there's a big Pawn in the way
and it's a connected chain so that's why
instead after D4 the move D takes e was
played but there's this issue I believe
of Knight and Rook on the same diagonal
so you'd be really really careful here
if your Parham because tactics will
favor white and by the way Wesley and
Lavon have finished their game they have
drawn and they're just analyzing it
right now
I have to say they are analyzing it but
it looked like it was an even game start
to finish neither player were in too
much trouble the key moment was right
out of the opening once Lavon was able
to get that E4 move in and I see Wesley
pointing at that B3 square and I think
that's the moment that they're
discussing Robert because B3 was really
the move that allowed Levon to equalize
out of the opening getting that Central
break-in and there we see the players
still trying to figure out what went
wrong for white because it just looked
like Lev made it look easy and with that
Levon and Wesley
draw their encounter and go on to the
rest day with a 50 score in the Tata
steel Masters
they do and while they get to go home
these players are still going at it and
look at this bishop G5 a pawn was
captured on D4 and no deerback says wait
a second let's go Bishop G5 and there
are many tactics that black has to avoid
because if you get greedy and take
another Pawn on C3 white takes this
Knight on F6 with check after Bishop
takes F6 the queen covers the bishop
looks okay but the Queens also covering
the Rook so if the Rook 6 E8 check the
queen is dragged away from the F6 square
and after Bishop takes F6 white goes up
a piece and will Checkmate this black
king So Parham quickly responds to
Bishop G5 with Bishop E6 closing down
the e-file keeping the F6 Knight
defended but Tanya the eval bar is
skyrocketing in no direbec's favor
and the reason for that Robert is this
devastating pin on F6 it's one of those
forever pins how are you going to get
out of this and I don't have a clear
answer to that Bishop E6 has been played
as you were mentioning black cannot take
that pawn on C3 now white can simply
recapture the pawn let's say you take I
want to keep my Knights on the board so
you take it back with the pawn
everything remains and yes there's a
material balance but there is this
horrible pin on F6 which is so difficult
to get out or one of the moves that
comes to mind is eight six trying to
hide away and trying to say you know
what if you move that Bishop away at
least my knight is free but I don't
think black has time for this because
you can take on F6 even with your Knight
Knight F6 Bishop F6 Bishop 86 is an
option that comes to mind
and this would be a difficult trade I
see our eval Bar says that this is not
the way forward for white there is
something stronger and the reason for
that is you just want to pawn on 86 but
the thing is that your D4 Pawn is weak
as well let's just finish that line
Robert that often Knight F6 Bishop F6
Bishop 86 doesn't seem to work because
the D4 Pawn hangs and black is doing uh
fine now and this is what black is
dreaming about but perhaps after eight
six there's something way stronger
because we saw the eval bar say that
white black is still busted and maybe
you just take with the bishop on F6
Bishop F6 Bishop F6 and maybe D5 here
immediately is that an option yes D5 is
the move as the eval bar confirms and
the point is that you Fork the Knight on
the bishop and after Bishop takes D5 you
can decide do you want to be fancy here
yes or no Robert
of course I do queen takes D5 if the
queen takes what looks like a free Queen
Knight takes F6 with a royal Fork of the
king the queen and the Rook you're of
course gonna take the queen and then
When the Smoke Clears white is up two
minor pieces with a complete winning
position so if you can't play after
Bishop E6 Pawn takes D4 if you cannot
play them with H6 how are you gonna deal
with the threat of D5 now with this
lasting pin I guess Knight B4 takes
control of that D5 square but that's not
the end of the story there's still
problems for black going forward because
if you think we're just trading pieces
you're gonna lose this game quite
quickly like you bring your knight to D5
you have everything protecting each
other that's great like a knight comes
into E5 or it comes to C1 wow and white
just has this Firepower against Black's
position F7 now is a Target by the way
so if you make some move like Rook C8 or
something you just take on F6 and if you
take on F6 with the Knight down goes F7
and you're crushed because there is
a discovery your Queen's under attack
this is no good and if you take with the
bishop we just saw this tactic Queen
takes D5 if you take the queen there's a
four gun F6 winning the queen right back
so I believe that Parham is in huge
trouble right now Tanya his position
feels like it's on the verge of
collapsing unless he finds all of the
accurate moves and this is a huge moment
for not a back he is one of the five
leaders and if he is able to win this uh
that that would mean that his call would
go to three out of four and he'd
definitely be high on the leaderboard
going into the first rest day that the
players have as we can see this is where
we stand Robert currently five uh we've
got Magnus Fabi Anish ding nordeback
Wesley and Levon all with two points
Wesley and Levon are the only ones who
finish their games they did draw so they
finished the day with two points
everybody else is playing we're gonna
have shuffling around on the leaderboard
it certainly will it's a game of musical
chairs in a sense and well normak and
Parham they are trying to get toward the
top they're such strong players despite
their young age uh but as we see six
games still in session uh we will take a
short break before we do I want to
remind everybody of a special event
starting February because the wait is
over after a two-year Hiatus the protest
league is back the 2023 season begins
with a qualifier week starting February
1st with 16 teams advancing into the
main season past PCL participants
include Magnus ding nepo Fabi Hikaru mvl
and Anish so we could not be more
excited for the League's return and with
over one hundred thousand dollars on the
line it's looking like the 2023 season
will be won for the history books use
the command PCL and chat to learn all
about it Tanya and I will be right back
and when you return it will be more from
round 4 from the Tata steel Chess
Masters
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
January and Vicon Zay the Netherlands
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun
oh my God he's gone for it Knight eat a
G5 was a nice Furious choice
once again Vicon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back there it is the world champion once
again proving that he indeed has the
best technique in the game
the world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title he's like
the nicest person on the planet when it
comes to his chest you just don't want
to mess with it
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps it a win
for black notary back continues his hot
streak the Dutch refer to Tata steel as
The Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
foreign
ER garci is on the clock here in the
fourth round of the Tata steel Chess
Masters it's his move he is thinking but
he is not looking at the board perhaps
he's looking at the empty table that was
left between Wesley so and Lavon aronian
they drew their game uh it was a good
opening from Lavon aronian he was never
in any danger but Tanya in this game
between Vincent kymer who is not at the
board and Arjun aragaisi uh we're still
pretty early on 18 moves into it and
well a cup of Pawns one Pawn per side
has been traded the darks were Bishops
are off but otherwise all pieces remain
this is a battle between teenagers
Winston Karma against Argent aragasi
such an exciting matchup this one and as
we can see that we're right out of the
opening but it looks like our eval bar
seems to like arjun's position meanwhile
Arjun in his classic pose of it being
his move but he's just looking
everywhere else as we've seen him do
that time and time again he is 100
thinking about how he wants to proceed
here what what is the calculation that
he's looking at why is our eval liking
his position and the reason for that
Robert is because take a look at
Winston's C3 on there it is a backward
weakness meanwhile Arjun is all ready to
already start thinking about doubling up
on the C5 it's just easier to play with
black it might not even be a big
Advantage which it clearly is not it's
somewhat even but I think black just has
a more pleasant position with ideas of
moving the queen away The Rook coming to
the C file C3 under attack how does
white get rid of this weakness would be
to make the move C4 but in chess it's a
give and take you can get rid of your
weakness but with that you will open a
monstrous Bishop on B7 that Arjun
currently has so it is a difficult
position for white to play it just seems
like a lot easier to play as black
I agree with that and Arjun he's looking
to be precise here moves that come to
mind as you mentioned bringing the queen
away so The Rook can go to C8 uh the
queen maybe can go to F6 as well for The
Rook to get to see it but it's all about
this C pawn and the potential push to C4
uh origin in a dream world he would be
able to bring this Knight up a square to
D6 and that way he controls the C4
Square completely but he's gonna take a
while and C4 is going to be an option
that Vincent will calculate each and
every move so a lot to figure out in
this game it's one of those positions
where it's almost like there's not a lot
of Life at the moment but there's so
much potential for both sides because C4
changes the position from kind of a
static one to a dynamic one opening the
bishop on B7 uh we will dive into this a
little bit more deeply in a little bit
but the game between Anish giri and
Magnus Carlson uh you know you hear that
match up you think Magnus Carlson great
record against Anisha historically but
look at him he is really working hard at
the board because the position has
gotten extremely spicy and it's more or
less a line that we were predicting it
there are some differences which is
important and makes magnus's position
better than some of our earlier analysis
but as we can see
the pawn did go up to D7 after the
Knight jumped to C4 then the Knight went
into C2
wrapped around to D4 The Rook is cut off
but Tanya
B4 Anish strikes he's got two good Rooks
and oh my gosh Rook takes D7 was played
and I keep seeing the eval bar creep up
rook takes D7 winning upon seems to have
been a mistake
I and you saw that expression by Magnus
I think he realizes that he has uh he
has gone down the wrong way he does look
a lot more tense you can look at him and
you can feel that he is in trouble
Robert Rook D7 was such a natural move
to be played you want to pick up that D7
Pawn I'm loving how calm a niche looks
he is in control slightly surprised
immediately respond he's reaching out
for the bishop and he's about to move
the bishop will he move it to D5 hitting
that Knight on C4 also stopping the
connection between uh the Knight on D4
and The Rook also you've got no good
Square because take a look at this the
problem is that after Bishop D5 if you
move the Knight back to D6 white can go
on and pick up the pawn on C5 and now
because you've moved your Rook away from
d8 to D7 the B8 square is free for your
Rook to jump in and this would be bad
news for black skin Anish plays the move
Bishop D5 immediately gets out of the
board but Magnus has been in big
pressure from the start in this game he
hasn't been his typical self of making a
move walking around checking out the
other boards he's had his head in his
hands he's been fully focused and it
looks like Anish giri is in driving seat
in this one and look at Magnus he he's
in disbelief right now and a big problem
is what time you call this out very
early on The Rook is in the corner not
in the game the king is on the back Rank
and here's where the problems they
continue if you go Rook d8 The Rook
trade seems like all right we're trading
pieces blocks up a pawn that's good news
but Bishop A3 is the dagger the pawn of
C5 is hanging you may think you're just
defending the pawn with your bishop and
perhaps Magnus had seen this position in
his head but Rook takes D4 it's a
sacrifice of Rook for night but after
the pawn takes on before the bishop on
A3 that is happy to see a newly opened
diagonal and not only can you take on D6
with the bishop it check you could keep
that PIN let's go Knight E4 let's take
that Knight on D6 with the Knight attack
the F7 Pawn this position would be
losing for Magnus Carlson so you you see
him he can't believe it and Anish Gary's
behind him and he's making a Michaela
Maroney face like uh excuse me like what
just happened here Anish Geary might
take down Magnus Carlson and the Vikings
a magic from the Dutchman continues he
has had so many good performances here
never won the event a bunch of second
place finishes but this year might be
anisha's year he is off to a great start
and in this game after Bishop D5 Magnus
is in huge trouble
this is a big big moment for Anish
Robert the last time that he beat Magnus
Carlsen was back in 2011 and that was at
this very stage in waikansea in their
first ever classical duel after that
he's never had a repeat of that he's
never defeated Magnus in a classical
game and this is his moment it's also
the confidence that he's showing how
quickly he's playing we've often seen
Anish have great positions but then
somehow loses that that ability to
evaluate it and to go for that kill in
that extremely critical moment but we've
been seeing a different a niche here he
needs to strike and he's showing all
intentions of doing that he has been
finishing runners-up in the Tata steel
Masters he's come second twice Magnus
the eight times champion of the
tournament he's got a sixth win lead
over Anish while Anisha just won one
game they've got 21 draws between each
other but this one looks like it's
headed a decisive way and in favor of
Anish this is a huge moment for him and
if you think about their you know
match-up their history against one
another and he's Gary won that very
first game in Vikings a 12 years ago
since then it's an old Magnus he has won
six decisive games he's pulverized him
in some of them and Anisha be the first
to admit that you know if he is going to
be the best he's gonna have to get
through Magnus at some point there is a
bit of a psychological barrier that
every player faces when they're seated
against Magnus but if you look at bangs
his face he knows he is has gone wrong
and each knows that Magnus has gone
wrong so now it's not putting it all
together we just were showing the
important variation that if the Knight
goes to D6 there is going to be a
problem down this diagonal the King on
f8 is misplaced if you bring the Knight
to E5 that doesn't actually help matters
at all because after B takes C5 now your
knight is loose on D4 and if you take
back guess what the idea is that Bishop
A3 are still there you may want to say
let me just defend with Bishop E7 pieces
are overloaded the bishop on E7 is doing
too much and we see by the way Richard
reporting five minute carwana they made
their draw in the background there but
to finish this point here the bishop on
E7 it defends C5 but it also defends d8
and why is that important because that's
a rook ba check and The Rook slides back
now we see the bishop doing too much it
can't have its arms in both directions
after Rook d8 Bishop d8 I could take on
C5 with check I take the Knight on D4
white would go up a full piece in this
variation so Magnus his hair is all over
the place he's frazzled he can't believe
what has just happened he played this
opening from the white side back in 2008
against Yannick Pelletier and now in the
black set against Denise Geary things
are going wrong for him and finding the
next few moves are not going to be easy
for Medics even to stay in this game
the hair is out of control the position
is out of control Robert it is such a
difficult moment we saw that Magnus
looking at his caution trying to figure
out where did all of this go so wrong
out of the opening from him and it's
hard to imagine the world champion
coming into so much pressure early on
there he looks back to see what the
other result is but of course his focus
is totally on the trouble that exists on
his board and his game when these two
players meet there's also so much of a
psychological battle given their history
their over-the-board history their
social media history it's definitely a
matchup that fans are super excited
about you know their uh their Bromance
what is their current status just nobody
knows that's a big mystery are they
friends are they enemies are they
Frenemies that is one of the 10
questions that even science can't answer
but currently look at magnus's face it
looks like he's not able to answer the
big question what is his name next move
now he's in huge trouble right now and
Anish is ready to strike and this would
be I think huge not just for the
tournament but I think it would be big
for a niche his career in general he
beat Magnus in that first game they
played but that was a dozen years ago
that was a lifetime ago since then you
know Anish has a couple kids he's
married like his change as a person his
whole life is different so to be able to
beat Magnus Carlson while Magnus is the
world champion in all three disciplines
on his home turf in front of the Dutch
crowd who love Anish who support him who
back him every time he plays that would
be a huge result and right now his face
says it all Magnus Carlson is looking at
this position and he doesn't know what
to do and he's mad at himself and he's
gonna have to push his emotions aside
for the time being because as we see in
the evaluation bar it's bad for black
but not all hope is lost so let's like
Magnus try to save it for him at night
has to move it is under attack it can't
be defended upon the B5 that's not going
to work out because after Pawn to B5
which does defend the Knight you simply
take this Pawn on C5 now the Knight on
D4 is loose that pawn on B5 is under
attack the Knight on C4 the V8 Square
upon going to C6 too much is happening
and it's all good for white so you can't
defend the Knight we have two safe
squares E5 and D6 Knight D6 Pawn takes
Pawn takes we were talking about Bishop
eighth I think Rook B8 first even
we were looking at
um it doesn't look Pleasant you can't
move the king you lose your rook in the
corner maybe you have some kind of
Knight E8 move it looks terrible but at
least you're not losing on the spot
Tanya I don't envy the task for Magnus
but you just need to calculate all the
different moves just throw a move out
and say wait that one doesn't look so
easy for my opponent and maybe it is
this passive position where you're all
tangled up and if Anisha isn't perfectly
accurate then you can escape later
Magnus is so frustrated not right now
Robert he cannot believe the mess he's
landed up in right out of the opening an
opening choice that he decided to go for
the Queen's Indian and surprise the
niche with Bishop A6 and it's caused him
this huge trouble on the board currently
and I think he's just wondering where
did this happen the key moment was
really that spot with King E7 where he
had the option if we just back up a
couple of moves Robert and after Knight
C4 D7 was played
and here he had the opportunity to go
into this line that we were talking
about with King E7 Bishop C8 and this is
what he had to do try to get his pieces
out as quickly as possible after Bishop
C8 you can go Knight D6 you can go
Knight C2 but one way or the other you
have to Target you have to Target that
Bishop you have to Target that pawn on
D7
yeah we were looking at these lines
earlier in this 94 move looking quite
frustrating to meet for black because if
you take on C8 we were looking at
positions like this where after Knight
takes F6 you know this position does not
look very pleasant for black if you take
the bishop lands on H6 check but because
of Knight C2 in the air perhaps there is
some kind of dynamic balance available
to Black I do have an extra Pawn
Robinson you have an extra on so you
know even if the bishop does land on H6
eventually and you're pointing out this
line Knight C2 I think that is key you
can't allow those mating traps and
mating attack on the back rank Knight C2
keeps some kind of balance and this was
the crucial moment it was missed by
Magnus and ever since then a niche has
been on top of things let's come back to
our current Port because this is where
it's at B4 has been played Bishop D5 is
on the board huge threats the Knight on
C4 hangs Knight D4 B4 what a move this
was by and he's just absolutely
fantastic play there Bishop D5 hitting
that Knight on C4 we've been talking
about peace activity and now Magnus
finds himself retreating one by one with
his active pieces if you take on B4 The
Rook takes on B4 and then suddenly these
two knights are really in the way of
each other can't defend you have to fall
back with the Knight white will go on to
win two pieces for a rook and we've been
saying this over and over again the
biggest problem in Black's Camp is that
the Rook on h8 is still not active
it's true and the problem
persist Bishop A3 coming you would have
a rook and one Pawn for two Bishops but
there's so many pieces on the board and
we talk about this a rook in one Pawn
that is five plus one six points two
Bishops three and three is six points it
sounds equal but when you have pieces
more pieces more powerful pieces and two
Bishops they're both powerful and things
to attack that one Rook is often not
going to be useful enough as the Bishops
do exert maximum pressure in the
position so this is a bad situation for
Magnus Carlsen he is going to work hard
to survive and maybe his best chance is
the line we just looked at I mean it's
not out of the question that he goes for
something like this and maybe instead of
walking to a pin he brings his Knight to
safety this looks terrible for black
nobody no player would want this
position but at the same time Tanya I
think if we stick to this position for a
second second it's not clear how white
wins the game will continue white is
much better but maybe there's a chance
for this King to like run to d8 just go
over here so The Rook can come to eight
things of that nature and while black is
in trouble black is not hopelessly lost
just yet but if you look at Magnus on
screen I mean he looks like a guy who is
ready to resign and get out of the Plant
Hall
he's in shock right now
he's not even blinking he he can't
believe what this position is and there
we see it's about choosing the Lesser
evil here there are no good moves in a
bad position he's landed up in concrete
trouble and that's the problem the only
thing is that Robert Anish has to
believe in his position he has to
believe that he is winning and then go
for it we've seen him get great
positions but at some point he tends to
lose that faith in his own evaluation
and that he he can beat Magnus Carlsen
he did it once in 2011 he's super close
to repeating that in 2023 in his matchup
against Magnus and this would be a huge
win we look at Magnus he's looking
devastated right now I want to show a
couple of lines you were pointing out
that takes on B4 might just be the best
way forward let's take a look at that
because it feels if Magnus doesn't go
for this he might just be dead lost and
you want to come back with the Knight to
A5 so that you don't end up in any pin
along the A3 effect diagonal I pick up
your knight on D4 give up my Rook for
two pieces you've got to try to activate
that Rook on h8 now King E7 is the most
logical move in this position you want
to bring that Rook into the game and I
go Bishop A3 check
King d8 might be a possibility but let's
see what happens if you make a move like
King F6 you know you're trying to
activate your pieces you want to bring
that Rook out but this is dangerous
because suddenly all of White's pieces
have so much coordination you can come
in with a check on F4 I can go Rook F4
check
and if you go King to G6 Bishop E4 check
really boxing up that King and we can
see the eval bar creep up and up and up
the king does end up in a meeting net
with the Knight jumping to defy the
bishop will fall back to C1 at some
point on this diac on the diagonal c1286
if you move your king there this is bad
news I just don't see Magnus creating
any play getting a chance to get that
Rook into the game and if that doesn't
happen this is game over right so at
that moment King died as you were saying
it has to be played and The Rook does
get to Ian this is what he needs some
semblance of Hope a position where maybe
down the line he can give his Rook for
one of the Bishops and then get a pawn
in return and we've talked about this a
lot in recent end games in the past few
days where you have to see the future
and say if you know everything goes
wrong and I'm going to be worse what's
the position where at least I can have
the most chances and so here getting the
Rook to eat at least you have some Act
activity white is better and each Geary
gets to play with zero risks whatsoever
he likely will win this game but Magnus
will hold out hope and then make a niche
work for it so we'll leave Magnus to it
uh the guy looks like he wants to be
doing anything but playing this chess
game so why don't we zoom out for a
second here we have two draws in the
books we saw the draw between Wesley and
LeBron's opposite colored Bishops not
much to look at there in Fabiano and
Richard reports game we got into this
Rook end game equal material there
actually wasn't much life left after the
position we looked at it seems like they
just traded pieces so those two are done
with but the other games are fascinating
look at the bottom right we see the move
G7 to G5 by Gucci against Jordan Von
Forest so he strikes with his g-pawn
after Jordan brought that Queen over to
G3 but that means that black king will
not Castle so why don't we actually just
tuned right into that game bring it up
to analyze because this the last few
moves we predicted with Rook E1 Tanya's
brilliant Knight D5 idea coming your way
but Bishop E7 blocks that but in the
queen takes advantage of Black's last
move and gukesh says I'm gonna play G5
but after Bishop D2 the queen is forced
back it is on the same diagnose as the
bishop Knight D5 is a useful Discovery
and queen C7 so black is not lost any
material but Tanya you've kind of lost
the right to Castle you still legally
can do it but nobody in their right mind
is castling kingside so I feel like
gukash has these long-term problems and
his King it's safe in the center for now
perhaps but in the long term I feel like
he's created many weaknesses
and that's bad news when your king is
stuck in the center and you're playing
against uh and you're playing against
sorry I think we have to just adjust the
cameras there uh but here with gukesh
you're playing against a guy like Jordan
who is super creative and super
Innovative with his attack it can always
be bad news if your king is going to be
there for the rest of the game now I
just want to point out that black hasn't
even started attacking White's King
meanwhile white can actually break into
Black's position with a move like F4 and
destroy the pawn structure on the king's
side start threatening all kinds of
invasions along the G file and the F5
also Robert the E4 Pawn is currently
hanging but do you have the nerves to
pick it up with that King on the center
my Rook on E1 yes I can make a safe move
like Bishop D3 but that's the kind of
move that I might make Jordan on the
other hand is probably already thinking
about a move like F4 and you want to try
to break open the king side I think
Bishop D3 is really good it looks safe
and I see when you play the eval bar
agrees to it this is the move to go for
and then you keep all your trumps you
want to make the move F4 but what I want
to look at if we just back up can white
get over aggressive you see your
opponent's king in the center do you
really care about material let's take a
look at what happens if white actually
makes the move F4 we've all played
Sicilians we know how crazy these
positions are and look at that Robert
the eval dropped but not by that much
and the reason for that is if you take
Knight E4
after I trade Bishop E4 my yes you're
threatening my Pawn on C2 but I come
with my Bishop to C3 I defend my Pawn on
C2 I'm targeting your Rook on h8
both the files in the center are open my
Rook on E1 is super duper active your
king isn't going anywhere and I've got
everything to play for this is massive
Initiative for white now it depends on
Jordan's approach here is he going to go
in to First defend the e-pawn and then
strike with F4 or will he go for the
direct approach of trying to create an
explosive attack against the King by
sacrificing the e-born
yeah just to continue this for a second
Rook G8 you think oh I can't Castle
anymore but we already established that
black doesn't want a castle kingside
anyway it makes moves like Rook shade
easier to play easier to swallow that
decision and white would be down upon
tons of activity tons of play we see
that the evaluation bar is perfectly
content with White's position uh and
just became becomes a sharp game the
reason why I don't like this option
compared to your first instinct of
Bishop to D3 if we back up here the
reason I like Bishop D3 more is because
it doesn't allow black to solve any of
his problems F4 is one option H4 is
another and with more pieces on the
board look at the harmony here with
White's pieces all protecting each other
all having a purpose maybe The Rook on
D1 doesn't have the best purpose right
now but that's okay The Rook on h8 is a
bystander you know it's not really
participating in the game right now H4
and F that's not H that's H4 and that's
F4 those moves still in the air maybe an
E5 at some moment maybe still a knight
D5 if Black's not looking out for it so
the typical plan for black is to play B5
but let's say I just I'm even solid for
a moment I play F3 White Foundation is
so strong you have a great Paul chain
here this Pawn on G5 it really sticks
out like a sore thumb and H4 will hit
you and you won't enjoy it so I just
really feel that maybe this Knight goes
back to E2 Bishop to C3 Knight to D4
then white has an easy bunch of plants
it just you look at the position you see
five different options I look at Black's
position I don't know what to do on each
and every move I've been I played B5
because it's thematic and then I'm out
of Moves Like I'm out of ideas so I just
think keeping more pieces on the board
not allowing black to clarify the
position is what Jordan should aim for
and I would agree with everything that
you've said and then add that the player
that we're talking about here is Jordan
van Forrest he is the guy who doesn't
want to play solid he doesn't want to
keep everything under control he wants
to create a mess he goes in for the
complications he is super Fearless when
it comes to these uh positions now he's
somebody who's also won the Tata steel
Masters what Irani had back in 2021
scoring eight and a half out of 13 and
playing an amazing playoff against Anish
giri where it was just anybody's
tiebreak anyone's game eventually Jordan
came on top and won the Tata steel
Masters for the first time he's just 23
years old he's got a rating of two six
eight one one of the big big stars uh in
the Chess World he also was part of the
Magnus Carlsen world championship team
for the match in Dubai against Jan nap
omnishi and it's interesting to see how
that experience has evolved Jordan as a
player uh Magnus often mentioned when he
spoke about his theme that Jordan's the
guy who would come up with the most
creative most fun opening ideas and
that's the Jordan that we keep seeing
here by the way as I speak he does go
for the recommendation that you liked
more uh Robert keeping everything under
control this is the Grand Master
approach you know this is the
professional approach why sacrifice upon
when you've got everything going for you
you can play f for any time you can play
H for any time you can even play F3 and
keep things solid Bishop D3 your
postpones the decision to break open
Black's king and the reason is that
every move that black has to make is a
tough move to find you know you can go
B5 but there is no follow-up to it
you're never getting any pieces into the
attack meanwhile again and again your
king is in the center and Robert I hate
to say this but one more time gokish in
a bad call out of the opening
he lost the first two games of this
event he had the white pieces against
ding the ren that didn't go very well
for him he had the black pieces against
Anish giri that went even worse and then
in game three he did make that draw but
now in game four he's playing someone
who also had a rough start but Jordan
you know has a dream position not a
single weakness in White's Camp not one
everything is safe and sound black has
overextended on the king side you can go
on the queen side here but you're not
threatening anything so I really feel
like kukesh doesn't have a plan and you
know as we remind everybody of these
standings uh gukesh has been at the
bottom and on the flip side Jordan you
know he struggled yesterday against
fabula carwana who's at the top and his
draw against Richard report allows
Fabiano to be temporarily in first place
with that extra game played so Magnus
Carlsen he you see him there with two
out of three he might end up at two out
of four but he has not moved Tanya he's
still still is thinking about what to do
against Anish Geary who if he wins will
be in first place
Robert and Debbie have him he hasn't
moved he hasn't changed his pose there
he's still got his head and and a half
full of uh uh there in his hands and he
can't get enough of where he's landed up
this is such a terrible position out of
the opening for him but I'll tell you
one thing Robert
getting a good position getting a close
to winning position against Magnus
Carlsen means nothing it's half the job
done you still have to beat him he's the
guy you give one chance to come back
into the game and the tide turns like
you've never seen before and that's the
problem Anish has to keep the momentum
going he's played accurately so far but
he can't afford to make a single small
error against this player Magnus is a
beast we know the kind of comebacks that
he's capable of in the position yes he's
in big trouble but it's far from over
and what he's doing right now he's taken
about 25 minutes for this move we are on
move number 24 that he's trying to find
that continuation that gives him maximum
chances to stay alive it's not easy but
again this guy doesn't give up a niche
close to a winning Advantage here as we
can see in our eval bar but that means
nothing when you're playing against the
world champion you still have to get the
job done you certainly do and there are
two different approaches and we just
want to thank everybody who has been
participating in the chat we do see your
messages there but there are two
approaches that Magnus can take right
now and that's why he's spending so much
time there's the approach we have been
talking about with C takes B4 giving up
the two minor pieces for The Rook it
doesn't look very good for black but
maybe with the King going to d8 and the
real company eight there are chances to
survive that's option one option two
which briefly was mentioned earlier is
if the Knight slides back to D6 pod
takes C5 Pawn takes C5 and say Rook ba
check and then Knight has to go back to
E8 you get to keep your material Bishop
A3 Bishop E7 it's not a fun position to
play but at least you keep your material
so these are the two options either you
give up some material and get some
activity and hope that that's going to
be sufficient or you keep the material
and hope that Anish giri makes some
mistake or Cashes in too early because
because this position white is down upon
but what is white up white is up
essentially a rook because this Rook on
h8 is stuck by the king white is kind of
a minor piece because this piece is
pinned and this bishop on E7 is doing a
defensive job to this Pawn on C5 so
Tanya these are two options Magnus
undoubtedly not just thinking about this
position but one ten moves down the road
from what looks like a tough one so what
do you think is he going to take the
approach where he gets passive but keeps
the material or the one where he's down
material but gets some activity
it's such a tough call to take because
you know that both positions objectively
are worse for you
I think he's going to go in for the plan
that we were discussing where you
sacrifice the two pieces for a rook but
you're at least able to get your pieces
out into the game at least try and keep
some activity again it's a tough call
and the more time that he takes on this
move the more it's clear that just goes
on to show this is the best player in
the world that we're talking about he's
taken almost 30 minutes for this move
and that just goes on to show how
difficult this position is for Magnus
many times in his interviews he's often
said that in any position if you end up
thinking more than 10 minutes it's
already a bit shaky he hasn't taken the
decision for a while now Anish meanwhile
not on the board walking around Anish
realizes that he is doing great and
there we see Magnus leaning back often
looking at his score sheet looking
pretty devastated with the position in
front of him there and well the one
thing he's got going for him is great
hair
yes and you see Magnus there he's
looking pretty distraught and that's not
a look we've seen from him that often in
Vikings a because from 2008 all the way
through to 2022 last year he is an
eight-time Champion he is the defending
champion and well in this year's start
he won an important game with black
against Vincent kymer and Tony we've
talked about it he often gets to slow
starts including in Vikings say uh there
was a year I believe it was 2019 where
he drew his first batch of games maybe
his first five and then he won a big
winning streak so this year he won a
game early which he doesn't always do
sometimes a little bit of a slow Riser
but now he might face a setback in round
four and Anish Geary you see his name on
this graphic a few times in 2018 in East
Gary in second place in 2019 niskier in
second place back in 2015 Anish tied for
a second so Anish has been within arm's
length of first place and it might be
about time that he grabs that title the
Thrones Magnus from his vikon Zay first
place uh finishes and that would be huge
for Niche because I think you know he's
a jokester right he goes on Twitter he's
cracking jokes posting memes but
something that must bother him is all of
these Wise Cracks about how he's never
won a Super tournament and he has had
first place finishes in strong events
but in like the premier tournaments it
seems like it has eluded him and Magnus
by the way did bring the Knight back to
D6 he decides to keep the material and
suffer passively thinking that it's not
an easy position to break through so I
actually you know there were two options
both of them had their drawbacks and
their positives I think that Magnus is
now forcing a niche to demonstrate some
killer Tech technique Tanya you know you
were mentioning this that there are
moments where Niche he doesn't strike
when the moment calls for it he knows he
is much better here but will he be able
to strike Magnus down
that's the big question and we can see
just how much better he is because we're
assisted by the eval bar but Anish 100
knows that he is better but is it enough
is it unclear better does Magnus still
have chances these are questions that
are existing right now in anisha's mind
but look at the speed with which he's
playing Robert that shows me a lot of
confidence uh something that we don't
find uh very often when the players face
Magnus Carlsen here now Anish very
quickly took on C5 trades on C5 creates
that weakness and this is a big moment
he will slow down here because there are
two options just like Magnus had two
options Anish does as well you can play
Rook B8 here immediately giving a check
and saying that do you want to trade a
rook with d8 or fall back with your uh
Knight to E8 not pleasant choices either
of them the other option is to keep this
option of giving a check alive but you
first develop your Bishop to A3 and
Target the weak one which actually if
you see is in possible to defend the
line that you've already pointed out
Rook C7 doesn't work out because now the
check is even more powerful on B8 yes
you can fall back with the Knight to see
it and say that the Rook defends the
Knight and the pawn but that's the big
problem this position everything is tied
down and it is super hard for black to
move any piece at all Bishop B7 ideas
rookie one idea is cutting off that King
on the f8 Square a really difficult
position this will be busted
again Robert do you think Anish is going
to go for The Rook B8 and try and trade
off the Rooks before he attacks the
weakness or will he keep the threats
alive will he move the bishop these are
questions that Anish has right now in
front of him and a lot of our chats
saying that Anish is playing so
powerfully and let's go in each there's
a lot of support for him as well in the
chat and that's really nice to see
because Anish needs that energy when
you're playing against someone like the
world champion uh you need all the
energy that you can regardless of what
the eval Bar says certainly and you see
Anish he knows he's two good options I'm
liking the look of Bishop A3 I'm
wondering how black gets out of this
there may be a timely Knight E6 Retreat
maybe there's King E7 I know we've been
harping on the fact that the Rook on AJ
has been stuck and I'm kind of walking
into the middle of the board but if you
give me a check on E1 I could
potentially block on E6 or even bring my
king back to d8 so this Knight on C3 is
also loose with this bishop uh staring
at it on F6 so there may be some
opportunities in some positions for a
some kind of a night move out the way
but ah it's so unpleasant even just the
simple Bishop takes C5 isn't looking so
fun but this is what I was aiming for I
was just trying to uh you know put all
my pieces close to my king if you take
this Knight on E6 the king takes and
gets out of not this pin but the PIN
with on the diagonal and everything
suddenly is defended right it doesn't
look good but we see the were actually
it's shrinking it's saying that white
Advantage is uh is decreasing so it's
weird but I'm just looking at something
just to survive that's really all I'm
aiming for if I'm thinking about this
from Magnus Carlson's perspective let me
just survive move by move and now you're
challenging this bishop on C5 the bishop
retreats to A3 what was I just
mentioning the Knight on C3 is loose and
it's funny you blunder a full piece and
it's still barely better for black
that's just how good anisha's position
is right he I'm giving you a piece by
accident and yet black is barely better
well he might very well decide to keep
all the threats and play Bishop A3
attacking C5 uh has to look at all these
lines and most importantly evaluate it
correctly as ending better for him by a
huge margin at the end the other option
that we're looking at also very pleasant
uh Robert which he could be attracted to
is the move Rook to be a check and I
think that could be something that
Magnus is hoping for the more the pieces
get traded
even if the eval bar likes it the easier
it gets for black let's take a look at
that Rook B8
I don't want to get my knight any more
passive enough pieces are not playing in
the game I want to try and trade off
your active look so Rook d8 is the
natural move the human move at least and
you trade on d8 Bishop d8 at first I had
a feeling that after Bishop A3 you
actually end up picking up the C5 Pawn
but black does have a resource to defend
that pawn that Bishop on the yet can
jump to B6 and you still keep some
material balance but look at this line
you can now give up The Rook on the one
for the Knight on D4 and we've been
talking about material imbalances by the
way he is reaching out for a piece
Robert and just to finish this line
quickly now you pick up the Knight it's
still far from over black can fight this
position after Bishop D6
yes yeah I mean 94 as well just the take
the night with the night and that way
you go after the F7 Pawn so it's going
to be a bad position regardless but you
are correct there is this past Pawn
remaining The Rook will finally get out
from the corner uh somewhere along the
back Rank and then get into play so that
gives Magnus some hope even if both
players know that white is much better
and and each plays Bishop A3 he says let
me just win this Pawn directly I'm not
going to be down any material and for
Magnus what moves does he have here I
mentioned King E7 there might be other
moves that exist Knight E6 looks very
bad because after Bishop takes uh
politics here Rook b a check now will
win material because if you block with
the Rook The Rook was doing an important
job of defending this Knight so you
trade and if you block with the bishop
because of your king moves you lose the
rook in the corner that's out of the
question you move the bishop back simply
Bishop takes C5 Knight to E4 you just
pile up all of your pieces of against
the Knight on D6 it is pinned and King
E7 the only way to get out of it still
94. this is just completely lost your
Bishop can't move because your Rook is
hanging your knight can't move because
the king is behind it you're gonna lose
the Knight on the Square uh I've seen
worse positions but not too many of them
and Magnus Carlson has in fact brought
his King out to E7 so this is the
critical moment for a niche does he
simply take on C5 the Knight retreats to
E6 he sees his Knights under attack he
sees that if he uh just to show that
line again it's kind of if he takes the
king takes and suddenly this isn't that
terrible for black white is better but
black doesn't look as losing as it did
before so just from an aesthetic point
of view this would be a dream come true
for Magnus
and then that goes on to show that this
is in fact the most challenging question
that Magnus could have posed this
approach in a difficult position to
still try and activate his Rook he
doesn't care about the C5 Pawn he
doesn't think about how he wants to
defend it it's all about getting that
Rook into the game King E7 I like it
Magnus played it fast enough and now of
course we see Anish is in a great
position but he still needs to find a
winning path here rookie one check is
the other approach in the position but
once again even after rookie one check
black doesn't need to fall back with the
King you can make the move that we're
talking about you can fall back with the
Knight intercept it and you're always
threatening to get that Rook from h8
into the game it will arrive on C8
White Knight on C3 hang so notice that
you can't pick up the C5 Pawn react
Bishop into C5 Robert would be a big
blunder two Bishop C3 so the move that I
wanted to make here would be Knight to
A4 I still want to pick up your C5 Pawn
but what I want to do is I want to pick
up that pawn with my knight and put
pressure on your E6 Knight
wow yeah that's a kind of a fork there
and so with C5 hanging I might and this
is what happens when you're calculating
is you schedule a position like this in
your head like this looks really good
for white so what this block of any
moves if the answer is no you disqualify
this variation and go on to the next
with Bishop B4 I'm going to defend my
Pawn desperately if you take with the
Knight on C5 as was the plan after
Bishop takes Bishop takes there are two
pins going on at the same time King F6
gets out of both them and you see the
evaluation bar it's hovering around plus
one it's very obvious to both players
that white is better but look at this
position now the Knight attacks the
bishop if you take on E6 Pawn takes E6
the evaluation is creeping back towards
the center because you have a pin here
but finally at long last The Rook gets
into play the Knight is free to move and
then Black's worries are really behind
him so you don't want to give up your
Bishops and if you simply Retreat your
Bishop I believe this night is free to
go at long last you attack the bishop on
D5 we've been talking about this Rook it
will slide into play soon and the black
king it doesn't look safe because it's
out on F6 but at least you're not
getting checkmated and you have activity
with your Knights
and we saw that Anish reach out for his
move and then he pulls back for a moment
and huge moment here for him will he go
for rookie one check these lines that we
saw still keep magnus's position alive
still keeps hope alive so Marcus Carlson
as he does he is fighting a difficult
position and he will do that till the
very end Anish will have to prove his
Advantage uh Magnus Carlton doesn't give
up a niche on fire so far has been super
accurate
but this is just about that margin
getting smaller and smaller that
Advantage getting less and less he still
needs to make those accurate moves and
we saw Anish had made a decision but now
he's doubting it he almost reached out
to make a move there but he's doubting
it a little bit which is why he pulled
back and is having another thing does he
go to capture immediately on C5 or will
he give a check a niche there with
complete Focus there
yeah there's so much to work out we've
been going through many variations and
Anish is going through many more the
calculation does not stop with all right
The Rook is free to go he's getting
concrete because if he is going to make
some exchanges he needs to make sure
they're the right ones just like we're
showing that line where the king got out
to E6 and it looked like most of Black's
trouble was behind him and we've been
talking about as pieces get traded as we
head towards end games what pawn deficit
positions are okay let's imagine a world
where these two pawns are gone but many
of the pieces are traded in fact I'm
just going to put a position like that
on the board uh let's see how to get
there so okay Bishop C5 play I want this
decision made by a niche he reached that
and decides to not give a check and
accept the pawn on C5 and Magnus
responds immediately no sorry that's me
I was just trying to make a I was gonna
make a point now you're all good I was
just trying to get to a position where
let's say we get something like this and
white ends up winning this A7 Pawn
Magnus would look at a position like
this saying I'm down a pawn that's bad
but I will have chances to survive
because there are not that many pieces
remaining so we see Magnus and he didn't
play 96 when you thought but now he did
it anyway so he just took a little bit
of time he plays 96 and I feel like once
Magnus studied the position once he got
over his initial frustration Tanya that
he's like wait this really isn't that
simple so he does have his chances to
survive and Anish goes back in the think
tank this is a really big moment with
the bishop on C5 under attack with a pin
on the 96 the opportunity to take on E6
but I don't think you should do that
um the Knight is under attack for white
so big decision for a niche
and Magnus took that huge thing but now
makes his moves fast which go on to show
that he has acknowledged accepted that
he's gotten into trouble out of the
opening but he is fighting and it's all
about the next couple of moves Anish can
very well blow away the entire Advantage
we've seen so many lines Robert that
you've been pointing out where magnus's
pieces actually come out and Black's
doing fine right now looking at the
board those two Bishops look super
powerful The Rook on the one black skin
on E7 still The Rook on h8 just a few
moves away from finishing his
development his coordination but there
is pressure on Magnus right now the big
question for Anish is how can he keep
the momentum up you pointed out the
bishop on C5 is hanging the Knight on C3
is hanging what happens if Anish wants
to play energetically the move Knight E4
or Knight B5 the Knight B5 isn't
possible because the bishop and C5 hangs
as we've been pointing out so Knight E4
putting on more pressure on that d69 I'm
forcing you to take take my Bishop on C5
there's no way that you can defend it
let's say you pick up the bishop I pick
up your knight I'm still not giving you
the time and the tempo to improve your
Rook from h8 you've got to move that
Rook Robin and I only see one good
Square you have to move it to C7 because
if you go back Rook d8 I just want to
finish this out rookie one check and
your king is back to square one you've
got to go back all the way to f8 and I
can also at some point it's not possible
right now but someday 97 might come in
you know back rank ideas I see that the
trick doesn't work as yet but this is
not what Magnus wants he doesn't want to
land up in this mess again so let's just
back up you go Rook C7 you hit my knight
I give you a check
you've got to go back with the King and
it's still not looking Pleasant your
Rook is still stuck on h8 and I see our
eval bar hasn't moved much which means
that white still keeps a majority of the
advantage no killer blow yet black still
behind in development White's still
better but how much better is this
right because Black's one move away from
going Rook T8 offering that trade now
there's going to be a problem down the D
file there are threats on the last rank
the pawn on F7 is also loose in some
positions so there's a lot to work out
but let's say you rush with Rook to bhf
you see the evaluation going down Rook
seat has played now your Knight's under
attack so you can't just move your Rook
away and if you trade we're getting
pieces off the board we also have
opposite colored Bishops so even if
white is able to win one Pawn if enough
trades happen it's going to be like the
game between Levon and Wesley one extra
Pawn with opposite colored Bishops will
not necessarily win you the game in an
all likelihood it will not so that is
why Anish is sitting and thinking and
working so hard after this move Knight
to E6 so we will let Anish continue
thinking in the meantime we will take a
very quick break and when we return it's
more from Vikings round four the key
matchup between co-leaders Anish Kiri
and Magnus Carlson will be right back
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
chess.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
one person who would love to etch his
name in the history books is anishikiri
who just gave a shake of his head so
Tanya he was looking confident he got up
from the board in his suit jacket he
just shook his head so there was a
variation he's calculating
in his advantageous position that he
doesn't like anymore so it's going to be
interesting to see how he replies and
there he goes he just responded with the
move Bishop C5 to B4 and let's just do a
before and after an instant replay the
evaluation bar up around plus 1.8 almost
two pawns better for white he plays
Bishop to B4 and that evaluation goes
down it still is a large Advantage for
white but that was according to the
engine inaccuracy and Tanya what do you
think about that move Bishop before do
you think it gives Magnus more chances
I think it's a it's a natural move it's
a human move you know your Bishop's
attack you feel you've got these two
Bishops you're they're putting so much
pressure on the black king you want them
to stay alive now Anish is threatening a
devious idea of 94 or Knight B5 hitting
that night on D6 and that would mean
material loss for black so actually
magnets cannot allow the Knight on C3 to
remain alive anymore Robert there is no
way that you can keep that dark Square
Bishop I think Magnus has to give up
that bishop and you look at him he still
knows that it is worse from him he's
he's got almost a little bit of a smile
on his face I feel which is kind of
strange to see uh it's interesting to
see uh see how he's responding to this
position meanwhile Anish played Bishop
B4 got out of his chair walking around
yes he seemed a little unsure about his
how to proceed but that is chess you're
not gonna have forced variations all the
time Anish has done the max that he
could Bishop before dropped a tiny bit
of his Advantage wasn't perhaps the best
move but I still think it keeps majority
of it Anish is better
but again will it be enough to beat
Magnus Magnus knows that the worst is
behind him The Rook on h8 will come out
he will take on C3 he will develop that
Rook
the question is will Magnus be able to
hold this position or not right now it
looks like he is a lot more comfortable
than he was just a few moves ago
one small note I'll make is if the a
pawns were off the board black would be
feeling a lot better about this position
why because with pawns on both sides of
the board in general both sides of the
board you take bishop and not Knights
are slow moving pieces so there's going
to be a Target on A7 that black will
need to keep an eye on a G7 also is
targeted by this bishop on C3 so Bishop
takes E6 followed by Bishop takes G7 is
a threat the question is how big of a
threat earlier on we were discussing the
opportunity if it arose to give up a
pawn to liquidate into a position that
seemed more measurable so let me just
take us through a situation Bishop takes
E6 uh politics or King takes E6 let's
take with a pawn I think it just looks
better and Bishop takes G7 now white
would be up a pawn a healthy extra Pawn
but then I look at the position and feel
like black also has pretty decent
chances to hold because once the Rooks
are swapped now where is that extra Pawn
it's on G3 it's hard to mobilize that
pawn and create a pass Pawn with so many
pieces on the board with black getting
activity a good knight that is on a
light Square attacking your Bishop in
the current position so Tanya well I'm
not going to argue about the fact that
Anish will have an advantage likely for
the rest of the game it's is it going to
be enough to win and just from the
standpoint of how is the player feeling
I just think that Magnus has to be a bit
happier now than he was before because
all that tension the pins the back rank
problems The Rook stuck in the corner
that in many of the variations that are
undoubtedly swirling through his head
that Rook gets out his pieces will not
be pinned so I just think that he can
breathe a little easier not that it's
over not that he uh can take his eye off
of the board here but I just feel like
you just think all right what happened
before it's uh not quite as bad as I
initially thought
100 that was what I was saying Robert
that indeed it looks like the worst is
behind Magnus he just had
such an awful looking position with that
King stuck on the background The Rook
from h8 not moving now we see that a
couple of exchanges have taken place
Black's King has come out it is progress
white keeps trumps whites got these two
amazing Bishops on the board the big
question of course as we've been saying
it will it be enough to take the full
point home against the world champion
who is an eight times winner of the Tata
steel Masters now we see Anish in the
background we also saw Parham taking a
look at this position this is such a
such a such an important game for the
tournament uh Robert you know wherever
Magnus plays for many players for for
the audience for spectators it feels
like it's a race for second place and it
almost feels like a given that the guy
is going to take everything he's just
Unstoppable when he's informed he has
been saying that he's feeling a little
shaky about his play in this tournament
not just that historically he hasn't
started strong at Tata steel Masters
this is the first time in the event that
he has been in trouble and speaking of
trouble look at the decision that Magnus
takes trying to get out of all the
trouble of the position he decides to
sacrifice a Pawn on A5 giving up the a
pawn is a huge commitment that you've
done for the rest of the game you will
be down upon white will have a passer
and Magnus has to have a clear path a
clear idea how he plans to stop that A1
Pawn notice that Bishop on D5 notice how
that Bishop on D5 controls the A8 Square
in imagine Anish picking up the A5 pawn
and just marching down the board I am
shocked with this decision of A5 Robert
you've got to break this down for us
what does Magnus want with the spawn
sacrifice
he's giving up the pawn to distract the
bishop for a moment and also to allow
his Rook the time to go to C8 just to
backtrack a single move here Rook seat
is the movie you want to play going to
an open file but as we've been
discussing Knight E4 taking advantage of
the pin on the knight in D6 so A5 says
go away stop pinning me you take a pawn
The Rook comes the C8 now 94 is just the
offer of a trade so Magnus is
essentially suggesting that he's okay
being down the a pawn but not for the
long run as you're correctly assessing
the bishop on D5 is an absolute monster
covering the queening square if the
bishop say could go to B6 A4 A5 A6 a7a
looks borderline Unstoppable but there's
so many pieces on the board the Knight
on C3 is loose let's say you move your
knight back to E2 it looks like a very
natural move this Rook can maybe land on
C2 at long last black is getting some
activity to work with not not that the
position is easy not that the position
is good but Magnus finally will get his
Rook away from h8 into the action and
White's gonna remain up a pawn Anish
doesn't have to worry he's not concerned
but what he does have to deal with is
Newfound peace activity for black and
I'm going to keep saying it because I do
think it is an essential point you want
to think about what trades are
acceptable for you what trades will
allow your opponent's defensive tasks to
be easier and Anish of course he takes
the pawn A5 I'm mainly curious at how
quickly Magnus responds and I can barely
get the words out of mouth he does play
Rook to C8 so now it's up to a niche to
figure out where this Knight on C3 goes
just one last Point Tanya is they have
Knight E4 I think swapping Knights is
not a step in the correct direction
because once you trade Rooks white is
still better we're never going to argue
that point but black gets activity maybe
Rook C4 maybe Rook over to A4 and the
King does feel much safer in the sound
of the board if there are fewer pieces
remaining
it's very lucky that Magnus in this
particular position will have the
resource of Rook C4 because otherwise
the threat of Bishop B4 is so powerful
Robert so the move that you intuitively
wanted to make is super important you
not only gain a Tempo hitting the bishop
but you stop a white Bishop from giving
a check and then followed by pressure on
A2 and A5 uh and for the first time in a
long time in this game we see Magnus
Carlsen get up and take a breather he's
left aboard that definitely is a sign
that he feels a lot more comfortable in
the current position he sacrificed that
pawn to get a the time and the tempo he
needed to get that Rook out the thing
about these top players is that until
all their pieces are in the game if not
all the armies playing the development
is incomplete there is a sense of strong
discomfort they want all the pieces out
all the activity even if it means that
the cost of a pawn and that's what
Magnus has done we were looking at
different lines of giving up the bishop
for the night trading it getting out of
the pin but no he decides to keep it he
decides to keep maximum pieces instead
sacrifices upon for activity and now
again the ball is in anisha's court will
he decide to go for these trades that
you're pointing out where once again we
saw the eval bar dip just slightly lower
than what it is and your margin of
Advantage keeps getting less and less
Robert I'm gonna put you on a spot here
predict a result in this game
wow I didn't expect you to do that to me
I feel a little thrown under the bus but
I will forgive you
a result oh my gosh
I'm gonna go with a niche win I think
that he has this long-term advantage and
what Tony and I are talking about we're
going back and forth about is the fact
that certain positions are easier than
others but it's never going to be easy
and this outside pass Pawn gives great
potential so I think that Anish has
amazing chances to win this game because
I just don't see how Magnus gains that
pawn back or really creates the
necessary threats and one variation is
going through my mind as I'm saying this
let's say you want to keep all the
pieces on the board if you are a niche
and you want to bring your knight
forward with a move like Knight to A4
threatening Knight to B6 here with a
fork something I was thinking about is a
very natural looking sequence of like
Bishop B4 Rook takes A4 if you take on
E6
and well okay I can take on before here
I realized but I was just gonna go for
this position Rook takes D6 check King
to F5 the king actually is very safe on
G6 and this is what I've been trying to
get to White is up a pawn white will
remain up upon when you push it to A3
but it's a blockaded pawn and that's the
only extra material in the position
Black's King is safe you probably feel
like you can hold this game with
actually a high degree of certainty so
this is the future that Magnus Carlson
can only dream of and Anish should keep
as many pieces on the board unless
there's a concrete reason to swap
keeping peace on the board makes Black's
life harder because there is a king in
the middle in the center there are
Bishops taking control of important
squares left and right so I really
believe that a niece should try to keep
some peace on the board unless there is
a specific reason to trade them off
wow that line you just pointed out I'm
still thinking about it Knight A4 is
quite a move Robert because you have a
direct threat of forking the Rooks on B6
Knight B6 is your idea which is why you
want to move that Rook away but as you
were playing out that line I think
that's not even the worst uh that black
has to fear by the way Anish about to
make a move with the Knight and he
chooses
I feel it's it's heading towards the
center is it A4 does he go Knight A4 he
went Knight A4 wow on the board as
Robert was calling out and the points
that was there Robert while you were
showing this line Rook A7 trying to
sidestep that fork Magnus also has to
watch out for the idea after Rook A7
Bishop B4 that you said
if we just make the move
and Rook takes A4 you are pointing out
the line with taking on E6 but here
white can even pick up the Knight on D6
with a check because after Bishop D6
King D6
and my first feeling was that this just
is blunder because of Bishop B3 but I
realized that you've got Rook D4 and why
is the eval bar still so skyrocketing
for white this way it should be seven
that's the way you go yeah because King
C7 lit by Rook check and you're picking
up this Rook for free so you'd be up in
exchange but even this Tanya if we just
continue for a second here let's say you
take this here and Rook takes A2 this
doesn't look that easy to win unless
you're winning a pawn somehow and you
probably are but uh you imagine a
position like this where you're up in
exchange and you think in advance oh
that King might go to G6 if I don't win
F7 then how am I going to win this game
F2 is a bit of a Target so this is just
like the hope that Magnus has is like
let me get to some worse end game I'm
going to be worse no matter what but at
least there's limited material and
there's not the clearest path forward so
you asked me I answered I do think Anish
Gary is going to win this game it just
remains way too complex with the king in
the center with pins with strong piece
placement for the white Brooks and I
don't think despite the fact that these
pieces are close together here I just
don't feel like black has the harmony
between his pieces
984 is actually quite an amazing move I
mean it's so it's so difficult to
imagine to put your knight at the corner
the edge of the board and to walk into
these ideas where your bishop and Knight
are on the same file and you can go Rook
A7 and hit them together it just shows
the kind of form that Anish is in he's
calculating the lines he's being
concrete he's not just saying that I'll
go Knight to E4 to the Central Square
I'll trade off the knights I'm up upon
I've got these two Bishops I have a
feeling that it's better for white he's
not playing on feeling he is playing on
pure calculation here he has seen these
ideas and he believes that's his best
chance and the eval bar seems to confirm
that and it's to me it's very impressive
the decision to play Knight A4 is
amazing stuff you're threatening Knight
B6 but you need to calculate these lines
with Rook A7 and once again Anish makes
the move gets up and we don't realize it
but as players we know that these have a
lot of psychological impact as well when
you're your player when your opponent
makes moves quickly their strong moves
doesn't sit on the board it just feels
like the pressure on you is piling up
and that's what makes the opponent
crumble
it does indeed and something that we've
been doing is going back and forth with
like oh it looks much better for Niche
it's too difficult for black to play but
there's this hope that if we trade these
pieces the defensive task is easier and
that is what's going through the
player's Minds at one point we caught a
niche on camera looking at a position
and then shaking his head looking
frustrated so uh the players are trying
to visualize the future that maximizes
their chances in the case of Anish Geary
is to win the game for Magnus Carlsen is
to hold and it's really a situation
where it's not going to be easy the line
we just looked at just to show again
that if you take this Knight on A4
Bishop takes D6 check where exactly is
your king going maybe the E8 to stay out
of Harm's Way but this Rook comes into
B7 the bishop protects A2 this bishop
can't move off the C file because if you
go to date in comes Bishop C6 check and
mate not just winning The Rook on A4 so
I feel like they're just too many
problems right now to solve with
material on the board so it's Niche
Geary he is playing this very
intelligently he didn't bring his Knight
to E4 and swap he is keeping his Knight
in a menacing position trying to go to
B6 with a fork and good luck to Magnus
Carlson I mean the moves are not getting
easier right now because he is keeping
peace on the board so if we just go back
I do think Bishop takes C3 and after
Bishop takes C3 this position while
still bad for black would have been
perhaps a little bit easier I see him a
night move that looks good I'm getting
active I'm gonna try to bring my Rook to
d8 or to C8 so it's a bit of Hope chess
I acknowledge but I just see a clear
path forward for Black's pieces compared
to the game where they feel stuck
it's excellent play by Anish so far and
there is so much at stake at this game
this is the Wimbledon of chess the Tata
steel Masters this is what sets the tone
for the rest of the Year this is the
biggest the most prestigious chess event
and there's one player playing with the
black pieces who's won it eight times he
is the eight-time champion Magnus
Carlsen and then Anish giri who has had
such a phenomenal run he's finished
runners-up he's finished second five
times in the event as we can see uh
there a niche at 28 he has been playing
this event as a child he's gone through
the different events happening in
vikanze and reaching the Masters where
he's finished runners-up so many times
it's so close yet so far to the
championship he's played the playoffs
fighting for the title been on the
receiving and lost those Robert it would
mean so much for him to win this event
it's still very early on and this is
just round four but any classical
tournament where you end up beating
Magnus Carlsen you know that the job is
half done because he truly is the
biggest obstacle for these best players
in the world in any given tournament in
their pursuit of the championship
and look at Magnus right now I mean he
looks like he's in shock he is trying to
work it out and as you said beating
Magnus Carlson is a huge step in the
right direction but if if we pause for a
moment and we think about the tournament
at large if Anish wins this game and no
deer Beck or ding are unable to win then
he will be in clear first place after
four rounds but then I look at the names
on that list like dingley Wren like you
know five minute Quran who Nisha already
played uh like no dear Becca busitar of
Wesley so Etc
and he starts to get through all of them
so even if he does go on to win this
game he is going to be thrilled through
the roof but he can save the celebration
for after the event because beating
Magnus is a lifetime achievement
but you want to win the tournament and
that's just one step you're not even a
third of the way through the tournament
so Anish he has pressure on himself he
really wants to win a big event and none
bigger for him then the Wimbledon of
Chess in its 85th Edition in the
Netherlands for him a drive away he is a
Dutch player the number one player from
the country but when you reflect on your
career and you see that the number two
player Jordan Von Forest he was the
first Dutchman in decades to win the
tournament that does have to sting so
Anish you know he's a friend of mine we
talk regularly and he is you know
generally in good spirits but you have
to imagine that getting this title would
be so Monumental for what has already
been in illustrious career it will take
it next level
I couldn't agree more with that and I
also get to a point that even if he was
to cross this one big hurdle the
tournament is so long and the
illustrious field is so strong that it
is still early days but once again
Magnus Carlsen is the biggest obstacle
and then just the joy of being able to
beat Magnus in a classical game is
something that few experience going into
the rest day that would be a the best
case scenario and I think this game has
so much at stake for a niche so far it
looks like he's got a dream position
he's played an opening where he took
some aggressive decisions Magnus Carlson
Landing in trouble but of course Magnus
is gonna fight tooth and nail to save
this one we see the current board with
us Robert Rook A7 is the move that we
are looking at for Magnus he's still
having a think he's taken about nine
minutes the players are on their 30th
move they have to keep the clock in mind
as as well Magnus has about 15 minutes
on his clock to make another 10 moves a
niche about a little more than 20
minutes so the clock could play an
important factor in a critical moment as
well that's not something to forget
currently uh Madness again looks a
little frustrated with what is going on
it's not easy to land up in a bad
position and then have to fight it to
save it but that's what the world
Champion's been doing this entire game
we see Arjun aragassi behind him walking
around and a niche there just crossed
the camera who's looked very comfortable
from start to finish Robert let's pull
up our analysis board and take a look at
what exactly are the lines that can save
Magnus in this crucial game and this
crucial moment
uh Rook A7 is what you were meant sorry
go on no I was gonna say can I just not
make any moves since I'm not sure we
were talking about Rook A7 I still loved
White's position so uh I'm gonna sit
here silently and Ponder the answer to
that question for eternity
well Magnus has only about 14 minutes to
ponder to that question and
it's because he's got 10 moves still to
be made
and the I got the feeling that he was
about to reach out well Rook A7 felt
like the most attractive response to
Knight A4 taking advantage of the pieces
that are lined up on the a file if not
White's plan is clear you want to jump
night with B6 forking or even think
about coming back with your Bishop to B4
winning that Knight on D6 so some
massive threats there and not an easy
moment for Magnus we see Anish there in
the background the tension is high in
his mind and his heart Anish knows that
this is a dream position to have against
Magnus but this has happened so many
times including the recent uh World
Championship Blitz where Anish was
dominating that game but missed the
trick and Magnus eventually went on to
win that end game so this has happened a
couple of times Anish needs to keep the
past behind him and believe that he can
do this he can beat the world champion
it's I know that this might sound this
might sound easy but I think even for
the best players in the world it's a
psychological barrier that they struggle
to break
it certainly is I mean Magnus Carlson
he's been the best player in the world
for so long that when you face him you
quadruple check all your variations
you're worried that he's gonna find a
way out he can be a magician but right
now he looks frazzled so let's leave him
to his task for the moment there are
other games still underway for in fact
and as we look at the bottom right hand
side of our screen between Jordan but
forest and gukesh it looks like pieces
have been traded so we're in a position
where there's still life left because
white has a pair of Bishops black has a
knight and Bishop the Queens are on the
board but the attack never got started
that's good news for gukesh next to it
second from the right down there Vincent
kymer Arjuna geisi Brooke Knight Queen
Five Pawns per side the material is
level but with black having the outside
pawn and white having extra Pawn towards
the center there's a dynamic that
doesn't make it as a dead draw now the
game that's really interesting as uh
Magnus surprise Knight to C4 by the way
so we will look at that in a moment I
just want to draw our attention to the
top right where it looks like probably
Ananda has actually been outplaying
dangly Wren whose King is in the center
and if we can I want to pump the
abusator of game on screen quickly
because that one is looking electric at
this stage uh the king is wide open
parham's King on H7 not looking very
safe so we'll quickly go to the game
between norderbeck and Parham because
black is up a past Pawn but the King on
H7 the queen on C6 Rook on E6 causing
that King some serious problems Tanya
this is a very dynamic position it's a
tactical position and I feel like white
despite having facing this past Pawn
here should be better because of King
safety
a hundred percent I don't know how much
better he is I see that about Baron does
say that white is doing well with the C3
Pawn definitely gives hope to Black here
now there are some concrete problems
your Bishop on F6 the E is under Fire
it's attacked you can't move it because
the G6 Pawn hangs there's no way that
you can give that pawn and survive to me
it looks like King G7 might be the only
move in the position you'd could also
consider Queen D1 check and then C2 but
let's show that the problem with that
line if you go Queen D1 King H2
and after C2
Robin there are so many ideas here even
even the option of taking on F6 you can
take on C7 with a check that is
something you can start with Rook F6
looks really attractive the eval bar
will tell us if Rook F6 actually works
turns out that it does Queen to C1 and
I'm guessing the move has to be
what is it
oh my god wow
and queen H1 your king is safe on G3
what a line Robert there's no check on
F4 and if you go to D6 I take your queen
here so this is about to be a Checkmate
you have a rook and a knight for that
Queen but the king safety that's
Paramount that tells the tale and that
is why Parham in the position went King
to G7 he protects this bishop and now an
important Point Rook takes F6 it removes
the defender of The Rook on 8 but it's
actually a losing decision because after
Queen F6 Queen takes eight pause white
is up at night should be winning right
not so fast C2 and there's no way for
this queen to stop this Pawn so black is
completely winning the C6 Square under
blacks control that means a new Queen
will appear on the board and that means
that Parham would win so instead look at
this move Knight to E5 if you take this
Knight on E5 you're gonna have trouble
once The Rook takes back C3 is loose the
king is open uh the queen has to stay in
touch with his Rook on A8 see 7 G5 I
just feel like despite the evaluation
Tanya if black doesn't get the piece off
the board it's going to be trouble
well I keep looking at these lines of
trying to promote the C pawn and that's
what's coming to my mind and let's just
point out that before if black doesn't
trade the Knight on E5 you're just
busted because that Knight is so strong
there are way too many threats for
example here the idea of Queen D1 King
H2 C2 runs into similar problems that
we've been talking about you can't take
Rook takes F6 the G6 Pawn is hanging
everything hangs and once again this
will be game over so black in fact after
Knight E5 Robert will be forced to pick
up that Knight and trade it and once
again it's the king safety that will be
a big problem but I think the C Pawn
gives black enough chances there to hold
let's take a look at this you take
Bishop E5 Rook E5
and queen D1 check
King H2 I'm really scared to make this
move because I feel that if I would and
then the eval bar is going to shoot
right up but I'm gonna try it anyway C2
here trying to Queen trying to make a
chance and once again we see this is the
wrong decision because you can just take
on C7 I'm guessing let's see Queen 67 is
good King H6 there's Rook E7 going for
mate over here that looks very
interesting but Rook h8 apparently is
even somehow Queen E5 attacking it
oh my gosh there's rookie H7 you cover
all the squares and it's a draw because
once you trade Rooks there's going to be
checks with the queen that is
unbelievable and we might see this we
see 95 King H2 so take any five with
check is forced The Rook takes back and
there is also the move Queen D6 so I am
looking at this move because the Rook is
pinned if you take the rook in the court
The Rook in the corner here you lose
your Rook with check you lose the game
and if you take the queen after Paul
takes the Rook gets the C8 behind your
past Pawn that's bad news so what do you
do queen takes C3 Rook E8 looks winning
for black because you are piling up
pressure on the pin piece but this is
where things get amazing F to F4 Tanya
blocking the pin and now the black king
needs to be very careful because the
white Rook is free to go
and we might be heading there because as
we can see on the live board this is the
action that you're calling out has
happened play by play Queen C3 on the
board Robert and now F4 is in the air
regardless of whether you play rookie 8
or not because once I can get out of
this pin along the B8 H2 diagonal again
your king is super unsafe I see the eval
bar it says that white is better rookie
it F4
what is the what is the evaluation in
the King Pawn and King Pawn end game
we've got to take a look at this Rook E5
I don't believe white can go Queen E5
right because after the queen trade
black has the outer pass Pawn he's a
king F7 King E6 you take and the C Pawn
goes and promotes so this would be a bad
decision so that's why the Queens stay
on as you were suggesting here and white
is better because the pawn structure is
bad over here for black the E5 Pawn is
the most advanced Pawn not saying it's
winning but also the black king isn't a
bit of danger if E6 can be played
very tricky position but it does look
like black will also have some trumps
and will be able to maybe hold on that
would be my prediction for this one I
think if rookie 8 and we get a Queen
spawn end game uh it feels like Parham
might survive this but for now it does
look like not a Bex the one who after
this a tactical Skirmish of exchanges
has come out slightly on top according
to our eval bar as we are seeing this
line with rookie at F4 really cool stuff
we will keep an eye out on this let's
zoom out and get an update on the other
boards Robert as well as the clock runs
low for most of the players well I have
to take us back to a niche giri versus
Magnus Carlson because look at the eval
bar on that board I mean the Knight went
into C4 and then White's Rook went over
to C1 to Simply attacking the Knight the
bishop on A5 does look loose but if you
take the bishop you lose your Rook on C8
so the night is under attack and it is
pinned so Tanya the the move here for
black seems very hard to find
well the good news is that white isn't
exactly threatening to take on C4 so you
might have a little bit of time to do
something because let's say it's White's
move here if you take Rook take C4 black
recaptures the rook and notice that Rook
on D1 and The Rook on D7 The Rook on D1
is pin so Rook C4 runs into Rook C4
meanwhile if you take with the bishop
black can respond with Rook D1 coming in
with a check and then capture on C4 so
Robert the Saving Grace here for Magnus
is that Rook C1 it pins the Knight it
saves that Bishop on A5 but at least
white isn't threatening to grab the
Knight how can black use this momentum
because White's got some ideas of his
own Bishop B4 check is an idea at some
point that you have to watch out for how
do you respond to Rook C1 is Bishop G5
an option
Bishop G5 might just be met by F4
kicking the bishop back so ah this I'm
trying to find even individual moves
here uh but I just want to show your
point because it is a really good one if
black played H6 and you see the evil bar
doesn't change all that much if you take
on C4 with the bishop The Rook trade
happens and as you pointed out the Rook
can take the bishop on C4 if you lead
with the Rook you just lose the material
because after Rook take this is amazing
you don't even lose material because
there's Knight to B6 but the point was
that the bishop takes C4 Rook takes D1
then you actually lose material black
would be up a rook for a bishop and pawn
but because there are tactics here with
Knight B6 white would still be ahead
that's amazing stuff so Bishop E5 was
Max's choice and Tanya the eval bar
keeps going up and up and up and Anish
Geary may be up from the board right now
but when he sits down he is going to be
happy about this move in all likelihood
I'm just trying to understand Bishop E5
so it's clear that Magnus doesn't fear a
trade on C4 because of the ideas that we
saw with the Rook on D1
is the point of Bishop E5 that if Anish
was to fall with a check on B4 Bishop to
B4 check
does he want to go King to f
6
has he just vacated that square for the
king is that the point I think so but
the tactics are going to favor white
because Knight C5 can be played cutting
off circulation between rook and Knight
on C4 if you take on C5 this Rook takes
on C4 and there is a pin along the C
file so if you try to defend with Rook
to C7 I simply go Bishop A5 kicking your
Rook out the way and when your Rook
moves back the bishop slide into B6 and
they're just problems left right and
Center Tanya it is miserable and let's
not forget about the little a pawn that
could because if black is all tied up in
knots the a pawn will just Sprint to the
other side
there is no little leap on that is a big
a pawn Robert and it has a clear path
ahead of it with this bishop on D5
controlling it it's always something
black has to keep in mind all trades of
heavy pieces will always favor white
white will end up in a winning end game
if the heavy piece is trade off Anish
comes back to the board this is a huge
moment we see it's almost a winning
Advantage there are all these ideas
possible after Bishop B4 check that we
are pointing out Anish completely
focused there when you're playing
against Magnus you cannot afford to lose
your concentration for even one move one
inaccuracy and he's back in the game
Anish that takes off his jacket he's
gonna sit back there Magnus gets up from
his chair and leaves the niche to think
this through I think just sitting on the
board looking at this position is hard
enough for Magnus
yeah I wouldn't want to look at that
position either and Anish Gary locked in
he is hovering over the board and if he
finds this tactic Bishop B4 check feels
very natural even if just to drag the
king out to F6 uh but one thing that
white needs to be careful about you
might want to play the pawn F2 to F4 to
attack the bishop but you need to look
out for a move like Bishop D4 check
cutting off The Rook on D1 from the
bishop on D5 so just like we were saying
the Knight was coming to C5 to cut off
Black's Rook from a minor piece uh black
could try to do the same if white is not
looking out for it but Bishop B4 check
and Knight C5 it just you know pins
everything in Black's position and the a
pawn is extra without that a pawn Tanya
the position actually might not be that
terrible for black but ever since Magnus
played A5 if we just go back to that
moment here where he played A5 to
distract the Bishop from his pin here
that has been the extra Pawn for white
and it's going to be the actual Pawn
until it becomes a queen
just amazing geometry in the position
with all the minor pieces on the board
the two Rooks the heavy pieces the major
pieces all attacking each other so much
pressure on black and we have to take a
look at this line because I'm I'm pretty
certain that Anish will make the move
Bishop B4 here you want to move that
Bishop away you want to try and put more
pressure Knight C5 coming in and let's
just show the different kind of dangers
that are there with the pins that you've
been pointing out a Robert Bishop B4
King F6 and I want to just expand on
that line a little bit Knight C5 Knight
C5 Rook C4 now when you had this on the
analysis board my first thought was wait
a second can't black just play Rook C7
because you're talking about all these
pins I'm just gonna sidestep them Rook
C7 and if you go Rook C1 which might
seem like a natural response to double
up the pressure look at the bar coming
down and that's because my Rook on C7 is
defended I can't jump in with the Knight
on C5 to D3 my Rook c7s defending at
least I don't lose material let's back
up what is the problem after Rook C7 and
the answer is that this is where the
power of the Bishops comes in you go
Bishop A5 you dislodge that Rook from C7
and after this whether you go to A7 or
you move your Rook to D7 it doesn't
matter because white will continue
putting pressure on the C5 Knight but
let's say you make the move Rook D7 here
and now Bishop comes in from B6 Robert I
take away the C7 Square I'm still
attacking your knight and with this
little Bishop dance I have put all my
pieces in optimal places to attack your
knight to win material and that is the
power of a bishop pair in an open
position
it's too much to deal with if you are
Magnus Carlson and the a pawn the little
a pawn that could uh you know it's going
to run to the other side of the board
and become a queen so it's problems
everywhere and you can't solve them all
like this position you might not lose at
night actually you might lose the Knight
I say Bishop to D6 but like even a move
like Bishop to back on this diagonal
Bishop F3 you have a new PIN to worry
about in addition the one that already
exists and a skewer down the diagonal
like every move you make has some other
problem to it and black is really just
struggling to find individual moves that
don't lose material and if you lose any
more material you of course are going to
lose the game so if after the move
Bishop B4 check and Knight C5 if Anish
finds and plays that he will be in great
shape but he is down to about 11 minutes
and it's moved 31 has just been played
so he has nine moves to make to reach
the time Patrol and when he starts
seeing things and you think okay that
doesn't look as winning as I would like
or I see an opportunity for black to
create some complications that's when
you start to go wrong especially when
you do not have much time remaining
I saw a niche that reaching out as you
were mentioning the clock does take low
for him he's taken about six and a half
minutes for this movie he's got nine
moves to make to reach time control to
reach that 40 move Mark which will give
the players an additional 50 minutes
for the next 20 moves and once they
reach move 60 they get an additional 15
minutes for the rest of the game of
course every move that they play every
time they press the clock they also all
through the game from move one get an
increment of 30 seconds but the clock
does matter right now Anish is burning
the time a little bit he's got nine
moves to make to meet the first time
control and this could prove to be
critical in magnus's path to saving this
game so he needs to be a little Careful
by the way Anish has made a move
um
no Bishop nope I don't have a move from
him he hasn't no he hasn't made a move
yet I did see him reach out but it
looked like he was reaching out for
something on the king side Robert and I
I don't understand what that might be
what his idea might be
Bishop B6 looks like a direct line
with such a concrete follow-up and a lot
he's about to make a move he does look
like he's looking at the king side so I
am wondering what he's eyeing over here
and now he paused again so he is not
certain of his next choice and he plays
Bishop there should be four on the board
so maybe he was just you know trying to
trick us he knows that we're
commentating so he's like he's trying to
confuse where where is he going what's
he doing uh of course he sees the
correct continuation with Bishop B4
check and he gets up from the board once
again where is Magnus going to move his
King to if he goes back to E8 or d8 it
looks very awkward um just to show you
if the king to E8 um Knight C5 hasn't
gone away as well you take on C5 I still
take on C4 not only is there this pin
rookie one will be a pin your Brooks are
still on the same line as each other and
your king is in line with this other
Rook it's not very pretty for Magnus and
Bishop B4 he has not responded to
because he's feeling the heat of these
minor pieces against the black king
against Black's pieces left and right
it spins all over the board and
anisha's piece player has been
spectacular in this game we've had the
eval bar guiding us throughout but there
he's been sitting finding one accurate
move after the other just keeping his
Advantage keeping the tension bringing
the heat on he's played a Flawless game
so far and it looks like he's getting
closer and closer to taking this one
home we do have a move from Magnus he
moves the king away to the most active
spot a natural move to make really King
to F6 you don't want it on the last
track dealing with threats there King F6
played and now will Anish find the very
strong idea that we were talking about
Robert intercepting the support on the
C4 Night by The Rook on C8 with the
spectacular Knight C5 he's gonna find it
I mean look at the way he is positioned
he sees that the end could be near and
he wants to find this move and beat
Magnus Carl person I mean he means so
much to him it's not overstaying the
case at all he only beat Magnus Carlson
one time and it was their first game and
that was a dozen years ago so since then
it's been all Magnus Magnus has become
the world champion the number one rated
player in the world has beaten a niche
six different times and when they play
in online formats Magnus is also beating
him so you know kind of to
punch back a little bit especially in an
event that means so much to you and has
since you were a child that's going to
be a memory to store for a life to tell
his you know two kids one no I beat
Magnus Carlson and the white side of
this position in vikon Zay 2023 so
Knight C5 is where our focus is Tanya
are there any other moves because I'm
not really seeing others that catch my
eye the way Knight C5 does
let's see if I just feels like such a
direct line you need to just precisely
calculate these complications that arise
after the trades but Robert just the
point that you were making a niche
hasn't shied away from concrete precise
calculation he's met them and he's
played them and he's done it fast that
has been super impressive as he was
saying beating Magnus in a classical
format in over the board it's rare that
that occurrence ever happens in a stage
like this where Magnus has won the event
eight times Mark Anish has come second
five times so much at stake also just
the joy of beating the strongest player
on the planet you're so close to it
Anish has played a near Flawless game
and
I'll be honest if Magnus does survive it
kudos to Magnus for being resourceful
but it will be heartbreaking for a niche
there's nothing more upsetting than
spoiling a winning position and I think
you know it's nothing more upsetting
than winning position against the best
player of all time you want to get this
Victory here so the king is out in F6
the Knight can't go to C5 and look at
the clocks I mean we have a bunch of
moves to make it to the time control and
when you see someone start to dip near
five minutes that's when you worry about
an inaccuracy showing up a mistake being
played that doesn't win a winning game
and that's the famous quote right the
hardest game to win is a one position
and for a niche he doesn't want to see
that come to fruition
that would definitely be very
heartbreaking but I think Anish right
now with full focus is calculating these
Knights once lines once again he's down
to six and a half minutes on the clock
he still has eight moves to make and
this is magnus's Big Hope inaccuracy is
when the clock runs low and we've seen
this play out so many times
I hope for anisha's sake that's not the
case this time but once again this is
what gives Magnus his chances right now
that Anish needs to sit and calculate
but he needs to do it fast he needs to
believe in his calculation and he's to
make those moves now Knight C5 Robert
we've got to look at this what are the
Alternatives because it's just such a
forcing line on the board and we see
Anish reaching out there but that was
just for his hair
he wants to make sure he's looking sharp
for the cameras when he takes home this
full point uh but there is a sense of
nervousness to him and the reason why
we're asking what other moves are there
is because if Knight C5 were you know
clear six moves down the road Anish
would have played it already there could
be a timely F4 that he's looking at
because let's just throw it on the board
if F4 you play Bishop D4 check I take
you Knight takes and then this Knight on
C4 gets captured and all of a sudden we
have two minor pieces and a pawn for a
rook a winning position for white but
guess what Knight C5 has been played by
Anish Geary he is showing that he just
wants to be meticulous he wants to be
accurate he does not want to let this
win go he knows he's winning I'm sure
Magnus also feels that and so when he
analyze the next few moves Knight C5
Rook takes C4 uh you're not getting out
of these pins Tanya Magnus Carlson is
losing this game
Anish giri has been Flawless today he
has played stunning chess raw but Knight
C5 played Magnus immediately takes on C5
it looks like Anish has calculated the
line through he picks up the Knight on
C4 wins that Knight on C5 and now the
big question if Magnus saves that Knight
on C5 with the move Rook C7 will we see
the action that we were calling out with
the bishop hitting that rook and then
eventually hitting the Knight you do the
little dance with the bishop Bishop A5
Bishop B6 or will Magnus go on to
sacrifice and exchange I don't even see
what is the way that he can do that this
just looks like game over Knight A6 is
what you're pointing out and after Rook
takes C8 night before and you still have
some hope alive because you hit the
bishop you're hitting the Rook on D1
you're hitting that pawn on A2 and this
would mean that white if he falls back
with the bishop to B3 you can pick up
the Rook on D1 and pick up the pawn on
A2 and this gives you hope
yeah it's not going to be much over the
bishop Rook C7 on the ball drop at Rook
C7 oh my goodness
can't go Bishop A5 Bishop B6 and win
huge material here this is busted for
Magnus
it certainly is you know he can't move
any of his pieces he is completely stuck
Bishop A5 May Force resignation you look
at Magnus right now and he is not he's
not acting he is not trying to play a
character he is very upset with how
today's game is gone because he was the
one who chose to play a provocative
opening one that he had from the white
side back in 2008. these are all choices
he made so he must have been comfortable
with the position he had studied it and
yet things went completely haywire and
wrong and so with things going off the
rails you're looking to think what did I
do wrong you could that's chess for you
you only have yourself to blame and it
can be lonely it can be isolating uh but
this is a great Champion here and Anish
giri in his own right has been a great
Champion uh people have you know
criticized him and would say what do you
mean Champion he hasn't won anything
he's never won a Super tournament but he
shown you right now that he can beat
Magnus Carlson he has been second second
place at the sermon five different times
you don't see just anybody doing that
and I think we're about to see a niche
play the move Bishop A5 to kick the Rook
out of C7 and then bring this bishop
into B6 taking advantage of a pin on the
C file
he's reaching out for it I think this is
just a moment that we all need to just
take in because it's massive and he goes
for it Anish giri Unstoppable today
in round two with the white pieces so he
has looked very sharp with the first
move Advantage first against gukesh a
couple rounds ago now against Magnus we
can't forget his games is black where he
played against Fabiano caruana and if
anything he was the one who had a
preferable position then against para
maxulu no trouble there so Anish giri
has been as close to perfect as you can
get in the first four rounds it's still
early in this tournament but Magnus
Carlsen doesn't drop games very often
but nor does Anish giri we mentioned the
stat he has lost seven times in his last
115 games in Vikings a that is not a lot
considering the level of opposition and
well Magnus here he is kind of perked up
a bit he might make one more move two
more moves but he is gonna tip over his
King extend his hand and give and he's
Geary a much desired full point
Magnus looks looks absolutely devastated
right now and I wouldn't be surprised if
the game ends anytime about now losing a
huge material in the current position as
we see Anish has played excellently
throughout from start to finish the way
he handled the opening it reminds me of
his game against kukesh where he came up
with this super nice idea of that small
Rook lift Rook to see to rookie to went
on to sacrifice at night went on to
sacrifice a rook went on to completely
expose black skin and deliver mate and
now again with the white pieces this
time he's taking down the world champion
Magnus in absolute shock at the way the
game has turned out Robert you said he
might resign in a move or two we might
see that happen right now as Magnus
realizes there's no way to defend
material in this position you move the
Rook you save The Rook you lose the
Knight as the bishop jumps into B6 and
the Bishops are doing the talking the
pin is devastating you end up down a
piece in an end game this is game over
for Magnus and he realizes it what a
game by Anish and regardless of what
happens in the tournament at least for
this part of it of the event Anish has
so many reasons to be proud of what he's
displayed today over the board he's
earned his rest day because tomorrow the
players are not competing uh here in the
fern Hall they get to rest they get to
do whatever it is they please before
round five and there it is the clock is
stopped Anish Geary takes down Magnus
Carlson not a site you see every day and
the look of magnus's face is like what
just happened there the players they are
friends they've known each other for a
long time they're discussing uh the game
but Anish is like what was that man how
did you make that mistake you're Madness
wow
and there we have the two players
analyzing the lines but this was an all
a niche giri game Magnus never got a
chance never got a position out of the
opening it went all wrong and Anish made
no inaccuracy in converting it to a full
point and there we see a lot of support
for Anish from our chat as well just
completely deserved for his display of
extraordinary chess today and with this
win he goes into the rest there as one
of the potential sole leaders really
depending on how the rest of the rounds
go but currently Anish on a massive
three out of four and it's not just
about being high up there on the
leaderboard he's done it by defeating
the world champion in a brilliantly
played game
and Magnus you know he's going over the
game with Anis right now he probably is
just trying to figure out where did it
go wrong what would you have done if I
had played this better move and it's
great to see him do that because you
know he's upset the game did not go his
way it was not his day but he loves
chess both these players do and to go
over a tough game with one of the best
players in the world that still is a
worthwhile experience so Magnus is of
course going to be upset about his day
today uh you know his quest to 2900 was
put on hold but it's definitely halted
for sure after today's action because
and each Gary is stealing those rating
points
we see amazing sportsmanship there by
both of them as they discuss the
openings and Magnus there it looks like
he's mentioning that he just uh messed
up and it's going to be I wish we had I
wish we had mics on the players and we
could actually hear their thoughts
Robert that would be amazing to hear
that post-game analysis but from what we
can make at Magnus they're pointing at
the F7 Pawn somewhere F6 Knight H4 ideas
and I think these are the Queen's Indian
ideas that we often see the players
right now are discussing the opening
because right after that it just felt
like huge trouble uh for Magnuson there
we see the Arbiter telling them you know
there's an analysis room right down the
hallway maybe take it there guys but of
course an Asian Magnus involved in
intense analysis there uh and a chess is
taking over right now for these two
players
Robert what do you think you predicted
on a niche win you were on point are you
predicting an Anish tweet as well
I don't think so I think Anish You know
despite all the jokes he makes and you
know the love he has for social media I
think he's also a person who shows the
utmost respect to the opposition to the
champions of the game so I mean if he
tweeted something it would just be
bragging at this point and I don't think
that's a particularly good look he let
his moves do the talking he just played
an excellent game he's in first place
and you know there are a few other games
still going Jordan Von forest and gukash
Drew their game as Magnus and Anish
still are analyzing I love to see it but
there still are three more games and
those games are looking complicated in
the top right between dingley Ren and
progdananda we have an end game where uh
material is even but Black's Pawn
structure is healthier in the bottom
right second from the right we see as
the players in East kyrian Magnus
Carlsen finally leave the playing Hall
we see Vincent kymer and Arjun eragisi
locked up in a queen Rook Knight and
pawn position but I'm still tuning into
the nordier back no deerback Abdus atar
of paramaksudu game Tanya because
neither King looks all that safe to me
and if nodirback can win this game that
puts him in a tie with Anish giri for
first place
that's a big game for not it back and
for Parham both players Parham has also
shown incredible play and let's not
forget that Parham is a last minute
replacement for jantristhoff Duda in
this event so he comes into the
strongest tournament
in featuring the best players in the
world with very little preparation and
despite that he's held his own he's
shown incredible resourcefulness but
that's exactly what he needs to show
right now as well look at that Fearless
move that he just played he moved the
queen from F4 to H4 now most of us mere
models would think about just trading
the Queens off and if we just pull up
the analysis board Robert the first
thing that came to my mind when you were
talking about this game was we're gonna
see Queen E3 check on the board I mean
look at that King on E8 I would never
want the Queens to stay on the board
with my king hanging out absolutely open
in the center of the board but no that's
not Parham and after Queen E3 rookie 3
you know it's an end game it's kind of
hard to believe that white could be a
lot better here I think this would just
end in a draw you've got Rook A3 coming
in you put pressure on the A2 Pawn the
king from E8 will defend the G6 Pawn
nothing to worry about but this is not
Parham style of play Byron makes the
move Queen to H4 instead so keeping the
Queens on the board and very importantly
controlling the h8 square because White
had a trick white wanted to play Queen
h8 with Queen H4 one black stops that
idea second eyeing an E1 check himself
and the big question is after Rook C5
it's really not a question but a line
that we should show it runs into rookie
one check King H2 the only move you give
a check from F4
and now you've got two options Robert
you can either intercept it with the
queen but that would run into Rook H1
where you end up losing the queen
let's just show that and after King H1
you pick up the queen
if not Queen G3
the other option is only worse because
after G3 you run into a checkmate with
Queen F2 so be careful the C5 Pawn yes
it's weak but it can't be picked up and
not a back realizing that has made his
response he falls back with the Rook to
D1 so keeping everything under control
on the e-file that said this is very
ambitious play by Parham to not trade
the Queens because now his King can be
in big trouble
his King is in trouble and this clock
isn't great either he's down under a
minute and he has two moves to make that
doesn't sound like many moves but there
are no checks there are no Queen trades
right now as you point out the queen
needs to stay in contact with h8 and
that's why the queen came to H4 what is
White's plan maybe to bring the Rook to
B1 and give him a b a check this queen
can hop into G7 at some moment so I
actually think with the C5 Pawn under
attack as well that param he makes the
move C4 he actually keeps the evaluation
where it was but these are the types of
games where it's thrown away I move 39
40 41 the stress of the moment as
nordierbeck brings The Rook to F1 Tanya
all of a sudden Queen trying to come to
G7 and Rook f8 Checkmate and the G6 Pawn
is loose the A6 C4 blacks pawns are all
over the place and Parham now down
under 45 seconds to make this final move
40 seconds on the clock one move
remaining and a really difficult moment
and right now he's just thinking why
didn't I trade those Queens when I had
the option but Robert he doesn't shy
away from complications either right now
Parham has to take care of this threat
but Queen G7 as we can see the pawns are
weak but the bigger weakness is black
skin meanwhile white skin is super safe
no checks on Yvonne I love this last
move by not a Beck Rook to F1 there are
no Rook traits possible on E1 and what
white has done with this move is taken
away Black's opportunity to go into
safety with King F7 so it was a
preemptive move stopping Black's King
from getting to a safe spot on the
king's side and queen G7 is a massive
threat he makes the move he finds it in
seconds how does Parham do this
he is living on the edge that's where
that rapid Blitz and bullet pays off
that was the 40th move he gains 50
minutes on the clock uh and he makes
that King D7 move walking his King up
into the open and now there are checks
you know Rook D1 check there's Queen G7
check uh there's Queen D2 check there's
all sorts of things like Queen B4 trying
to go to B7 so there's a lot to figure
out here for Parham but he makes King D7
which turns out to be an accurate move
I would not be able to make that move
for just two seconds on my clock
the only way to explain it is if you
understand this idea that you were
pointing at and let's just put the king
back to E8 now that the players have 50
minutes on the clock they've got time to
just take a breather to calm down to
compose themselves and approach this
position afresh the moment you
understand that white has this really
big idea of going Queen G7 and then your
king is really in the king Zone a
Killzone Rook f8 is a Checkmate coming
in you have to deal with so many threats
and I was mentioning Robert that The
Rook moved from D1 to F1 to stop the
king from getting to safety from F7 but
by doing that black has got the option
to go to the other side and get to
safety you've got to have some nerves to
make the move King D7 but you also
realize that it's the only way to
survive Checkmate Queen G7 would have
been game over if it was allowed and
Parham in seconds finds the move just
brilliant play as you're mentioning the
Iranian Grandmaster has spent so much
time playing faster formats he's so
quick with tactics his tactical vision
is second to no other we've seen him
play aggressive chess he thrives on
complications so this a move like King
D7 it it's like second nature for him
yeah KD7 a huge move and you say safety
I look at the King on D7 I'm like your
definition of safety is a lot different
than mine and no dear back he is
scratching his head here he probably
wants to move his Queen somewhere where
can it go and go to B4 trying to get to
B7 and go to B2 doing the same thing and
the good thing of putting your queen on
B2 is you keep an eye on G7 and D4 Queen
D4 check centralization could be very
useful for black at some moment so
playing Queen to B2 just gives you all
of these options here and this King on
D7 it's just vulnerable to checks but if
black is able to trade off say the Rooks
maybe there won't be a Checkmate so you
at least can feel a little bit better
and I see your eval bar it doesn't give
a massive advantage to white but if
you're a player playing Black I know if
I had the black pieces right now I would
be just thinking that I'm getting
checkmated in the next five moves with
all these checks coming in the queen
jumping into play it's so hard to hold
these positions but param just makes it
move we can see him he's walking around
taking a look on other boards seems
completely relaxed and this is the thing
about these youngsters Robert they're so
concrete and they are not afraid of a
position just because of the way it
looks he's seen the lines he feels he's
got resources of his own for example
you're pointing out now Queen B4 allows
Queen D4 check and nice centralization
that will keep everything under control
and after this you can also think about
getting your Rook to B6 hitting that
Queen stopping the queen from coming in
to B7 just some ideas to keep in mind on
the other hand if you make the move
Queen B2 keeping the D4 Square under
control
at the same time you're threatening
Queen B7 black can centralize the queen
from E4 and now what I do is I stop you
from going Queen B7 check as well I've
put my queen in a nice spot and if you
go Rook F7
I really want to make the move rookie
seven but I'm super scared of the eval
bar screaming that it's wrong but
and just it slightly does go up but
perhaps the moment I made rookie 7 I
also realized that black has got the
option to go King E8 where you actually
gain a Tempo by hitting the Rook on F7
and even this one gives a little
advantage to White that's just how
complicated the game is
yeah I think the reason why this is
better for white is how we started
looking at the position if you play Rook
C7 that threatens Queen B8 Checkmate and
queen h8 check mate so you play Queen
check on E1 the King goes the two and
you get that Queen trade that Parham did
not like earlier the queen has to come
off because it's checked to the white
king and the queen is under attack so
you trade and then after Rook takes C4
we get that end game and param he looked
at this end game and even though there
are drawers Tendencies he was worried
and the reason he was worried was
because in an end game like this no
matter if this Rook is passively
defending or it can be a little bit more
active and stay on like a square like C4
that the white king can Venture on over
the trade that black cannot afford just
to put this on the board is you cannot
take A2 for G6 these types of positions
are typically winning for the side with
the two pass pawns because when the
black pawn goes up the one white Rook
stops it from behind and then whites
Brooks whites Brooks excuse me White's
pawns just Rumble to the the other side
so this is an end game to know to store
in your knowledge your memory bank of
end games a two on none on one side is
and one on the other is different than
if the pawn were on G7 which would be a
drawish position
nicely pointed out there and now we
still have this position I did see
nodded back reach out to make his move
but then he pulled right back so he's
also still thinking there are so many
options which are Super tempting for
white hair we mentioned three of them
already you've got Rook F7 check ideas
you've got Queen B4 you've got Queen B
two you can also give a check right now
yourself with Queen D2 so not about
trying to navigate and see which is the
option that he likes best not easy as
black not easy as white that said if
param had the opportunity to trade
Queens I think he's gonna take it now I
think at this moment with the King on D7
and white out of any threats any back
rank ideas you really want to get rid of
the queen you have to keep in mind the
point that Robert you were trying to
make that your King has to keep the F7
Pawn at the G6 Pawn defended you can't
afford to allow white to connect it
passes two connected passes are way
better than one lone passer on the other
side King D7 on the board Parham walking
around the players have met time control
so they get an additional 50 minutes on
the clock not a back still thinking on
his 41st move
he's going to think for a while because
the time show gives him 50 minutes we'll
see that time added to the clocks
shortly uh when they hit their zeros and
make their moves let's zoom out for a
moment there are other games remaining
uh we promise we will look at the games
between Vincent kymer and Arjun eragisi
that one is looking quite level in
nature in the end game and then the top
right we have prognananda on the black
side position where he is the favorite
now uh dingley runs King is caught in a
bit of a net so we will certainly tune
into that but first we're going to
stretch our legs just like the players
are doing and when we return it is these
final three games in the fourth round of
this year's Tata steel Chess Masters
we'll be right back
foreign
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a
quack quack how to play duck chest the
duck is a brick pieces cannot move
through the square occupied by the duck
okay kind of square to place the dog
huh
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no London's
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemates but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I think I actually am getting
the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the first time
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
I won
yeah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun oh my God
he's gone for it Knight eat a G5 was a
nice Furious choice
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th taught to steal
chess tournament
magnet for the best players in the game
some recognize the Masters field of 2023
as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back there it is the world champion once
again proving that he indeed has the
best technique in the game
the world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title he's like
the nicest person on the planet when it
comes to his chest you just don't want
to mess with it
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps the win
for black Notre back continues his hot
streak the Dutch refer to Tata steel as
The Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
[Music]
on a day when world champion and the
number one rated player in the world
Magus Carlsen suffered defeat the only
other player over 2800 might also suffer
the same fate dingly Ren the top player
from China currently rated 28-11 who has
previously finished second place in the
Tata steel Chess Masters he's facing an
uphill battle against your compatriot
the teenager prognanda so Tanya Prague
is proving that he belongs and right now
he has a better position with black
against dingley red
well Robert I'm still reeling from that
Sensational Anish win and it wasn't just
about the score for me it was also just
the quality of play that Anish displayed
today it was really at the highest level
an opening inaccuracy by Magnus which
ended up in big trouble and there was no
coming back from that we rarely see
Magnus Carlton lose in this way Anish
was really on the top of his game and
speaking about being on top of the game
I think that's what Prague needs to do
now as we can see he has a really
Pleasant end game the reason for that is
that Black's pieces are Super Active the
night on before the rook and C1 more
than that it is White's Pawn structure
Robert a simple concept of Pawn islands
that tells you how many weaknesses aside
has we can see that black has got two
Pawn Islands one on the king side 87 G7
and one as you're pointing out on the
queen side meanwhile white has got three
Pawn Islands which gives him a lot more
weaknesses weaknesses means Target uh
that black can capitalize on it's not an
easy task to convert this but it is
pragnananda's chance to score a massive
upset now Prague has defeated world
number one in faster time controls in
speed chess formats multiple times in
fact but this is the first time that he
plays against the world number two
against England in classical chess their
very first match up against each other
and it looks like ding is in the back
foot here in this end game he's got to
be careful but again it's never easy
when you're playing against a player
like ding it certainly is not the last
replay was Pawn to H4 to defend this
overextended Pawn that was just targeted
on G5 the black king at any moment can
slide into H5 to put pressure on H4 that
pawn is defended for now because of the
Rook on D4 but if this Rook slides the
H1 maybe Prague will just win that pawn
so there is something I want to point
out that let's say I play King H5 and a
move like Rook E4 has played there are
checkmating ideas against this king
that's one thing uh if I could get my
Rook to D3 that is Checkmate but if I go
over to D1 then the Knight can go to E5
to cover the square so if I made some
random move that is Checkmate that's
game over but another thing
this Knight on C4 is kind of a Target
because the king is protecting it so is
The Rook so if you could just give this
check on C5 that would Fork the king of
the Rooks I'm already looking at moves
like Knight A6 or Knight to D3 let's
just get my knight to C5 hit this hit
this hit that I feel like too many of
whites pieces included upon H4 are a bit
too loose for comfort
lots of big threats I love how you're
pointing out that Black's Knight can
jump around and create folking ideas
also the good news for Prague and Prague
fans is that he has made time control so
we see an additional 50 minutes were
added on the clock the players have
reached move 41 and in these kind of
positions that's exactly what you want
you want enough time to find the
accurate path ahead now you were
pointing out H4 and the possibility for
Prague to advance with the King to H5
hit that pawn on H4 but I'm a little
worried about this King position on H5
because it feels like you could also
come into a lot of danger Robert let's
say King H5 and just to demonstrate an
idea I play the move Knight E5
I take away your D3 square and what I'm
really dreaming of is if your knight was
to move away I might suddenly start
threatening moves like Knight D3 hit
your Rook which might even force you to
trade with Knight C5 check Robert
because if you don't
let's just show that if you don't do it
Knight F4 can come in with devastating
effects it's not made because luckily
you can take on H4 but Knight F4 to show
the point King into H4 and now
it still doesn't work Robert because you
have Rook G4
let me go to a different Square uh how
can I make this work rookie one rookie
one is the square that will demonstrate
this perfectly and then you just take it
immediately so that doesn't work either
but we'll be fancy Knight F4 check the
king no matter if it takes it goes up it
gets into the Rooks path so you have a
discover check and you win The Rook so I
get what you're going for unfortunately
there was no way to blunder into it uh
that's a shame but I I think your point
at large is a good one that the Knight
coming into E5 and he did play King H5
and Dink quickly just responded with
Knight to E5 uh it at least on the board
getting white some more activity this
Rook can land on D7 and if you're not
careful if this Rook lands on H7 you can
even Checkmate the black king but as
soon as the Rook releases H4 will drop
but uh Rook E1 comes to my mind as well
this E3 Pawn that you were highlighting
it's just such an eyesore it's a
weakness and you can go right after it
rookie one does hinder all my plans of
trekking with Knight D3 Knight F4 Why
move that Knight on B4 and once again it
will be on ding to find a way a good way
to defend this pawn and it's really not
easy because you can't push it the H4
Pawn is hanging I can't go E4 that will
stop my Rook on D4 defending that H4
Pawn but you have to be a little careful
Robert let's say you play rookie one and
I make the move E4
you still cannot rush in with taking the
H4 Pawn so just to show how tricky
Knights are in the end game you get that
pawn where you end up walking into a
fork and losing The Rook so there are
still certain things that black needs to
be watched needs to be careful about in
this end game absolutely and something
that what you need to be care about is
the Checkmate and so it's funny did I
just walk into that well you know I
guess wait King goes C4 it's time to
check C4 maybe I'm the silly one I
thought it was Checkmate it's not
Checkmate but this still is going to be
good for black kicking The Rook away
taking the E4 Pawn but I really did just
think that was Checkmate in one I'm
gonna be honest
foreign
it's easy to miss that it's not
Checkmate also because the Knight was
covering White's own Knight was on C4
before it moved to c to E5 and that's
just the kind of actual mind games and
mind tricks that happen even when you're
playing a real game of chess so as you
were pointing out rookie one is a big
moment here for Prague and will he be
able to find it Robert it's it's a dream
position that Prague has achieved with
the black pieces against England
is one of the hardest players in the
world to beat and here Prague all of 17
years old in his first Clash against the
2800 plus player looks like the one
who's pushing for a win here
still a long way to go but this is a
dream scenario for him
and just to notify everyone watching
that our generic I see true with the
black pieces against Vincent kymer we
didn't dive into the game but it looked
level throughout so the teenagers split
the point that's really good news for
Arjun because he's had the black pieces
three times in the first four games he
started with black in the first two
rounds he drewga's prognananda in the
first round and then the second round he
drew against Wesley so that was
impressive defense by him then in game
three with white against levonne Ronin
he was in a bit of danger he in fact was
lost according to the engines but it was
very tricky involving the zugs Wong and
now in the fourth game against Vincent
camera he was never in trouble the when
we tuned in earlier it was even a ever
so slight Advantage for him so he's
still in the middle of the pack Tanya
he's been very very impressive in this
tournament because I feel like outside
of the Levon game in three of the four
games he's been you know completely calm
he's controlled the the situation and so
in the next nine rounds he may be able
to score a victory or two
he's definitely got reasons to be
pleased with the way he's played so far
and you mentioned the Levon game but
Robert when you end up holding a game
like that and saving that critical half
a point it gives you so much confidence
as well you've had a long-fought battle
against one of the best players in the
world and you survive that then you know
that yes I found my rhythm in the
tournament I am in shape I can save
difficult positions I'm finding dynamic
continuations as he did against Wesley
as well Arjun aragassi is definitely in
shape the other teenager who has been
playing Amazing chess here is not a back
he is currently one of the leaders he
was one of the leaders at the start of
the game he is at two points out of
three his game still continues and it's
a wild position against farham as we can
see on the bottom left the second board
the King on D7 still at the center of
the board anything can happen it feels
like black can get checkmated at any
moment and Robert I would love to pull
in this game while we wait and see how
Prague shows his technique and ding
defends that game we'll keep an eye out
on it but right now wild action on in
the nordeback versus Parham wild feels
like a bit of an understatement I guess
the reason why it's just wild and not
incredibly wild there aren't too many
pieces remaining but this King on D7 is
not exactly a happy camper where is it
going to find shelter Rook F7 check is
already possible and the king is not
going to the E8 square if you go Rook F7
and the king the queen jumps in and that
is check in mate it's a sort of a ladder
checkmate with the queen and Rook if
your king goes to ca the queen still
goes to f8 because when the queen is
dragged back to d8 the block the queen
comes back to C5 there was a queen on D5
covering that square now the queen is
gone if the King goes to B8 in goes the
queen to A7 and then pick your poison
there's Checkmate in two different ways
over here uh Queen B7 or queen A8 that
would end the game so Tanya that means
the King has to go up to C6 and param
had to see this in advance when he
brought his King to D7 in the first
place he is showing off some incredible
understanding that the king will have to
run up it will go to C5 maybe it will
even go to D4 and into the white
position
and Robert do you still think that this
is just wild and not incredibly wild I
mean with the King running up on C5 D4
down the board a rook and a queen still
giving you checks I would be shaking and
shivering with black meanwhile Arham
super chill he's composed he's walking
around he's made his moves he realizes
that King C6 it's not getting checkmated
but take a look at this brilliant
defense that he's come up with Queen B7
only runs into King C5 and the king is
totally safe the other check that you
have from A4 Queen A4 instead of Queen
B7 black can run to B6 but also
intercept it with Queen B5
just the vision and the realization and
the calculation that your king will be
safe on C5 and on D4 in the lines that
we've been checking is incredible stuff
here Rook F7 so tempting but concretely
it seems to not work out and black is
surviving
right so Rook F7 maybe you hold off on
that move and there are other moves to
player Queen f8 comes to mind because
now after uh this move Rook F7 check is
a much bigger threat let's say I make
some the problem with it having limited
material is you can't really waste moves
it's not easy to do but I was going to
say that if this king is up to C6 now
maybe it is safe but I have more checks
to give this King but Queen CA check
King goes to B5 and look at the
evaluation it started to say even black
maybe ever so slightly better because
the king is running to the other side
and now the white king might find itself
in danger because all of your heavy
pieces are on the other side of the
board
and check this out Robert if you give a
check on B7 Rook B7 after King A4 I
don't see the next check for white
I mean my king is on A4 and you don't
have a check
it's a great king it's a healthy King
they say in the end game you're supposed
to use your King as a weapon uh this
feels not like a pure end game because
there are checkmating threats but the
king is safe here and in fact it is
black threatening a mate of his own if
you make some move like Rook A7 to guard
for the pawn you'll see it rookie one
check can you shoot and Tanya have a
different line that looked exactly like
this the pawn has to block and then the
queen can choose B2 or E2 doesn't matter
this is check and mate a sort of ladder
Checkmate toward the King on the second
rank
what a position this is just amazing
stuff that it looks like black king on
D7 should be getting mated or he's gonna
end up losing that Queen on D5 somehow
through some pain but it's absolutely
safe but don't forget the players have
no idea of the objective evaluation of
the position not a back very well might
still be thinking that there has to be
something in this position because it
looks so tempting for white but at some
point through calculation you realize
that none of the checks are really
working out and in fact Black's King on
D7 through a series of force moves
manages up in a safe place regardless of
which track you give this is amazing
stuff and not back there with his
classic pose of twirling his piece full
Focus full concentration still perhaps
looking for that Checkmate that doesn't
exist but such an instructive Point by
you there that players especially newer
players who are getting better they
still want to give those checks because
how do we improve as just players we
often do tactics and we see a king out
in the open and when you're solving a
puzzle you're saying okay check check
checkmate that's how it works but that's
not always how the game itself should be
played when you're doing a puzzle you
know there's a solution when you're at
the board like Noir Beck and paramar
there may not be a winning sequence in
fact we're being told by the engine
evaluation that is not a winning
position even if white is better so
don't just give a check for the sake of
checking an enemy King this isn't three
checks this isn't a puzzle this is an
over-the-board classical chess game so
if we're not going to play Rook F7 which
is a fine move but not giving white a
better chance where else can we go we
say queen f8 queen B8 is also a move
that looks like you're just kind of
getting closer and closer to this King
over here if you make a careless move
like G5 you see the evaluation bar go up
because it's a rook F7 you don't have
Rook E7 as Queen a 7 checks and wins
this Rook on E7 you can't block the
check you can't protect the Rook so if
you go King C6 now Rook C7 check your
King has to go here and you never ever
want to walk into a situation like this
Rook takes C4 check picks up a pawn uh
there's probably something even better
here maybe we can find a Checkmate but
the point is that you are walking into a
discovery and that is inadvisable
oh queen bee it looks quite strong with
the threat of Rook F7 and these are
definitely options that norderbeck is
considering but Robert I think Parham
also has ideas of his own we're talking
about Black's King
but black needs to also find a way to
get to white skin and the one weak spot
in White's position is the G2 Pawn black
does have the option in certain cases to
go Rook to E2 let's say you make a move
let's say you make your move with Queen
B8 and the eval bar will let us know so
rookie 2 now seems to be fine and
immediately as you play it I also
realize it's a great move because it
stops Rook F7 the queen on D5 now guides
the gods the F7 square at the same time
I'm hitting that pawn on G2 and if you
give Queen A7 check now I don't think I
can step up with my king because A6
Falls with a check but perhaps I can
just go back King to E8 I stop you from
giving rook f8 and if the best that you
can do is Queen be a check then I'm
already really happy
just repeat the moves and make a draw
that's Black's goal in this position so
great I by you there that Rook E2 would
be such a fantastic move because let's
say black had a free turn here if you
play A3 and then rookie two you already
see the evaluation claiming that black
is significantly better the reason why
no check on B7 no check on F7 Checkmate
on G2 if you play Rook G1 to stop the
Checkmate this Rook can also slide up to
E3 threading a new Checkmate because
that pawn is pinned also trying to help
you push your Advanced Pawn up the board
Rook can go to B3 at some moment to
attack this queen and if Queen goes to
A4 with check you can even think about
playing Queen B5 because the end game if
the Queens are traded is winning for
black black has the best pollen on the
board has an advanced king and the A3
Pawn is loose as well this would not be
a good deal for Notre back so I think we
have seen that black has ideas of his
own own with rookie two you don't want
to allow that Queen B8 is one option
rookie two seems to work Queen f8 will
protect the F7 Square it looks dangerous
for black the only other move that I can
think of because we keep talking about
rookie 2 is Queen B2 just keeping all of
our options open with our Queen covering
the weak point in the position and just
passing the turn essentially back to
Paro
once you've put your queen on B4 it's so
hard to retreat with it to B2 as a
square we've come to this conclusion
after realizing so many different points
about this position and sort of playing
through the different ideas but it's so
much more attractive when you're playing
White Rabbit you make a move like Queen
B8 to make a move like queen f8 or to go
in with a check with Rook F7 just so
much more aggressive Queen B2 I would be
surprised to see on the board and I saw
when you played it the eval bar does
approve of it so it is a good move
because it stops the threat of rookie 2
plus threatens a check on G7 not an easy
move to find here for nodded back and I
think if he doesn't play this any other
Queen moves the more I look at rookie 2
the more I like it if I can push white
into defending that G2 Pawn let's just
say I just want to make one more point
you go back with Queen to B8 or queen to
f8 if I can go rookie too
and force you to play Rook G1
and I love this idea of going rookie 3
here threatening Rook H3 a move like
King H2 oh this is Queen A7 Rook E3 just
walking and this is what I mean it's
just
it's just
mine holes everywhere there are mines
everywhere in this position I thought
I'm just winning this position after
King H2 Queen D6 I trade the Queens get
a great Rook Pawn ending but Queen A7
would be game over for me
if you missed that check to the side
there it could be a problem and well I
think that no deerback he is going to
continue thinking about this position
and while he does while we wait for the
players to make their moves we should
note that round five is played in a
different venue and the tournament
organizers were nice enough to let turn
Ambassador Anish Curie into Thursday's
venue early so let's have him show us
around
we all love to play the title chess
tournament in Vikings
part of the tradition is that we play
one round in a special location
somewhere else in the Netherlands
that are still just on tour is back and
as a tournament Ambassador I have the
privilege to take an early look at the
location it's going to be spectacular
the location for the Tata steel chess on
tour is the young craft arena in
Amsterdam
I look forward to see you all here on
the 19th of January
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
filmed a little while ago and not today
because I think Anish would have been
much happier smiling non-stop after
beating Magnus Carlsen but it is so cool
that the Tata steel chess tournament
does this every year I remember when I
commentated live on site we also went to
a football stadium it was a lot of fun
we got to be on the pitch beforehand so
for the players it's a new venue it may
be a fresh set of circumstances but it's
great to see the chess is really loved
in the Netherlands and big venues Host
this chess tournament
is that one round during the whole event
that happens on site somewhere else in
the Netherlands they usually do it at a
stadium at a big arena and this time is
no different the players will be playing
uh around will be playing around in in
the Amsterdam stadium and I'm sure Anish
giri who we just saw in the video he is
gonna be super excited to be there after
his big win today so definitely a round
that he's looking forward to but before
that the players will have a rest day
and I'm sure that's also arrested that
Magnus Carlson is looking forward to
after what happened today in his game
you want to try to change the Rhythm you
need a little bit of a break and that's
what the players will get tomorrow but
meanwhile action is still on and
nordeback has made his decision and
Robert this is what I was saying it's
such a human approach to go forward
queen f8 or queen be it as you were
pointing out I like this move it puts a
direct threat of Rook after seven with
devastating effect does Rookie do still
work I'm always afraid of suggesting a
move because I feel like you'll make it
and our bar is going to shoot right down
right up in this case but it stays it
stayed there because Rook F7 check the
king runs away King C6 Queen CA check
the King goes to B5 and we've looked at
a position just like this before if you
go Rook B7 check the King has safely run
to A4 now G2 Checkmate is threading the
only way to stop it is not Queen G4
because then I believe you throw in this
check and The Rook is lost by the way I
just noticed that uh but Queen G4 is to
put that on the board after rookie one
you pointed this variation on earlier I
can take this Rook but after Queen takes
C4 check I may have to prove the victory
somehow instead of taking a free rook
this check again it uh shows that after
G3
oh my gosh I was about the queen bee too
I was about to play this move it's super
tricky but you do it with the other
piece yeah this would be this would not
happen but I completely get your feeling
you want to give the mate but it is
possible the other way as well even the
position that you have Robert we can uh
show that line as well and now you can
go Rook to E2 and give the mate from A1
instead right the King goes back and the
queen gets to go to A1 uh but I was not
having full board awareness there The
Rook covered what would have been a
Checkmate not only two because the queen
not on B2 because the Rook I blundered
my queen uh but if the queen blocks Rook
H1 check a deflection tactic the king it
was protecting the queen not anymore
give me your queen give me the game so
in many of these positions uh a queen
trade will be good for black and the
black king is starting to the A4 square
at Parham he's played King E8 to D7 to
begin with you know that he's ready to
play King C6 at any moment
at any moment but at this moment he does
have the opportunity to create his own
threats with rookie too and knowing
Parham knowing his style of play I could
bet my house that he's going to play
this move but it's probably a bad idea
to bet my house on anything but rookie 2
is indeed what I'm expecting from Parham
uh Robert we also have another game on
let's see if we can pull our zoom out
our bird's eye view we've had four
results all we've had Five results
already with one huge decisive victory
for the tournament Ambassador Anish giri
taking down world champion Magnus
Carlsen the other four games ended in a
draw but Fighting Chess all around and
we see that Prague did go for your idea
at the top right board attacking three
Pawn rookie one was played should we
just pull that board up and take a look
at these developments that have happened
rookie one played ding
took the decision to defend that Bond
not with E4 falling for the trick as I
did against you but instead rookie for
he saves that E3 pawn and black has to
always watch out and not move that
knight from B4 Knight D3 Knight F4
always in the air for white that's the
one trick that Prague needs to be
careful about
he does and he will be vigilant he can
play Rook H1 this Pawn on H4 is a Target
and I'm wondering how dingley rent plans
to save it I don't think he can so he
might have to
move his Knight out the way because if
Brook takes H4 you're trading the Brooks
uh like if I make a move like King C4
Rook H4 the Rooks are coming off and if
you take now the king is going to get
this pawn and there are passers that are
going to reach the other side so I just
don't think that a position like this is
what ding wants maybe he'll move his
Knight out the way and after Rook takes
H4 he'll bring his Rook up to E7 get
active hit the C7 pod which means B6 is
going to be loose the G7 Pawn is also
under attack so dingley rent is going
for counter play of his own by attacking
the black Pawns
that's a really nice line a very
resourceful way to counter the position
it might still be worse but White's best
chances lie an activity of his own Rook
so very important that after Rook H1
this line that you mentioned attacking
that pawn white doesn't go on the
defense I just want to point out another
variation that I thought was first
possible Robert but if we look deeper we
realize that white indeed must go for
this active resource that you're
pointing out after Rook H1 if you try to
defend the pawn with Knight to F3 saying
that I don't want to give anything away
black can continue pursuing it with Rook
H3 you hit that Knight and at first it
might seem Rook F4 keeps everything
under control because you're defending
the Knight you're defending the pawn on
H4 by the way Rook H1 on the board so we
might see your line being played out and
here if this happens black has got
Knight D5 and I think that comes in with
devastating effect you're hitting that
pawn on E3 The Rook is overloaded
nothing can be saved here you have to go
Rook F7 but then you just pick up the
born on E3 and white is helpless can't
pick up either of the pawns because the
Knight on F3 hangs
and if the Knight moves there's a
discovered check that won't be so fun
either and this Knight can go to G2 and
win the H4 Pawn so it feels like the
position is looking really nice for
Prague great winning chances and ding
fully aware of that needs to find a way
to cause problems that's why I like the
look of the move Knight C4 because it
threatens Rook E7 Rook takes E7 Knight
takes B6 you need to start getting after
Black's pawns so Rook H4 is one move Ken
did why don't we also try for checkmate
this is a checkmate with the Knight on
C4 uh the Knight goes back to E5 but
something about this looks very wrong to
me The Rook on e4 is blocked in by it
the own Knight so if there's a move here
that gives black a bigger Advantage I
would prefer that to go on Rook H1 and
taken H4 I just I'm not really seeing it
at the moment
I see our eval bar does like Black's
position but not by a huge margin Robert
which means that white is still within
drawing range and black needs to play
Super accurately to make the most of
this advantage that you have so far
Prague is really keeping it there he has
uh played All the Right Moves Rook H1
has come in and now really it's on ding
first you find this idea that you were
pointing out with Knight C4 it's not an
easy move to play on the board where
you're just walking into giving away
this pawn and you know that black will
have a passer on the king side yes you
get some activity but you are down upon
rookie seven ideas can be met by Knight
D5 it gets pretty complicated
I think the point is that
ding needs to find a knight to C4 which
itself is is a very difficult move to
find
and his Knight was just on C4 two moves
ago it's very difficult to go back to
where you came from but what other moves
there aren't many pieces on the board
move like King C3 doesn't really make
sense because Rook takes H4 forces the
Rooks off the board because the Rook is
trapped in the Square so you take G and
even if you save your g-pawn what black
is already up a pawn so if you go to
Knight F7 or King H5 King G6 get your
knight out of here give me this pawn and
even if I didn't win a pawn I could
start pushing my H Pawn as an outside
passer a decoy so I just feel like
dingley Ren needs to find that active
chance I would love to play Knight D3 as
you mentioning earlier but this really
really really strong night on B4 is
keeping it out of there so I just think
my process of elimination the move
Knight C4 comes to mind because Knight
H3 as you showed before this looks very
wrong with the Knight coming to D5
scooping up this Pawn on E3
too many pieces and too many pawns
hanging in this variation the hardest
part for ding to play Knight C4 is the
key point that you made that the Knight
just moved from there to E5 and it's
also a square that doesn't do much
you're not really threatening from C4 to
jump into anywhere and I'm just
wondering how ding is going to approach
this position not an easy end game
things looking good for Prague still a
long fight ahead but it's much harder to
defend this position proc can just stay
still he just needs to throw the ball on
ding's code it's so easy to go wrong
with white as we ourselves have been
seeing despite having the eval bar
making inaccuracies because that's just
the nature of this position to defend
this is a lot harder if black just sits
it's going to be a difficult task for
ding the ren no matter what the next few
moves bring and for ding he would love
to hold this game because if he is able
to make a draw then he will find himself
in a tie for second place with Fabiano
caruana no dear back Abdus atarov well
he might have other ideas because a draw
for ding may not be a tie per second if
Abdus tarv wins he will be tied first
through second with Anish giri but I
would say the storyline the biggest deal
of the day is Anish giri taking down
Magnus Carlson the Dutchman takes down
the Norwegian the world champion in all
three classical rapid and Blitz formats
I mean you couldn't ask for a better day
then the one in each scary has gotten
today
and that win pretty much gives Anish
giri bragging rights for the rest of the
year Robert because this is
the most prestigious chess stage and to
beat Magnus in this classical format
with the game that he played just an
amazing result all through kudos to him
for being super accurate super combative
in that one and everything just worked
out while the other four games did end
in a draw as we see Wesley against Levon
was was even start to finish but we did
have a very big fight between Richard
and Fabiano which kind of fizzled out a
little disappointingly because that
really started with a lot of fireworks
but Richard handled it perfectly and
then with the pieces being traded uh
liquidation happened and that ended in a
draw the other really exciting game that
is still on of course Prague as we can
see on our screen sits tight he's made
that move that attacks the pawn on H4
and currently at the top right we can
see ding is still having a thing not an
easy moment he needs to find a way to
activate his own pieces frogs in the
driving seat in that one while the
madness continues at the bottom left
that second board that we've got is just
crazy all through
I can't wait to dive back into the
action advantages for the youngsters
prognanda and neuterbeck abdusitarov but
before we dive in back into the action
we're gonna head on a quick break and I
first want to give a shout out to the
Collegiate chess League because it is
back the spring season kicks off January
21st that's it four days away and the
season promises to deliver the best in
Collegiate chess with past participants
including the likes of a Wonder Liang
and gruvio paren and an impressive
thirty thousand dollar prize fund will
bring you coverage of all the action at
twitch.tv Collegiate chess League use
the command CCL and chat for more and we
will have more from Vikings a when we
return from this quick break
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer bringing you
chess terminology let's Dive Right into
one of one of everybody's favorite
tactics if I might be so bold because
it's surprising it's something that
never never fails to deliver shock value
and excitement whether you're watching a
broadcast or just reviewing some famous
chess games and that is the process of
an under promotion when you move upon to
the other side of the board almost
always you're looking to get a queen but
the rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples
under promotion as we said is the
process of promoting a pawn but not to
the most obvious or most powerful type
of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kramnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a knight that
move comes with check on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately kramnik would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop under promoting
to a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we checked and mate
along the A4 E8 diagonal and if the
bishop moves anywhere else white
actually plays a subtle move Bishop of
seven first and there is no way to
prevent Checkmate on the next move shout
out to everybody watching this video
thank you for tuning in and enjoying our
breakdown of under promotion and we'll
see you on chess.com
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
teenager who led his country to the gold
medal he is looking for a second win of
the event he entered the route two out
of three in a tie for first he saw Anish
giri take down Magnus Carlson he wants
to follow the Dutchman's lead and join
him Atop The leaderboard batonya Parham
has been very impressive in this
tournament in game one he was a last
minute invitate of the field he was
shaky with white against Vincent kymer
but since then he defended that game
against dingley Wren for almost seven
hours yesterday was a pretty peaceful
day against Anish giri and today he's
also showing that stubborn defense he's
been worse throughout this game it
looked like earlier he was in tactical
trouble but right now in in this queen
rook and three Pawn position the King on
D7 out in the open and yet the eval bar
has not changed its mind Parham is
holding this position right now
what I love about the way players like
Parham and Arjun come up with their
defensive resources is always taking the
dynamic Way Forward it's been so
impressive to watch this entire gameplay
by him his King has been in the center
for the last several moves White's got
this queen and the Rook Super Active but
param hasn't gone in or offered a queen
trade instead he keeps his own chances
alive as we can see in the current
position he is threatening to take on H3
but there has been a very nasty trick
set up here by white in this position
the last move played Rook to F4 inviting
Rook H3 now notice the G2 Pawn is pinned
so you can't take on H3 but the whole
point is that now once The Rook has
taken this Pawn the king's sidesteps
goes to G1 you're threatening Rook D4
pinning and winning the queen The Rook
on H3 hangs and you might be like but
wait a second there's a check on D1
Queen D1 comes in but white doesn't care
because now white Falls back with the
Rook 2 F1 intercepts the check attacks
the queen no checks here possible The
Rook hangs the queen hangs so Parham
needs to watch out he's definitely seen
this he will not go for Rook takes H3
but if not white has got a killer idea
of playing Rook D4 you pin the queen you
win the queen
wow and one more thing to show in that
variation after Rook H3 you can play
Rook D3 to save the D4 square but what
have you done that Rook that was on H7
helping the king feel safe Queen to G7
check the king runs up give me this Pawn
with check you think your King's Running
Away we kept talking about that A4
Square not anymore Queen and Rook are
here and the Queen on D5 is pinned and
lost this would be a win for white so do
not get greedy do not try to steal this
Pawn on H3 Rook F4 says you know go for
it have it it's not gonna work out for
you so that means param hasn't come up
with something else Rook D4 remains a
massive threat he can move his King out
of the way but if he does that maybe A6
is falling maybe G6 is falling there's
just so much to work out here in this
position and he has to move his King I
think that is clear and as soon as I say
it he does pick the C7 Square first king
Parham maksudu on move 40 brought the
king from e E8 to D7 that was the
correct Choice it was difficult he made
it now in another difficult moment he
plays kc7 I've been very very impressed
with Parham because Tanya I see him as
such an attacking aggressive player now
he is demonstrating that he's not one
dimensional he can defend tough
positions for dozens of moves I am very
impressed and that is a sign of the
champion of a world-class player not
only to be able to play attacking
aggressive chess but also to be able to
be resourceful in very difficult
positions one of the examples of that is
now he's somebody we've often spoken
about as he's so aggressive so attacking
but what makes Hikaru truly Stand Out is
his ability to defend difficult
positions and to me Parham I can see a
few reflections of that style that
Hikaru has which is so strong which
makes him almost unbeatable of course
Arham has to mature a lot more as a
player right now but he's showing all
the right signs this King march bringing
and keeping the king in the center of
the board and still safe that is high
class chess you were pointing out Queen
takes A6 it might be an option but
Robert that actually allows black to
create his own play remember the pin
that we were talking about now you can
come in with Rook takes H3 give a check
the King has to sidestep to G1 and now I
give a check on D1 with my queen the
difference is that your queen has moved
away from the King side I'm gonna make
the most of that with white after Rook
F1 for example their ideas are going
Queen D4 check and at least there is a
Perpetual a repetition in this position
if black wants to play on you can still
do that but at least black is completely
safe so the A6 Pawn doesn't worry Parham
so much the big question is can white
create more coordination and more
threats with his pieces is Rook D4 a
possibility here
Rook D4 looks possible attacking the
queen please play Brook takes H3 check
King slide to G1 the queen is under
attack Now The Rook is hanging and
you've left your King's defense so after
Rook D4 you can't take the pawn but
maybe there's a queen move that looks
okay like a queen C5 perhaps nope that's
not it clearly and I think the reason
why is Queen F4 check winning C4 and
then the game is in White's hand so oh
this is every move Tanya is tricky uh
group D4 looks excellent what is the
move to save black here
oh God it looks scary as we speak
because if you move the queen to a wrong
square like you pointed out you can pick
up the pawn but also there's Queen d8
check coming in there's Queen D6 stuff
how are you hiding with all these
threats if you go Queen to C6
you can even I'm nervous I'm going to
the end game and pick up the C4 Pawn
why not
extra pawn and very importantly when
your Rook comes to G4 this Rook is
passive in some of these other end games
that Rook was over an A3 causing
problems what do you do Rook H6 no Rook
G7 there might be H4 H5 very quickly and
that actually might be a big problem for
black not to mention the white king can
just come up the board this is not the
type of end game you want if you're
Parham magsudu so there is a move here
and by process of elimination it must be
Rook F7 you take my queen I take yours
and the difference is you can't win this
Pawn because the Rook slides the C6 and
black immediately wins the game a rook
behind a passer the black king is fast
and so that is not acceptable for no
deer Beck he needs to continue the
attack so Rook D4 is met by Rook F7 I
think queen h8 move like that keeps the
attack going but it's getting very very
messy
this is just such inspired play we've
been seeing by the players today just
amazing chess all throughout Robert
we've had one decisive game so far but
there's been so much action on all the
boards
there has been and one last line I just
you know the card of the corner is Queen
C3 that attacks this pawn and protects
the HD Pawn at the same time but if this
King runs away to B7 and you take the
Pawn With The Rook on C4 there's this
really nice tactical shot of Rook takes
H3 check I know I just told you that the
pawn is protected and that's true but
the queen is overloaded remember this
term the queen is doing too much at the
same time protecting the rook and
covering that square so the queen is
dragged to age three down goes The Rook
on uh C4 and then the position is even
by materials the game should be a draw
but just so much happening uh in this
game so much happening in the other game
and well one game that was exciting
early and fizzled out was the one
between Fabiano caruana and Richard
report they drew their game early and
maybe it was too early the Press caught
up with Fabi for the whole story
then we reached an equal end game uh and
he offered a draw
around move um
I don't know what it was 1920 something
like that and I was ready to accept the
draw because it was completely equal it
was after he took on G4 traded queens
and then I was expecting that uh like
the play would continue hg4 he would
move the king and trade all the works on
H file and make a draw
but I I realized that it wasn't exactly
like in the rules that you can draw
before move 30.
uh so we asked the Arbiter and the
Arbiter said you should play a few more
moves
and so we did but then with every move
that we played he started to get worse
and worse until soon his position was
extremely dangerous
but at that point we reached move 30 and
I thought a little bit I mean about
playing on but uh yeah just the fact
that we had sort of agreed beforehand
like the moment that we had kind of
agreed the position was completely equal
um but then yeah I think it just like
the last few moves of the game
don't really count in a way because
probably both of us were not
um
like
psychologically fully in the game
anymore
ouch that is
that is awkward
yeah Tanya um you know how I feel about
the draw offer ban the draw for and in
fact it was bad they couldn't make a
draw when they wanted to so then they
just kind of sort of wink wink you know
agreed on a draw and then Richard
started making bad moves so I'm with
Fabi from the sense that this position
that we have on screen was even so if
they wanted to make a draw in a
different tournament they would have
just said yeah this position is even I
get it but one I don't like draw first
and two if draw first did didn't exist
ever unless there was a repetition that
someone makes a mistake you take
advantage of it so I think that Fabi you
know with the fact that they agreed you
know he did the gentleman the Sportsman
thing to do you don't really like reneg
because Richard wasn't playing the board
so much anymore it sounds like but do
not offer draws Bobby come on man no
draw first
no it was definitely very gentleman-like
of Fabi to continue uh on the terms that
they sort of had agreed off in this
position and let's just point out sorry
Robert if we can just back up to this
moment which he mentioned that he was
expecting Richard after the queen trade
to just move the king up the board
everything all the Rooks get traded
everything gets traded on the H5 Rook H1
Rook H1 Knight H1 and he said this was a
draw so he was completely ready to
accept the draw offer at this point this
is the moment where the draw was offered
to Fabi and he was going to take it and
then they realized that they haven't
made it to 30 moves they asked the
Orbiter the Orbiter tells them that they
still need to make a couple of more
moves and it's true because when we
caught up with the position we felt that
Fabi had his chances it's even material
but the Rook controls the H file coming
into H2 G2 is a weakness we were
pointing out the flexibility and the
mobility on a fabi's pawn structure on
the queen side and it felt like it might
be even but if anyone can try here it's
Fabi and every move that Richard made
was a bit not up to the mark of the
position uh
and it's so strange if that happens
because you sort of agreed to something
a couple of moves ago but then you're at
this point when the circumstances are
different the position is different you
want to play on but you can't anymore
it's it's a really awkward situation to
be in I just want to point out that what
you're saying is 100 correctly if
Richard put King E2 Rook H1 Trey the
Rooks this position would surely be a
draw no questions asked and I guess it
is a strange dynamic because once you
agree on a draw you just start making
random moves and I actually looked at E4
and I was like why would you do that
you're giving yourself an isolated pawn
and now that I actually see the game and
hear why that move E4 was played it
makes more sense because at the final
position if you look here they made a
repetition just back and forth like this
but if you don't make this repetition as
black you're better here you have a
healthier Pawn structure white has two
isolated pawns black only has one so
this position is one that Fabiano in
another game and it gets different
opponent a different tournament could
have played for a win because he has the
better chances but if we you know go too
far we lose the storyline if we go back
to this moment right here and Richard
was in the myself I need to find every
single accurate move he would have just
moved his King up as uh we have been
discussing played Rook H1 black doesn't
want to give up the open file and the
game would have been a draw let's say
it's here here it's the show now we have
a position where your knight looks
trapped but you just play F3 and your
knight will get out this way and if you
try to trap tonight that's how you lose
games like this because I'll play E4 and
get up to your Pawn so it still is equal
but my point is that Knight H4 prop yeah
pretty much nothing would have changed
that except for what Richard did but now
we get why he did that
yeah is this I don't think I've ever
heard of such a thing happen at a
tournament and it's uh you know as you
mentioned Fabi is is a pure example of a
sportsman I mean he's he's
a gentleman and his Sportsman spirit is
super high and that's what we see in
this one uh but it's definitely not a
pleasant situation to be in because
somewhere Fabi did realize that he would
want to continue but you sort of agreed
on something before and I don't know I
think this is definitely something that
needs to be sorted out from the
organization perspective withdraw offers
as you're pointing out that's the bane
of our reality that needs to be
eliminated
there is a famous example of that by the
way but let's go back to the dingly ren
versus prognanda game because those two
are still playing but while we bring up
them on screen uh the game between uh
Larry Christensen and I believe it was
Anatoly karpov
um there was
uh maybe it wasn't that game but there
was a famous game that essentially
viciana lost in five moves at one point
and the reason why he lost his game in
five moves back in the 80s was because
he had seen another game that was a
quick draw but it was actually a losing
variation so I'm actually going to look
up that game because I know the player
uh that he lost to and I would give the
Fuller story because Vichy losing that
early doesn't make any sense to most
people so I'm just gonna pull up
um the start of a position uh give me a
second it doesn't matter whose game
let's go to move one and the you know
these were not the players it was Vichy
Anand against Alonso Zapata in that game
it was E4 E5 so we started off normally
Knight F3 Knight F6 Knight takes E5
great D6 Knight F3 Knight takes E4 and
then after Knight C3 there was this game
where the bishop F5 was played and the
player is strong player at the time I
said Larry Christian I'm not sure if it
was him he actually beat Anatoly karpov
in like 12 moves one time but Bishop F5
defends the Knight and the game was a
quick draw and it's actually a huge
blunder because after Queen E2 the piece
is pinned and you're threatening D3 and
if Queen E7 to block the pin and defend
the Knight there's Knight D5 attacking
the queen and attacking the fork on C7
so when your queen moves out the way
there's Pawn to D3 so Vichy resigned in
fact after the move Queen to E2 was
played in that game he lost in six moves
sorry I said five he wasn't six moves to
Alonso Zapata because this was before
the engines he saw some game where oh
this looks pretty good and he didn't
actually realize that in the game that
he was uh basing his move off of they
had agreed on a draw and just made some
moves and so that there are famous
examples of this in chess and my point
is the same every single time ban the
draw for I don't want to see draw first
play it out I get certain positions are
dead equal no hope for other side but
funny examples of this do exist in chess
history
I think it's moments on
these what has happened today and what
you mentioned about vichy's games that
bring about a change in the Chess World
this is definitely something to think
about that if the draw for did not exist
the players would play out and perhaps
Richard would make moves differently as
Fabi pointed out he wouldn't make these
moves with slowly but steadily worsened
his game but then in the spirit of
sportsmanship Fabi had to sort of agree
for a draw in that moment where it was a
it was something that was decided before
it's a bit messy in my head still Robert
I'm trying to get my head around it but
there we are and speaking of a mess take
a look at the position that we've got uh
the board we have in front of us Prague
still trying to push his game against
thing and we see both these players look
at that pose look at the way they are
looking at the board there we have got
dingler in fully focused head on his
hands completely involved and engrossed
in the position because he's got his
task cut up and it's not an easy one
prabhna Nanda one of the youngest
players in the field right now he's all
of 17 years looking confident leaning
back against the world number two as he
has an extra Pawn in this end game
Robert will this be enough to take the
point home
it's a great question I like the
presence of an outside pass Pawn that
seems to give very very good chances
especially because it's an extra Pawn
the E3 Pawn still a weakness but the
Rook is very active and I mean dingley
Wren should probably slide his Rook on
over to a square like E7 and then Knight
f8 becomes a threat going after the H7
pawn and the C7 Pawn at the same time
there could be a knight D5 that has to
be calculated so maybe Rook F7 seems to
be the place to go that way you don't
give a Tempo to that night but E3 is
weak C7 is targeted H7 can quickly be
threatened by a move like Knight f8 I
would say that there are still good
winning chances for prognanda but he
must keep this h-pawn
nicely pointed out the H Bond and we've
often spoken about how helpless the
Knight is against The Rook Bond so
that's something to keep in mind any end
game where the Rooks get traded white
will be dead lost and speaking of
dangerous positions uh Robert if we just
zoom out for a moment we will bring up
the other board because I have my eye
out on it and it is just so fascinating
what is going on there as well we've of
course had Five results already with one
big decisive game which is the storyline
of the day with Anish giri taking down
Magnus Carlson the other games ending in
a draw but I see our second vote from
the left there and not a back still
pushing for that win currently he is on
two points this win will put him on
three points out of a possible four
going into the rest they the position is
super weird super crazy Rook to D4 is
the move that we were looking at it has
been played if we just back up to that
moment we found this very challenging
you came up with the resource that black
has against Rook D4 Parham as well found
it he made the move Rook F7 you attacked
my queen I'll Attack your queen and we
came to the conclusion that in fact this
was the only way forward for black and
then white made the move Queen to h8 the
other end of the board keeping the
defense on the D4 rook and things are
still very tricky for black where are
you moving with your queen because watch
out for Queen d8 check
oh that is a nasty threat also important
to point out that these checkmates that
black had in other positions don't work
here Rook F1 check King H2 your queen
can't reach the necessary diagonal
because the queen on h8 covers E5 The
Rook covers D6 you don't get that fatal
check to deliver check made so it if
that's the case The Rook is probably
better off staying on F7 defending the
King on the seventh rank but where does
this queen go if you go to C5 the queen
can come into d8 check and maybe the
king does in fact Escape here it looks
scary but param has proven that he is
capable of holding on running with his
King and something is disliked about the
move Queen to C5 we just went well I
just want Queen d8 it said it was even
so there is a move here that gives white
the upper hand
but I think Parham has taken another
route he has decided to move the queen
from D5 not to C5 but he plays the move
Queen B5 the one thing I like about
Queen B5 Robert is that it keeps the
chances of giving a check on B1 alive
now you want to keep your own activity
going your own counter chances it just
feels like a slightly more active Square
than C5
totally with you there and it covers all
the important squares it covers the pawn
on C4 it also covers D7 because of Queen
d8 check King B7 you can't get the D7
not with the queen and the Rook where
they're situated and so this could be a
position where uh no dearbeck is going
after Black's King but if he is
unsuccessful you need to watch out for
this Pawn on C4 as well any Queen trade
that doesn't lose a pawn should be to
Black's benefit and so for the deerback
queen B1 check is not really a huge
threat because the king can just slide
up to H2 so he has a turn here to figure
things out like even a quite with the A3
it's not the end of the world you see
the evaluation is slipping a bit but my
point is it's not a kind of huge blunder
because you cover many of the important
checking squares with your queen and
your row
also important to note how black is
covering important defensive squares
instead of A3 if you give a check on d8
the one thing good for black is that
you've got forced moves you can't really
you don't have too many options not so
much to think about you can't take your
king to C6 because Queen E8 if we just
show that quick King C6 Queen E8 and you
end up losing the Rook so this gives
Parham the opportunity to make his moves
fast as well and which is why notepack
needs to take his time before making
hand moves we call hand moves the ones
that you naturally play in Blitz you'll
just quickly go Queen d8 check and after
King B7 you just realize you've got no
good way to continue so once again Queen
B5 Black's position looks super
dangerous very tricky and yet white
doesn't have a clear path to prove the
advantage
no and what no Rebecca has been doing
very well is not giving the checks he's
been making moves like Rook to D1 so
maybe there is a useful move here
because the queen is very importantly
placed on B5 I feel uh there might be an
opportunity to distract it one thing to
note queen dhx king B7 Queen D5 would
pick up this Rook on F7 but the queen is
on B5 so if we distract the queen with
A4 in this position it doesn't work you
see the Eva bar drop the reason why we
keep showing variations like this you
give a check on the diagonal the only
thing you do is block it with the pawn
and the queen comes in with Checkmate so
do not give the check on d8 the threat
is strong in the execution instead
because the queen covers the E5 Square
from h8 maybe A4 to begin with just to
distract that Queen away if you take now
Queen dhek wins the game on the spot
King B7 thank you very much for your
Rook on F7 I'm going to win a rook and
win the game
oh actually this is not so clear is it
because of King A7 oh let's check wait
let's check here but if it came B8 if
you take the Rook then Queen picks up
this right oh my gosh even when I tasty
stuff I thought I was suggesting let's
see I mean this was this is a really
nice idea and just to just to show what
you meant by losing control of the E5
Square Robert I think the key check
might be Queen E5 queen d8 super
attractive but once you've deflected the
queen from B5 perhaps it's Queen E5 and
after King B7 Queen D5 still doesn't
work because you can't pick up the Rook
so
still says it's winning this is hard to
understand maybe just instead of picking
up the Rook pick up the pawn and now
your Rook is closing in on the king this
Rook is still loose you can give one
check but this queen can't get to the
all-important diagonal in fact all of
those squares are under White's control
here this is beautiful geometry and
they're going to be many checks against
this King on B8 so the white king is
safer tucked away and we did just see
the move A4 played I know dear
oh my God not a back finds A4 what a guy
this is the guy who led his team the
Olympia team to win the chess Olympics
in Chennai he's the one who won the
Medal on his board the world rapid
Champion look at the way he's keeping
the tension on the board not giving the
checks but creating more and more
threats the most difficult problems for
Parham to solve this is Play at another
level
you're just giving no easy choices to
parm I like the way you were describing
that is sometimes you give a check you
make the moves easy and the reason why
I'm calling specific attention that is
I'm looking at the clubs Parham has 14
minutes and 40 seconds to get to move 60
before he gains that extra 15 minutes
it's Black's 48th move right now and
Tanya as we've been looking at every
move for black takes several minutes of
calculation if you're a queen C5 here
maybe it's possible and all right it
only gives white a little bit of an
advantage not a huge one if you play
Queen to B4 let's see there it is it's
losing Queen d8 check Queen D5 check
pick up the Rook so you kind of have to
know where your queen belongs and
covering the D5 Square seems to be the
most important thing and covering the C4
Pawn if you cover the d8 check then you
lose sight of the C4 Pawn if you throw
in Rook F1 check there it is losing
because after King H2 two there still is
no check on E5 and you've given white
control of the seventh rank in addition
to Queen to d8 there will be Rook D7 and
you're not going to stop all the checks
so every turn for Parham is a challenge
and he is now down to about a minute per
move he does get the 30 second increment
per turn but Parham whose previous
experience his best tournament in touch
of Steel was a Seventh Place finish four
years ago in the Challenger section he
is on the rise at a career high rating
but I do not envious tasks Tanya I'm
looking at this position and I just
wouldn't hate to be sitting in the seat
all those lines apart you make a great
point about clock management here
because black has only a small margin of
error and has to find the only moves and
the only way to do that I say a lot of
only is because that is what defines the
position the way to do that is by
elimination so very often you end up
burning the clock on each and every move
and that's how you win games at this
level by putting incremental pressure on
your opponent until they eventually
crack very few times you'll see a big
blunder and the game is over that
doesn't happen that often and that is
what nordeback is succeeding to do so
far in this game I'm so impressed with
this move A4 Robert as you were
mentioning the queen has to find a good
square covering D5 covering C4 and the
only way to come to the move what you
were suggesting Queen C5 is once you
realize that but the big question is how
long will Parham take how much time is
he going to take to understand that
concept and he still has 12 moves to
make and two one minute that gives him
about an average of a minute per move in
a very difficult position
and I'm gonna play a little game here I
just want to see something let's see
Quincy five okay the bar stays the same
what about Queen C6
the bar also stays the same two moves
that keep the evaluation the status quo
but are very different why now it's
Queen E5 check and if I get Queen E5 and
your king goes somewhere do I not have
Rook D6 that doesn't look very appealing
to me there's gonna be a if the queen
moves off the diagonal there's Queen D5
check the G6 Pawn is under attack maybe
I'll play A5 and Rook B6 check so that
doesn't look very good so why don't I
put my queen on C5 there's some kind of
difference here I'm also looking at
Queen d8 check and then Rook D1 Rook B1
now that your queen is off the B file
like if I give this check okay every
time I give the check it's wrong so I'm
just trying to show something eval bar
stop reprimanding me I wanted to bring
my Rook to the B file because if you
make a careless move and I go Rook B1
your king can no longer hide because
Queen V8 is check and mate so oh my
goodness Tanya maybe it's
Rook D1 first okay of course it is just
don't give checks that's the answer here
never give that first check
don't try that at home I don't know if
that's a great general advice to never
give checks because usually they seem to
work perfectly but this is one of the
unique position where really keeping the
threat is much stronger than its
execution and the way not a back has
realized that on every move and
continues to grow on it is just
incredible to watch now Queen C5 the one
thing that gives me hope for Parham is
that in general if you realize that you
have these two moves Queen C5 and queen
C6 Queen C5 feels like it controls most
quests you're also controlling the E5
Square which is really important in the
position why give your opponent more
chances extra chances for checks the
line that you were pointing out Robert I
think one way to explain that is also
that if you give a check on d8 and the
King runs to B7 with the same idea of
getting your Rook to B1 the point is
that black can continue running to the a
file and The Rook from F7 can actually
join on and defend your mating threat of
B8 and once again we see that if valbar
doesn't move so it validates this
defense now we're only able to come to
these conclusions by playing around
checking different moves but for the
players they've got a limited amount of
time and need to make an optimal
decision in that much time not an easy
task when you're threatened with
checkmate
farham has made a move he's gone for
Queen C5 he finds the most accurate line
of defense and Robert Rook D1 on the
board
he didn't even think God
he mapped this out when he played A4
we've been moving pieces back and forth
making mistakes
Abdus atarov the young Uzbek player the
former World rapid Champion the current
leader of the Uzbek team leading them to
a gold medal Olympia he brings the Rook
back to D1 and what you just said is
brilliant that if the king could get to
A7 The Rook could slide to B7 but now
you're too slow King B7 Rook B1 is check
after King A7 Queen B8 is Checkmate and
you don't need to just give a check Rook
B1 is a big threat with Queen B8 to
follow in many positions or queen d8
check and then Rook to B1 so this is a
very critical moment for Parham if he
stops the check on d8 The Rook still
slides to B1 threatening Queen B8 check
and that King earlier on we said it
could run up the board but it's looking
scarier because this Pawn can also push
up to A5 at the right moment and get a
rook B6 there's so much to work out for
Parham and I feel for him because he's
on the defensive and now he's down under
nine minutes Tanya and he has a 11 moves
to make
I'm still just shocked and amazed with
the speed with which he let's start to
move Rook D1 it just shows amazing board
awareness and now we we are
complimenting one player how impressed
we are with not a back and look at
Parham he makes the move Rook D7 these
guys are machines how are they playing
like this this is unreal chess this is
God level chess
it is and I think that made them with
Rook B1 in like three seconds and he
keeps putting the pressure on Parham
both in terms of checkmating attacks and
on the clock he is the former World
rapid Champion he's a teenager but he
won that title in 2021 that is no small
feat no Rebecca abusive is a beast I see
his rating it says 27-13 I'm looking at
his play I'm like he is clearly better
than that but Parham he's no slouch
either he brings the Rook back to d8
seeing the threat was Queen on the last
rank over the B8 Square so he blocks
that but can white just go pick up this
Pawn go up a pawn why not canned white
bring the queen all the way back on the
yo-yo string and go up to B7 I'm looking
at the time and I sing a world rapid
Champion playing perfect moves and I'm
seeing the young player from Iran in his
early 20s part of maksulu playing some
of the best defense you could possibly
ask for and he did that against Stingley
Ren in an end game now he's doing it in
a complicated tactical melee
this is just unreal stuff
to hold on to these positions to find
lots of moves and the Queen and Rook
dance that nautiback has been doing the
last few moves coordinating them not
giving a single check when that's the
most tempting thing to do on the board
creating these mating ideas it's so
instructive the last 10 most by
nordeback have been mind-blowing and as
you're pointing out Rook d8 I don't know
who I'm more impressed by not about
putting threat after threat or Parham
finding the only moves the only way to
survive and keep going with just minutes
left on the clock nine minutes to go 10
moves to be made and each move difficult
than the previous one as naughty back is
not letting go of the pressure Rook d8
stopping the idea of Queen be a check
which would have resulted in a mate
finally naughty back decides to give a
check on G7 Parham wastes no time makes
the only move if it's the only move
you've got to play it fast Rook D7 on
the board if the queen goes back to the
eighth rank are hump will repeat but now
your idea of again transferring the
queen to the other side of the board
trying to get in from the B line becomes
a reality because Queen be it will come
in with a devastating threat of Queen be
a check and I am not seeing a way for
black to save the checks down the B file
this is wild stuff and this is just the
strength of the new generation uh both
players are impressing the world right
now and as we see the players in this
tournament the oldest player on screen
here is Jordan van Forest at 23. para
Sulu 22 years old the rest of them in
their teenage years gukesh being the
youngest of the bunch and Abdus attar of
2713 I believe he is underrated his
classical chess is not raiding it's not
caught up to his performances in the
shorter time patrols I mean all of the
top players have so much respect for
both of these two and I just believe
that uh Abdus tariff has shown time and
time again that he is a force to be
reckoned with and I just love the way
he's playing this Tanya he brought his
Queen to G7 with check he can take this
Pawn on G6 and let's see what happens
with 66 the eval Bar says still better
for white but the the event Slips Away a
little bit and so instead queen of B2
just going for the attack I don't think
that that Nordic wants the G6 pod so
badly with the Queens on the board he
wants to go for parham's King when
Parham has a minute to make for every
move
I would be terrified to be sitting in
front of nordeback right now look at him
twirling that pawn having this uh
dominating position and finding the best
moves on the boat how is this guy doing
this queen B2 played as you're
mentioning he doesn't care about the
pawns who cares about the material when
you're going in for the king absolute
accurate this is a master class in how
you attack your opponent's king and now
big question to Parham he's got no time
little time on the clock he's got to
find a way to survive Queen dear check
and these ideas which are coming in a
move like Rook D6 for example to try and
run away with the King it just falls
into Queen B8 okay first I thought Queen
B at King C King C6 Queen B7 Checkmate
that's game over so which means you have
to go to D7 but that invites Rook B7
check and why is this not check mating
if this is not Checkmate then nothing is
Robert
oh my gosh Queen E8 check the King goes
to D5 and the king is running towards
the other side for now you can keep the
king inside with Queen to ghx taking
away the D5 square but the king runs up
to E5 and after rookie seven check King
to D4 and if you are not careful and the
King somehow survives that is a past
Pawn that's the reason why nowderbeck
did not take on G6 to begin with if we
go back a few moves when he went Queen
to B2 if he takes on G6 up goes the pawn
to C3 the threat is C2 and Rook D1 check
and then black can deliver a Checkmate
so that is why he didn't go Pawn
grabbing even though the advantage would
still be his according to the engines
it's not a position you want to be where
you're passively defending when black
will bring the Rook to C6 and white is
kind of Frozen despite the extra pawns a
queen B2 I love that move Tanya and now
for Parham he sees Queen B8 he sees
Queen to B7 another idea is kicking the
king to the last Rank and all I need is
a rook somewhere on this eighth and
final rank that would be Checkmate so
maybe there's a queen f g or H7 I'm just
gonna pick a square let's go to G7 all
right still threatening Rook to B8 The
Rook has to go to B6 and The Rook could
slide the other way this
is so complex how is Parham surviving
this far that's a big question and how
is he going to continue to do so with
this queen barreling down the B file and
that's the bigger question how do you
keep surviving so much pressure and so
much tension on the board not a back
playing like a total Beast this position
Robert for a lack of a better word even
that might be an underestimation of the
way he's handled this game Queen B2 I'm
just so impressed with this whole A4
Rook D1 Rook B1 the last few moves have
been absolutely mind-blowing by white
and one thing that comes to my mind in
this position is
that can black play King to C6 and
simply sidestep some checks and at least
you've not you're not coming in to be it
with a check but maybe you still go
Queen B8 because I don't know what my
next move is and there we have it Queen
B it still works yeah I think we can
just make a random move to see what the
thread is Queen C8 check there it is if
you move your king to D6 because you
have to save your queen and your rook in
comes Rook D1 check picking up the Rook
or actually just pick up the queen what
am I talking about that's more valuable
and if the Rook slides to C7 there's
Queen E6 check where does your king go
not to the B file no not to any of these
squares the queen goes to D6 and there
is this move Rook B6 check distracting
the king from the queen you take the
Rook you lose the queen and white wins
the game so Queen B you know what king
C6
you did it but but Queen B8 we were just
looking at that it just looks like
trouble and queen bee is a very obvious
move for nerdirect we do not fault
Parham for going wrong this position has
been the biggest gargantuan challenge
for many moves but look at he knows
Queen bait is good he is going to play
that move and what is next for para
maxulu
and he's reaching out for it he goes for
it he is playing this position
flawlessly to Perfection Queen B8 played
as you're mentioning not a difficult
move to find when that's the square that
you've been eyeing for the last couple
of moves that's been your idea to come
in with the queen and now a huge threat
as we were seeing with Queen C8 check
which would eventually go on to win a
Black's Queen how is Parham going to
handle this he's down to six and a half
minutes on the clock seven moves still
to be made and the clock is not his
biggest problem anymore
it certainly isn't there's a queen and
Rook on the same line that's a battery
you do not want to see because the king
is in grave danger how do you defend
that King you may think Rook C7 isn't
that threat Queen C8 that's what you two
are talking about but after Rook C7
there's a new check on E8 and if your
king decides to try to run to the D file
somewhere with King to D5 Rook D1 I'm
very sorry but your King has no more
squares which means that you have to
give up your queen just to block that
check that's a losing situation so you
can't play Rook to C7 that allows Queen
E8 what can you do here as Queen C8
check is such a big threat I'm
struggling to find parham's next move
foreign
because I really don't see a way that
you can stop Quincy it Queen 8 and
Queenie it and there we see nordeback
who has played the position to
Perfection gets up and takes a little
walk which actually puts more pressure
on your opponent left by himself on the
board farham in a difficult situation
we're struggling to come up with a
defensive move the eval bar seems to say
that there is no such thing as a
defensive move anywhere anywhere and
Robert I'm just wondering about that
position where Parham had the
opportunity to actually trade off the
Queens a while back
thou would have saved him a lifetime of
troubles yeah let's quickly bring up
that position because it may be the
moment that Parham regrets uh it was way
back in time at this point we had a
position right around here where he
could have played Queen E3 check forcing
the Queens off the board and entering an
end game where white is better plays
without risk and maybe Parham it was
near move 40 he didn't have much time he
was likely assessing this as being
difficult for him if not believing that
white has better chances to win than he
had to draw we could see the evaluation
bar say oh not so fast black is holding
on because after Rook A3 the king is
very close to the g-pawn so if you
attack it the king defends it and if you
sit passively for now it's not the end
of the story the game will continue
maybe the white king comes over to this
Pawn or maybe it goes up to the up the
board he push the king side pawns but it
should with proper play be a drop Parham
probably didn't want to give up material
without time to think about all the
options and then since the played
perfectly threat after threat causing
problems for this King on D7 and even
though the eval bar wasn't changing
that's a credit to Parham maksulu's
defensive resourcefulness but as we're
getting into the game I just saw that
Rook it looks like he moved that piece
and just to see where he went Rook D3
was the choice and it's going up and up
Tanya this might be a situation where
this king is not going to find shelter
and at the very least white could pick
off the pawn A6 with check
I mean you want to pick off bonds to
give Checkmate here Queen B7 Rook B6
there's just no way that that doesn't
end in Checkmate we've got the analysis
board up the players we can see on our
cam Queen B7 will be on the board Robert
is King D6 Rook B6 does that end in mate
or not
see the king runs to E5 the queen goes
to a check I want to see if I say G8 but
that looks wrong let's go to G7
King if four then rookie six is lights
out oh my gosh the king can't escape the
Rooks in its path
that's a huge problem for Parham he
would love his Rook to be back on D4 or
something so his King could run away he
goes for it he goes for Queen B7 check
the only move Parham is going to make it
really quick he's going to go King D6
and now not the back I'll be surprised
if he goes on to pick up the pawn on A6
might still be winning huge Advantage
but it looks like the way he's played
his eyes are on the Target and the
target is that King yes I thought Queen
A6 was you know forcing a Checkmate or a
win of the queen as well because the
king stepped up there'd be Rook B5 but
after Queen A6 check the king runs it
back to E7 clearly still a huge
Advantage for white you could steal
another pawn and go after the king that
would be winning but I'm with you Tonya
check check check oh
he took the pawn
you know you know what he did he just
wanted to do this Robert he wanted me to
feel better but I also think that he is
in a situation where he's moving very
quickly because he sees a way to grab a
bunch of Pawns and he knows for a fact
that that is you know a significant
Advantage if not a win so he doesn't
want to calculate all the king
maneuvering but he did have that winner
you had the better move with Rook B6
it doesn't matter I just thought Rook P6
was the most natural way it's so
tempting to go in there with the Rook
but this is winning as well as we can
see Queen Essex he he picks up the bunch
of Pawns as you're saying there's a
famous saying in chess right if you see
a Checkmate or you can win material win
material because sometimes the mate is
not a maid and you're just sort of a
long line wrong line uh but if you win
material you know you're going to win
the game in the end so he does pick up
the A6 Pawn picks up the G6 pawn and the
troubles on black skin continue the one
thing we notice is that how White's King
has remained unscratched there's been no
threat on the king no way black has
managed to create play and that has been
the biggest drawback of Black's position
it doesn't matter if you mate
immediately or five moves later nor the
back has found the way Queen G6
everything safe The Rook is definitely
coming into B7 next you've got Queen G7
check ideas if Black's Rook intercepts
on D7 and this just looks like game over
Queen C6 is not possible Queen D5 is
that a move to try and defend and you've
got Rook E1 perhaps we have so many
checks Queen G7 check rookie one check
there's even Rook B7 check because if
you take the Rook ooh G7 with a skewer
winning the queen so uh Rook B7 is
available I would like to play that as
king going to the last rank I don't have
Checkmate so how is that possible
the queen covers my mating Square
hmm
should still be easily winning though
because if the King goes over here this
queen B6 Queen B6 and Rook d8 picks up
the queen yeah okay I'm starting to uh
believe that for Parham you know he's
got no chance anymore there are too many
threats there have been too many threats
and that is how top players win chess
games it's not always as simple as uh
let me go win a minor piece Jordan van
Forest blundered upon yesterday against
five minute carwana that is a rare
occurrence what's more likely to happen
is the sustained pressure leads to an
inaccuracy because we're not engines
right none of these players can see
through to every single variation and so
mistakes happen when you're under
pressure and Parham has been fighting
clawing into back in this game but no
they're back never let him go I mean
seriously such an impressive attacking
display
just super stuff but the uzbeki Prodigy
here and this is how he won the world
rapid Championship as well where he just
kept putting pressure and playing fast
and we see him not only putting pressure
on the boat but the clock as well
playing accurate playing fast farha
makes the decision to go with the King
to D7 so his idea is that if you jump in
with Rook C Rook to be seven with a
check he wants to go King C8 and attack
your rook and not give you enough time
to create threat because once White's
Rook leaves the first track black will
also start threatening Rook D1 check
coming in Queen G1 check ideas so Rook
B7 I think would be an accurate
inaccuracy here I agree with you and one
thing to note is now that white has
stolen two pawns a queen trade is almost
certainly going to be winning unless you
allow that pawn of the board so there
may be a position where instead of going
for a Checkmate everybody's like all
right let's get those Queens off and the
ensuing end game is just one so Queen F7
check for instance all right Queen E7
you can't play because Rook B7 but I was
just wanting to show a position like
this I guess it's not as winning as I
thought it might be because the pawn is
so Advanced and the black king will
Sprint to help the pawn and that means
that White's pawns are a little bit too
slow but I was just looking to see if
there was a queen trade victory for
white the answer is no but after Queen
F7 Queen E7 Rook B7 would win that Queen
on the seventh rank
I'll just be a little disappointed if
this ends up in a rook Pawn ending grind
win rather than a spectacular Checkmate
because the play that white has
displayed this deserves a beautiful
finish
yeah and you know tournaments often have
a Brilliance prize and usually some kind
of amazing tactic this was just effort
pure effort on the part of noribbeck
Abdul sitar he's earning this game but
it's not over so he can't let Parham
push this Pawn of the board and have
some hope so I like Queen F7 check I
think it's a good idea to start giving
the king some checks where does that
King even go from there if it goes to C8
I think that the queen comes to B7 the
king comes to d8 and we start giving
even more checks and The Rook comes in
somehow this you know the there's no
mate yet but it looks you know so
promising
well not about reaching out is
definitely going to be a check there
because as we've seen that if black is
given just a couple of moves then you
can allow see C3 that would just no
checks of course no checks who gives
checks noobs give checks checks for
noobs I can't believe it he moved this
Pawn up to A5 because he wants a new
Queen like that he sees everything this
is a full board Awareness on display uh
just to go back a second there if he the
pawn was captured on A5 he now has Rook
B7 check because after King C8 that
queen that was protecting the king from
C5 there's Queen C6 check the King has
to go to d8 we give it a check and this
is a known pattern rookie Queen E6
rookie only move and we just have this
King in a vice grip so A5 taking
advantage of the fact that the queen
needs to stay in contact with the C6
square and now Rook D1 is that a threat
timer that's the big question because if
it's not a threat you can just push your
opponent up to A6 and win that way but
if it is a threat maybe start giving
some checks
it's amazing how quickly Barham
responded with Queen D5 in this position
because he needs to start threatening a
check also from parham's point of view
before naughty back went A5 he's of
course looking at all these different
checks and these different ideas where
is he going to go with the King and
suddenly your opponent comes on and
makes this completely unexpected move
that really shakes you up it's so
difficult to handle after Queen D5 I
don't think you can allow a rook trade
that would give black a lot of chances
because then the C4 Pawn starts counting
so he does finally give a check from G4
also controlling the D1 square and his
idea is simple he's not even going for
checkmate Robert you move the king
anywhere everything's under control I
won't be surprised if we see white
pushing A6 on the next move he's going
to and I feel like I've learned a great
lesson about when to give a check
instead of giving the first check that
crosses your mind maybe the threat
really is strong with the execution I
always thought that was just some saying
that I didn't need to listen to but now
I I feel like I've learned a lot thank
you noribbeck you may be young but you
have taught us all an important lesson
and it's time to push the pawn up to A6
you can play Rook B6 check I'm sure
that's good but the way nordybeck is
played he is going to refrain from
giving a check on B6 push this Pawn up
and this distract at bare minimum the
black pieces because the C Pawn is a bit
too slow A6 A7 and 8 is likely to happen
I don't like group B6 check because that
might actually give black the
possibility to go King C5 and start
advancing with the King you don't have
so many checks yourself let's say King
C5 and it's probably still winning for
white you've still got Queen C8 check
but suddenly ideas like Rook D1 come
into play I'll go all the way up to D4
Robert and this gets complicated so
we're not about been playing A6 is
definitely going to happen you've been
talking about board awareness keeping in
mind all the aspects that exist we've
been saying that Queen on G4 defends The
Rook from jumping onto D1 but we forgot
to mention this H3 Pawn that was the
other idea of the move Queen D5 and with
Queen G4 not only did he stop the D1
square but he also stops all ideas with
Rook H3 A6 as we were talking about it's
on the board it's played and Parham
immediately responds with C3 he's got
three minutes a move to make
he's threatening to go C2 next
hopes is a threat it's not even really a
threat oh Rook B6 because King C5
there's Queen before mate now that the
pawn pushed he waited for the pawn to
push so it clears the fourth rank God
he's everything
that is and if you go King C7 he wants
to go Rook B7 Check Yes and if you're
King D6 now Rook D7 give me your queen
at bare minimum there might have been
checklist
he has just played everything so
perfectly
a masterpiece Robert King C7 Rook B7 if
you go King C6 you end up with Queen A4
check let's just point out the different
checkmates that are there Queen A4 King
D6 goes into your trap if you go down to
the and this is game over if you go down
to the eighth rank that is made along
the eighth rack he's gone King E5 it was
the only move to stay in the game to
survive to not lose the queen
immediately oh my gosh but Queen G5
check the King has to go up the board
if you go to D4 there's Queen F4 Jack
you're winning the queen that wins the
queen on the spot if King F4 a king
default excuse me Queen F4 because this
is the Checkmate that nerdibox uh set up
and if the queen goes to E4 Rook B4
checks and wins the queen so that means
your King has to go to E4 at this point
and the queen E7 check if your king goes
to D4 their ideas with Rook to D6 if you
go Queen E5 there's idea oh no I blunder
checkmated one rookie six thinking
you're winning the Queen the queen
survives and checkmates the white king
so be careful in order to make that
would be a heartbreaker to blunder and
we see the king is up on E5 not the
queen yet but do not make the blunder I
just did
and it's so easy to make these mistakes
Robert and for sure if it's a bullet or
a Blitz game it's bound to happen but
these players the kind of moves that
they've been making how accurate they've
been their awareness has been so on
point they're fully aware of these ideas
Queen G5 played and after King moves on
to D4 I'm still wondering does White
have
what is white have because Rook B4 check
I thought was winning at first but you
still have King C5 and you survive
King to E4 played yeah and the queen E7
check Queen E5 do not be like me do not
blunder a Checkmate because Rook D1 is
the threat I think you have to keep
giving checks so Queen E7 Queen E5 bring
this queen back maybe to H4 because that
leaves this side of the board open for
the rook and if the king keeps going in
comes the queen to E1 with check and now
I think we win the queen somehow
I don't win The Rook okay
winning material that's all you need to
finish the game
and the good news for nordeback is that
he's got 14 minutes on the clock to
figure out a pleasant choice of checks
that he has currently he can go Queen E7
there's Queen H4 you could go Queen G4
all of them keep his winning position
intact he's reaching out for the queen
and he makes him with Queen E7 Robert
he's playing the line that you're
calling out
but Queen E5 just no rookie six just
stop there
okay Queen E5 do not blunder the
Checkmate I did that's the one thing is
look out for otherwise he keeps giving
checks oh my gosh Queen if I play it
please do not play rookie stick I never
root for a player it's not gonna happen
Robert I mean have you been seeing the
kind of chest that notifex played
it would break my heart for him if he'd
blunder checked many one I know he's not
gonna do it he's not me he's not a fool
uh but that would be the ultimate
tragedy and look what he's doing by the
way he's spending time he knows he's
winning he he's going to win whether he
has 13 minutes on his clock or he has
three minutes on the clock so he's doing
the right thing trying to find the
quickest knockout
I mean rookie 6 would be the worst
blunder in the history of worst blunders
in this position imagine playing this
amazing game and then walking into this
Maid of one mate in one but it's
happened it's happened to everyone and
it can happen with the fact that he
slowed down and he's taken his time if
it was a bullet game one could still
expect it but with time on hand he's
going
to what comes to mind look before Queen
87 all these ideas I like that notabeck
is taking his time to calculate and we
see that an Orbiter standing as the
players have crossed the 60th move but
it doesn't matter anymore the addition
of time on parham's clock because he's
busted on the board I feel like the
Arbiter is doing tactics you know like
oh how can I find the Checkmate here
yeah where's the quickest Checkmate and
neuterbeck playing like this a
disrespect Speed Run I mean the way he
was playing you know how quickly he was
playing uh it was really a sight to
behold and I do love that he slowed down
it's a lesson for everybody out there
who feels like they don't end up winning
games that are just completely won he
knows that he is winning he doesn't need
to rush this decision blundering a
Checkmate on the first Frank so Queen H4
check looks good Rook B4 check looks
good after Rook before maybe be there is
Rook D4 that you have to calculate so
there's just no reason to rush and as
soon as I say don't rush he plays Queen
H4 not that he rushed but he is finding
the right way King F5 walks into the
Checkmate a king D5 loses the queen uh
King E3 was the only way but then this
queen drops back to E1 and will
eventually win this Rook it seems
that's a really nice four sequence of
moves and we see a move by parami's gone
for King to F5
and Checkmate that is that handshakes
and I love that Parham let notibe
Checkmate him so many people resign they
don't want to be checkmated but that's a
sign of respect that Norbeck played a
brilliant game and let's let him finish
the job so credit to both these players
Parham finding the king Escape but we
just have to talk about one player
particular norimek Abdul sitarov he is a
a rising star he's a former World rapid
Champion he led his country to a gold
medal in the chess Olympics he is a
monster and currently he is in a shared
first place with Anish giri Tony we
can't say enough about him
absolutely this is his debut at the Tata
steel masters with three points going
into the rest day and what a gameplay
that was we saw the players even Parham
acknowledging just the brilliant chess
that his opponent showcased with a big
shout out to Parham kudos to him for
finding these defensive resources Played
Like A Champion himself but not a back
in the end just putting so much pressure
so much pressure that the ambitious play
that Barham offered just backfired at
the end but brilliant play by both these
youngsters not a back clearly with a
bright bright future ahead and I'm not
even just talking about a far away
future I'm talking about the future of
this tournament currently leading the
event along with Anish giri it used to
be the case when you looked at the
younger generation that they received an
invite into the field like that's the
person I'm going to beat because playing
Magnus playing Wesley playing Levon that
sounds very difficult but I'm going to
beat the lower rated younger players who
don't have that experience you look at
this tournament nobody could produce a
tarf at the top okay he is not somebody
who is just going to lose of course not
he's in fact in a tie for first place
and speaking of youngsters who are
making their mark on the tournament we
have prognananda here taking on dingley
Ren and Prague has been better for most
of the game you know we apologize to him
and to ding the rent for not being able
to focus as much as we would like
because we'd love to give everybody
unlimited attention but now all eyes are
on this matchup and Tanya he is up a
pawn it's this H Pawn still surviving
but look at dingley rent he's fighting
back trying to get active attack this
Pawn on B6 to keep this rook in the
king's sight I mean it's a good effort
from ding the rent even though black
remains upon ahead
and it's a very healthy Bond ahead a
rook D6 played defending the B6 Pawn
attacking the Knight on T6 so white
still doesn't have a have the time to
activate the Rook to 87 as well hitting
on H5 you can go Knight F4
and attack the H5 Pawn but that just
helps black further because black really
wants to get H4 in Prague wants to go on
to push the spawn further so once the
Knight moves to F4 H4 becomes a free
pass and that would make things even
more difficult for black for white sorry
for sure and the King on F2 is well
positioned this is an end game use your
King as a weapon white is doing just
that at some point there could be a king
B5 to go after the B6 Pawn so that's why
the Rook on D6 is so well placed it's
protecting that pawn over there on B6
and you do not want to trade off Rooks
because if you trade Rooks and this
Knight can't catch up to the H Pawn that
will not be good for ding Lee Ren so
where is his Knight going Knight F4 H4
looks pretty good uh for black where
else can you go
even that position Robert I think white
has to try to coordinate the Knight and
the Rook to create threats against
Black's King and I'm trying to find the
way forward for Prague let's say you go
Knight F4 because it feels like a forced
sequence of moves you go H4 you have to
defend the H5 pawn and what if I start
threatening with discovered checks I go
Rook to F7 your idea of King B5 might
very well be the right way but it's
encouraging to see the eval bar not drop
down below I want to threaten some
checks with my knight and the problem
that black has is that where do you go
with your king let's say you go to G1 I
start giving you a million checks 92
Knight F4 92 Knight F4 Knight H3 Knight
F4 and how are you hiding with your king
if you go King H1 then watch out Rook
287 and you might just lose your biggest
strength yeah that's not what I want to
do I would rather keep my King close to
my Pawn so when you check me a bunch I
think I can ah I was gonna go here but
then I saw the eval bar react negatively
but you're right there's so many checks
here if the King goes here Knight F4
check if the King goes back no more
checks but thank you for the punch I've
separated this is amazing stuff Rook G4
winning that Bond so it's still not easy
and white has got counter chances by
coordinating that rook and Knight
against black skin and ding is fully
aware of all this this is what he's
trying to create I think we're going to
see this line we are going to see Knight
F4 because I don't find an alternative
for white
I guess throwing in the check first and
then seeing where the King goes because
if it goes to G3 then Rook G7 the same
exact plan that we were just
orchestrating and I I need to take us
back uh to move 49 because I am being
informed we didn't get to look at the
game that the move here King F5 was in
inaccuracy compared to King F6 uh just
the difference being that in the game
after King F5 uh the king going to E4 it
perhaps the king went on a long journey
and it slowed down the progress of the
pawn whereas if the king had gone to F6
immediately uh over here
after Rook takes C7 uh maybe even this
Knight comes back into the game and this
Rook slides the B4 with check and I
think that black not up a pawn anymore
but will likely get that pawn and be
able to protect the remaining Pawns
but that said it's so natural to go
ahead with your king that's the kind of
Chess that humans
humans finding the move King F6 would be
super hard draw but in a game and
especially when
so can't blame Prague for missing that
one but a critical moment that pointed
out Rook D6 and ding is still having a
thing as you mentioned Rook F7 is an
alternative to Knight F4 so two ways
forward here to still pose resistance to
this H Pawn
if Prague is able to get this Pawn
rolling down the board that's bad news
so I don't think white has the time to
try and create play on The Queen side as
such
right and so well I'm look at the clocks
by the way because we are move 56 and if
these clocks are up to speed they are
down to just about a minute to make four
moves and that can be easier said than
done especially for dingley Ren one slip
one wrong spot for the night this H Pawn
runs and becomes a queen so dingley Ren
he's got his back against the wall he
might throw in the check he might just
play Knight F4 but he has to move Tanya
he needs to move
I feel Knight F4 is tough if you haven't
if because you know with just 50 seconds
on the clock just fearing this move H4
if you are not thinking about the idea
of Rook F7 it I don't know it's kind of
hard to play Knight F4 as well
he played it he he went through it just
as you said it he says Tanya what was
that it's not too hard for me yeah if
you can spot it it's not hot Tanya
Knight f4 on the board played by Ding
and he hits that pawn on H5 H4 we were
pointing out which looks scary at first
as black is threatening to go King G3
and H3 start pushing that pawn but it
might just have enough time for white to
go Rook F7 we'll find out H4 has to be
played Pro goes for it will didn't go
for this counter attack with Rook F7 he
goes Rook G7 that's a new way to play
and I see or a valbar it approves
yes it stays around the same and the
point is the Knight can go to H3 with
check and the black king can't touch
this so that's good news for dingley Ren
but if the King goes up to F3 and the
Knight does slide to H3 to stop this
Pawn maybe the Black Knight it's been
good on B4 for a large part of this game
let's go into D3 I'm attacking the pawn
to B2 I might give you a check on E5 I
might even be able to trade Knights at
some point if I'm not walking into a pin
so that's what black really wants to do
is dislodge the blockading pieces of the
passer so a nitrate would be favorable
if not just immediately winning for
black
and 30 seconds for Prague he still gotta
make two moves he goes King F3 Knight H3
playing the ending out to Perfection as
we can see with the eval bar it remains
about the same Advantage for Prague
currently black still has to watch out
for checks on G5 checks on G1 Rook G7 a
clever move stopping the black king from
connecting with the H Pawn no King G3 as
long as white can keep the H Pawn as is
it gives hope to White's position but
frog needs to find a way to dislodge
this Knight
and the problem for white though is the
pieces can barely move Knight G1 check
Knight back to H3 we see that but if you
ever move your Rook to F7 then the king
approaches the Knight and forces it away
from H3 so coming up with an idea for
white not easy but for prognana down on
the clock right now he has got to find a
move I think Knight D3 rerouting the
Knight over towards the king side is the
way to go maybe your knight also ends up
on G4 to block seconds
okay good move he's just four seconds on
the clock
go on Robert no no no it's good for you
to call that out I mean he barely got
that move off
barely got that moving with four seconds
he's now up to 34 seconds he still has
one more move to go Robert he made the
move Knight C6 and you were pointing out
Knight D3 with similar ideas but it
looks like he hasn't messed up his
Advantage with this move one can get so
panicky in these situations but not
pragnananda
no and the Knight is coming you have
watch out for Rook G6 as well by the way
that is in some positions a threat and
the Knight goes up to G5 giving the king
a check if you go to the G file anywhere
you are going to regret it because the
Knight will check and there'll be a
discovery against the king so the king
should step either up to F2 or over to
E3 looks even better to my eyes because
king of two walks into a fork
king after walks into a fork King F4
also gives the chance to give a check on
H3 and then you're just pushing the king
further backing F5 Rook G5 check
meanwhile King E3 not an easy move to
make either because you're going far
away from your Pawn King F4 staying
closer to it but this does give white
the opportunity to come back with the
check he does it and now will Prague go
further back on the board but it's move
number 61 we see the players lean back
take a breather very important to just
calm down compose yourself that frog
having a drink he needs to just get up
wash his face come back and take this
position afresh
oh so the clock is ticking down but you
get an extra 15 minutes so to remind
everybody of the time Patrol move 60 has
been reached and once 60 is 60 the move
is made you get 15 minutes for the rest
of the game prognanda he is going to
wisely use that time so while he does
Tanya and I are gonna head out for a
quick break just like dingley red he was
jetting away from the board will jet
away but just for a little bit and when
return we'll break down this exciting
end game where prognanda is up a pawn
against the number two player in the
world
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids that feels just like playing
but chess is a great way to learn
patience strategy and critical thinking
chess kid features a comprehensive
training program that guides kids to
level up on their way to Mastery there
are more than fifty thousand chest
muscles and a whole library of
entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thus far in round four we have two
leaders at the moment probably hoping to
be the third Victor we'll see if he's
able to do that now that he's back at
the board but the major story today was
Anish giri's epic win over Magnus
Carlson and he shared his thoughts on
when he knew the game was in the bag and
what this Victory meant to him
I thought it was in the bag uh after
first time after he allowed me in bcbc
because I think I thought it was
actually dead lost and then I blundered
96 and then the second time I thought
after A5 Bishop A5 Rook C8
I mean I thought okay it's very
convertible
um even for me but it was in the bag uh
after
first time after he allowed me bcbc
because I think I thought it was
actually dead lost and then I blundered
96 and then the second time I thought
after A5 Bishop A5 Rook C8
I mean I thought okay it's very
convertible
um even for me but you know still
possible like I was almost blunder at
one point I thought I'm I haven't he has
no moves I've almost played King G2 then
there's 93 check cheaper so there's like
but then when I saw that I was like oh
yeah that that's that blunder it I
should avoid so that was good actually I
was sort of just thinking that uh the
odds of me messing this one up are
higher than usual that made me feel
relieved because uh I didn't put much
pressure on myself I thought like okay
you know
but he likes it I'll mess this one up
somehow I don't really see how maybe it
will happen uh I didn't feel the usual
Magnus effect because um I felt like he
was missing stuff
um and he was making moves that I
thought were weaker than the moves I
expected and um that gave me confidence
but in terms of like uh yeah I think
it's a sort of a historic moment I've
beaten him once but everybody knows it
was a little bit lame he blundered
something
and I was so small it was a different
person back then uh so yeah I really and
it's always a kind of a weird story
because I always tell my story noted so
I beat him at 16 and I've never beaten I
never beaten him ever since and that's
always a weird like and I was thinking
something I was thinking like I have to
beat him at some point right we're not
going to wait till like we're both 50
and we played the smash like Tim and
karpo for playing you know like uh so I
thought like okay
um so I'm really happy that I won
because now you know yeah I was uh was a
fair and square
while Tanya we heard Anish curious
thoughts uh he's saying that it meant a
ton to him and he felt like it was a
smooth conversion according to him
unlike the first time he beat Magnus
which was back in 2011 in their match
right here at the waikansea Tata steel
event so a long time ago as you
mentioned an important insight there by
a niche that he feels like Magnus is a
bit shaky and he made the most of it and
felt like he couldn't really feel that
Magnus effect that Magnus touched that
most players do where it's almost
impossible to even win a winning game
against him but today he made it look
good he made it look easy and a
brilliantly played their game there by
Anish giri really interesting moments as
he highlighted that A5 move by Magnus
that we were discussing where things
really turned around but for the one
player for whom things are not turning
around anytime soon is being lyron look
at prognan thus still hanging on to that
advantage that H Pawn that extra Pawn
currently dings hopes rely on this
Knight on H3 stopping that pawn from
moving forward but how long can that
happen for what black has these ideas
Robert of giving a check on E5
95 Rook G6 ideas trying to dislodge this
Knight on H3 if Prague manages to do
that this end game would end badly for
ding but trading the Rooks at the moment
would probably be a huge mistake because
Rook G6 tactically is protected but
after Rook G6 Knight E5 check the white
king goes up to B5 and will take B6 so
if we continue the variation King takes
B6 Knight F4 we are kicking this Knight
out of here and if you trade Knights
this would be winning for black the H
Pawn is first you take on A5 you're way
way way too slow while this Pawn
promotes so that would not be good for
white to trade Knights but the Knight
goes up to G5 and it's a bit Untouchable
because if you went to G1 then the black
king comes to F2 the Knight is trapped
but it goes to G5 if you ever push the
pawn to H3 it's going to be a sacrifice
on H3 and the best that black can do it
apparently will do is make a draw
because two Pawns against a night a lone
knight and king cannot deliver a
checkmate
nicely pointed out with the current
position that we are seeing we see a few
checks been given there Knight H3 was
played and black continued let's just
get up to date with the position
yeah with Knight to D4
Knight D4 played and this is where we
are
yes the last move played was a Prague
bringing that Knight up into the center
over here and well it's dingling around
on the clock and he can't bring his King
to B5
I thought Wait no that's not Checkmate
right the king go to D5
not Checkmate yet I I've already
blundered a few checkmates today so
Tanya I need your help seeing if it's
checkmated one it's late in the day but
imagine that is also something that we
keep talking about the players the kind
of stamina that they need for these Long
play games here and in these critical
moments often arise we're already in the
sixth hour of play and you know we've
got Prague against the Mighty Ding
pushing for a win with the black pieces
he needs to play this out till the end
he's got nine minutes on the clock this
is the final time control the final 15
minutes Edition has happened after move
60th so he's got nine minutes to find a
way to convert this position into a win
Robert what do you think is it closer to
a prog win or closer to a ding hold
I think a Prague wins this outside pass
Pawn looks so strong over here the
Knight can hop over to F3 F5 to keep
that pawn safe and sound and what black
would really like is to somehow get the
Rook over to B4 I feel like it defends
and attacks simultaneously and look at
this Knight on F3 it's just it's a
passive piece uh the good thing it's
doing along with the Rook is keeping the
black king out so that the pawn can't
push but with the Knight coming to D4 if
you try to kick this King out from E3
The Rook can intercept and the
difference now is in the other variation
the King was already taking on B6 so it
after it takes takes you go King to B5
you're too slow King comes to F3 King
takes B6 and King G2 actually traps the
Knight the Knight on E6 covers the
Escape squares the black king will
gobble up this Knight and then the H
Pawn will become a queen so the E6
square is just better for that black
knight and that means that rookie 7
check will just be blocked by The Rook
on E6
that's a really nice point because
usually you want to trade out of Rooks
you want to make that H Pawn The Rook
Pawn win because Knights are so bad
against it but here because of White's
activity the king activity this plan
will fail so rookie 7 still has a
defense resource for uh after rookie
seven black he still has the idea to go
rookie six as you're pointing out
Robert but then what is the way forward
here for white after Knight D4
you simply keep the Rook as is do I
I'm trying to find a move here for white
and I'm struggling I guess if you keep
the Rook on the G file black will give
this check on C6 and what you're doing
is forcing this King aways the King goes
with the D6 and now the king is cut off
along the C file which makes your B6
Pawn feel safer and maybe black can just
go after these Queen side pawns maybe
Quirk C2 to take this one or Rook C4 to
take the A4 Pawn but either way I feel
like black can start going after the
queen side not just to rely on this Pawn
H4
you know I keep saying the White Knight
on H3 is so important because it blocks
the pawn on H4 but the Knight is also so
far away from the rest of the game and
meanwhile black can play on the king
side and the queen side as you're
pointing at so we do have a move as Rook
G4 been played yes it has ding has gone
for Rook G4 and now your idea of Rook C6
is a possibility I I think you want this
King to venture up the board all the way
to D6 the pawn H4 can't be captured
because of Knight F5 checks that does
give the black Rook a turn if it wants
to go say Rook to C4 and you can't take
this Pawn because it's a fork and you
lose the Rook just on H4 would be a huge
blunder so I'm looking at this position
and I feel like black is making some
serious progress to go after these Queen
side pawns but it really does come down
to whether or not white can quickly try
to scoop up the pawn on H4
here's a fun idea if black was to
actually move the Rook anywhere else the
D4 Knight isn't hanging and I just want
to demonstrate it it's not going to
happen but it's a fun point to make
let's say you move Rook F6 or Rook F6
defending the H4 Pawn which of course
makes a lot more sense and now you pick
up the Knight on D4 Rook D4 this would
be a huge blunder by white because then
comes in a check and can go King D5 or
King B5 attacking The Rook on C6 it
doesn't matter either ways black gives a
check on C5 and ends up picking up the
Rook on D4 which also defends his own
roken C5 so fun fact the D4 Knight is
not hanging that's an amazing variation
and extremely important because my
initial reaction I have to keep my Rook
here or check the king away but Rook H6
might just be a great move getting
behind your pass pawn and if you can't
take this Knight on D4 that means that
black has the time necessary perhaps to
bring the the Knight to F3 I do need to
get this Knight out of here so Knight E2
King F3 maybe Knight F4 King G3 I just
really really really really want to
force the Knight out
I like your move Knight F3 even in the
starting position without Rook 86
because in fact Knight F3 would not only
defend the H4 Pawn but even threaten a
deadly Knight E5 Fork as well so this is
the another option that Prague is
probably thinking about an attractive
move Knight F3 and he goes instead for
the check approach that we looked at
earlier driving the king away and
potentially targeting the queen side
Pawns
his Knight F5 check as a fork so he
doesn't need to play it right away if
we've learned anything from Notre Beck
Abdus atarov is when you have a check
you don't necessarily have to play that
check and so Rook to C4 Rook to C2 go
after these pawns over here and then
Knight F5 check is available and If you
get another move you go Knight F3 to
defend it
I like to move Rook C4 because then you
really have a discover check threat
picking up the rook and you're putting
pressure on the A4 Pawn as well
this has been a really well played End
Game by Prague and I've always felt
Robert that end games being strong at
them is such a strong sign of maturity
as a chess player because growing up we
often tend to focus on openings and
middle game on attack but being able to
play these technical positions the way
Prague is it just goes on to show his
experience and maturity is well beyond
his age
and he's playing this so nicely right
now I feel like he's showing us some
great technique you said he is a mature
player he certainly is providing that
evidence in this game and he's forcing
the white king away two squares either
D7 or E6 and no matter where you go the
black king can inch closer and closer
and I do want to point out that if you
go Knight G3 you can't get your King
around to attack this Knight so you kind
of shut the Rook off from the G file and
we've already been mentioning this idea
of Rook C4 I love that go after loose
pawns and maybe even bring your Rook
over to the G4 Square so your king can
chase down the Knight
it's truly a position where black is
playing with all the Army all the toys
in the nursery Rook C4 the King on E3
Super Active the night-giving checks
white has got too much to defend white
has got to keep an eye on the H Pawn not
advancing it the Knight on H3 is
constantly stuck doing that The Rook is
stuck preventing black species from
approaching the Knight on H3 which just
leaves the queen side super vulnerable
so really nicely pointed out uh Robert
that the full board awareness
Prague can show here by now going for
the pawns on the queen side King D7
played and there are no threats now that
white has created in on Black's pieces
so this is the moment where you could
make the move King F3 but then you have
to calculate the line that Rook F4 you
still have King G3 and you're still fine
actually so King King F3 is possible
because the Knight on F5 is defended by
The Rook on C5 and in fact Rook F4 would
be a big blunder although I'm wondering
if the king F3 Rook G5 it's not a pin
because the pawn on B6 protect protects
that Rook so the Knight is able to move
away from F5 that's really good news for
Prague so that makes king of three all
the more uh enticing I think he should
go for that and Tony what do you think
about his clock management he is down to
about six minutes remaining there is no
more time to be gained besides a 30
second increment do you feel that he has
enough time to convert this position
because it doesn't look too easy
I think that's going to be the big play
Factor here is going to be the clock
situation Prague if he's able to find
the right plan which is what he's trying
to figure out how to combine the threats
on the queen side and get this Knight to
be dislodged from H3 because there's a
30 second increment on every move it's
going to be enough but he needs to find
that winning path within the next four
minutes because let's say the clock runs
down to 30 seconds and you're playing on
under a minute and the advantage remains
at where it is it can get super tricky
to convert a position like that
it feels tricky I mean this
current position you think what do we
want to achieve if this Knight can
sacrifice for this Pawn at some point
and then the white king can get over
here towards the queen side pawns that
gives more hope to ding leren we always
want to visualize what future looks best
for us and that's one to aim for but
that's not gonna happen anytime soon the
night on F5 protecting this Pawn H4 this
night on H3 Knight on the rim are dim
and look at prog's King it's getting
closer hits The Rook on G4 I feel like
Rook G8 is the move that you kind of
want to play just to get out of there
because Rook G5 once this Knight moves
The Rook trade is offered and I do not
think that white can afford to trade
Rooks in this current position
here's a fun idea Robert if Rook G8
black can actually continue with the
line that we're looking at of attacking
the pawn on A4 take a look at this Rook
G8 I go Rook C4 and you want to play
Rook f8 try and win that night let's say
you go real Cafe I can maybe go king
after King G4 but that allows Knight F2
checks and I don't want to allow any of
that now I can simply take the pawn on
A4 Rook A4 and if you go Rook F5 your
Rook at night are geometrically placed
in a way that I can Fork them with my
king go King G4 win one of the two
pieces and that would be game over so in
fact Rook C4 regardless of where you
move the Rook of course if you play it
to Rook G5 in the current position if
you just go back then as you mentioned
black can go Knight to D4 or maybe still
the idea of Rook C4 is Rook C4 still a
possibility
yes yes it is wow what attack did you
found here it's actually really
important because after this hitting the
rook in the night if you go Rook B5
you're gonna win this Pawn on B6 but
that's not the important part at the
moment and the A4 Pawn is loose I think
you play King G3 because the Rook is on
the fourth rank it will block all checks
and the plan is simple H3 H2 and if the
Rook Gets behind the pawn the blackwork
will slide over to H4 to intercept it
and then black promotes so the pieces
are perfectly placed for prognananda uh
really cool tactic you just showed us
with the Rook taking on F5 and the King
sliding into G4
it's going to be more interesting to see
if Prague really wants to focus and
shift his attention to the queen side
pawns because very often when we've got
a plan in mind of the dislodging the
Knight on H3 that could be the big focus
of the position and that would make it
super hard to make a move like Rook C4
eyeing that A4 Pawn but if Prague wants
that approach then he needs a clear path
of how he's dislodging the Knight on H3
one of the ways in which he can do that
after the move Rook G5 would be to move
the Knight away let's say Knight D4
offer a trade of the Rooks I think Rook
C5 would lose on the spot
yeah and this looks like this is bad
news with the King coming in and there's
White's King is super far away to pick
up all the pawns uh King G3 next just
finishes the game
yes so Road trades are bad for white you
can't even win it what looks like a free
Knight on F5 even if the Rook moves away
so for dingley rent right now I think
Rook G8 makes the most sense but Rook C4
is such an obvious reply going after the
A4 point I
you asked me earlier uh you know what I
thought about the winning chances I feel
like Prague is definitely winning this
game and he's beating a player rated
over 2 800. Prague has been famous
throughout India for his wins over
Magnus Carlson but those were in Rapid
chess shorter time Patrol and an online
event that's not to say that it's not a
magnificent achievement of course it is
it's just different and classical chess
you know Magnus Carlson lost today it
really doesn't lose very often dingley
Ren he also hardly loses he had an
unbeaten shriek of a hundred plus games
right so ding is hard to take down he is
playing a world championship match later
this year but pragna Nanda he's a
teenager but he is going to take down
the world's number two
foreign we are looking at a 17 year old
currently
playing against
the world championship Challenger a 2800
plus player one of the world-class
players and with the black pieces so far
currently the teenager is the one who is
out playing ding it has been an amazing
and end game play so far and Robert he's
really kept his Advantage going move by
move he has kept attention on the board
making it more difficult for ding who is
really defending this position by a
thread here currently he has to keep the
Knight on H3 defended the queen side
pawns defend it is too much to hold on
to this is a huge moment and today has
all been about a niche defeating Magnus
but if Prague does this if he pulls this
victory in his bag
this is no less than what Anish has done
today
I think in many ways more surprising
because probably known as the black
pieces and Anish had white he has beaten
Magnus before he's also in an older
player compared to prognelli he's not
old he's telling his 20s but it's
something that the world has seen before
and the world has come to expect more so
than prognananda with black against ding
the Wren these super solid the technical
wizard dingly Ren but right now look at
Prague he is focused he wants to win
this game and dingley runs doing
everything he can but it's a lonely
playing haul out there as we see behind
him there are some people still sitting
and watching but just a few it was a
full Lively vibrant atmosphere earlier
today and now before the rest day very
few people remain
and prague's sister vaishali who is
playing in the challenges has also
finished her game she's not to be seen
in the playing Hall but we can see just
a couple of people walking around but
Prague and ding don't care about any of
that right now it's all about the board
in front of them Prague is trying to
squeeze out this win he is doing really
well in that task thing trying to save
that half a point but it looks like it's
going to be too difficult to do that
with the position that we have in front
of us this is prague's second outing in
the Tata steel Masters he did have his
debut in 2022 where he finished 11th
place and
in the Challenger so I'm sorry about
that this is his debut at the Tata steel
Masters he played last year in the
challengers where he finished with five
and a half out of 13. the 17 year old
impressed us all at the Olympiad in
online formats he's established himself
as one of the best players in the world
amongst the elite but this event means
so much to him he is playing in OTB over
the board classical format against the
best players in the world and holding
his own here as well
no losses thus far three draws and maybe
his first win in the Masters Tournament
and you mentioned his sister playing The
Challengers she's having a tough go of
it I saw she lost her game today as well
uh but I do want to Quick give a quick
shout out to somebody in the challenge
Elaine Roberts she Drew her game so she
is two out of four in the Challenger
session she is the lowest rated player
in that field and we mentioned her win
over Erwin Lami uh yesterday sorry that
win was from round two Tanya and I
mentioned it yesterday of a great
attacking display so credit to her she's
from the Netherlands I think the you
know local fans would be very thrilled
to see her continue success but that at
the moment is not what we are focused on
it is progdananda with the black piece
of the diggly Wren Anton a ding is
frozen he doesn't know what to do with
this Rook uh you can't play Rook F4
check that allows the king to slide over
and get the Knight The Rook can go to G5
G6 or G8 none of them look too appealing
because Rook C4 can almost be be
pre-moved no matter what even if the
night's under attack we were talking
about your wonderful tactic the king
could slide into G4 so for dingley Ren
he doesn't see a good move right now
it's a difficult moment we've been
talking about clock management and
weather Prague will have enough time to
convert it now the big question is will
ding have enough time to put up a big
resistance he's down to five minutes on
the clock this is the final time control
the last 15 minutes Edition has happened
the players have crossed the 60th move
Mark and there we see ding making his
choice he falls back with the Rook to G6
so he's threatening the B6 Pawn as well
he knows that after Rook C4 now he
doesn't need to go for Rook F6 pin but
can perhaps pick up the B6 Pawn but
Robert if you do that you lose control
of the G file and note how The Rook on
beasts on C4 also controls the F4 Square
so black can actually come in with the
King now hit that Knight on H3 which
doesn't have a check on F4 anymore all
thanks to the Rook on C4 and once again
the pawn from H4 will start marching
down the board that's a huge problem for
white because you bring your knife to G5
the rookie can come to G4 anyway and
trying to kick this Knight out that
night has been doing an important task
and then get the pawn one little tactic
here Rook G6 it looks like you're
walking into a pin so H3 you can't take
me not so fast you can take this Pawn on
H3 it's a free rook except for the fact
that there is a fork here winning that
Rook right back and if instead of taking
the Rook you take a knight once this
trade happens the white king is in time
to go after this Pawn King C6 Knight
check here do not play King B6 because
after Knight B3 the king's farther away
you can start with King C5 because if
the Knight moves anywhere away from the
queen side the king gobbles with the
pawn if you go to B3 I kick your knight
out and I can play B4 trading off your
final Pawn the game would be a draw so
just a little tactic should be watch out
for Rook D5 check was played and if the
King goes to C6 Knight E7 a fork
protecting the rook and hitting the
enemy Rook but tracking e600
King E6 looks possible because after
Rook D6 you do have King F5 so I can't
give you a check on D6 and this after
Rook G6 King G6 it's interesting how the
eval bar still says it's fine because
black can start chasing around White's
Knight and also find its way to Queen
inside and pick up the pawns so this
should be fine but if not that King E6
I've got to move my Rook to a spot where
I keep the Knight defended so I think
after King E6 I can simply switch back
to this move Rook C5 save that Knight on
F5 Knight D4 is in the air Rook C6 is in
the air at the right time so I still
feel that white is in big trouble after
Rook C5 and the problem for ding is that
for King E6 not only do you have to make
sure that Rook D6 is unavailable and
that Rook C5 is fine there's also Knight
E3 defending the rook in this manner and
black is just a pawn a head The Rook on
D5 may come down to D2 go after the pawn
it may go to the D4 we keep talking
about the strength of a rook on the
fourth rank protecting and attacking
simultaneously so danger doesn't have
easy decisions the position is nothing
like the game between Notre back and uh
Parham muksudlu but it has some
similarities in the sense that every
single turn is difficult for ding
whereas project has like six different
attractive options that all put pressure
on his opponent
ding will want to try to keep the king
closer to the queen side pawns because
that's really his only chance that at
some opportune moment if he gets it he
can try to sacrifice the Knight for the
H Pawn and collect the queen side bonds
what about the move King C7 I'm hitting
that pawn on B6 how do you respond to
that
going for the B6 Pawn so King C7
I guess B5 can be played so maybe that's
what Prague is going for a little bit of
liquidation but if you take and Rook
takes B5 it's clear that black has free
access to the B2 pawn and then there's
two different Rook Pawn passers that is
no fun ding has played the move King to
E6 he goes into the center
goes into the center as you were
pointing out hits that Rook hit that
night Rook C5 will just be a repetition
and Prague finds your move he plays
Knight E3 defending that Rook on D5
keeping all the threats alive and now
once again Rook D4 is coming in hitting
that pawn on A4
protecting attacking a great Square for
the rook and dingley rent down under two
and a half minutes that's not a lot of
time because he's faced with Rook D4
he's faced with Rook D2 uh if the Rook
ever leaves the G6 square or the G file
I should say the black king approaches
the Knight
um Rook F6 check we just learned don't
give checks just because you can the
white at night will be in trouble once
the king moves over so Knight G1 check
baby
my two one check well at least it's a
check and if you go King F2 you can come
back to H3 and give a check so white
black needs to find a safe Square for
the king and I'm just wondering if
that's King E4 because I kind of like
that my knight on E3 does defend G4 but
I have to watch out look at this King E4
you might have Rook to H6 here hitting
my H4 Pawn
and then look at this Knight F5 the king
wow impressively defends everything the
Knight attacks the rook and defends the
pawn H4 and the question could be asked
is this good enough the answer is no you
give away Rook for free look at how many
night Forks we've seen today but the
king is just too close to this Pawn on
B6 and the black king is too far away
from the Knight on G1 so this game would
Peter out into a draw apparently because
when this check happens this is what
happens I blundered because Knight F7
look at that never take your eyes off
the prize because Knight takes F7 the
pawn is free to go forward and that's
why instead of my G5 you wait but Knight
G1 there's King G2 and then Knight E2
and if you push Knight F4 is check and a
fork night end games are tricky but also
beautiful
super stuffy and we might be seeing
something similar played out as we can
see ding has gone for a check on G1
after prague's response Knight E3 I'm
expecting King E4 because King F4 King
F2 don't seem to make any progress white
can jump back and give a check on H3
I'm with you you plug that down to about
five minutes on the clock but it's ding
who's under massive time pressure with
just a minute and a half left
King E4 seems natural at this point and
he plays it of course he does
centralizes his King Rook H6 there's
Knight F5 which is what we were
discussing and eventually this Rook will
be free to go so ding brings his Knight
back to H3 now it feels like it's time
for Rook D4
bring that Rook up attack A4
preemptively defend the pawn on H4 I
think that would just be a nice move for
prognanda and help get him closer to the
finish line
Rook D4 looks really nice you can't
really move the knight from E3 because
white has got a check on G4 so even by
elimination one realizes that you want
to move that Rook
Rook
E5 check perhaps doesn't really get you
anywhere because then white can start
walking with the King once again to the
king side you don't want to allow that
Rook D4 I like it you hit the pawn on A4
looks very strong here and what is
prognan thinking about so that's one
option he can bring his King back to F3
but I don't think he wants to repeat
moves there is a time and a place for
the king to run to the queen side but
not right now if you go King D3 you
blunder this Fork Knight of four check
oh important to be careful about night
jumps I'm just wondering if black has an
option to immediately go for an attack
with Rook to D2 and try to hit he goes
for the move Rook D4 Robert you're
calling out the action it's played on
the board hitting that pawn on A4 I was
wondering about Rook D2 as well hitting
B2 Prague decides that A4 is the pawn
that he wants to go for also very
important that after Rook D2 black white
can go on to attack the H4 Pawn the
multi-purpose square of D4 not only hits
A4 but very often you can next march
King D3 and defend the H4 Pawn at the
same time if white makes the move Rook
to hit six
exactly the king is free to go after
Rook H6 back to F3 The Rook defense The
Rook attacks the queen side is going to
collapse and then black will have at
least one more extra Pawn in addition to
the H Pawn so after Rook to D4 it's
dingley Ren on the clock he's kind of
running out of moves Tanya that's the
problem for him and if this Rook will
run F6 already Knight F2 is Checkmate
that's just kind of funny geometry uh so
if you play B5 that's me I don't think
I've seen a Checkmate like this
oh wow so actually after Rook F6 you
might have to watch out to not pick up
the A4 Pawn
because take a look at this if you go
Rook F6 here
where he's gone for B3 but just to show
there are tricks of Rook F4 check and
picking up the A4 Rook wow it's not just
Knight Forks it's a rook checks that win
a rook behind the enemy King but instead
dingly red plays the blue Pawn to B3 and
I think this Rook should sit on the B4
Square it is defended it defends B6 it
attacks B3 it protects H4 The Rook does
it all from before
this is looking really I don't see a
wave that white can actually defend that
B3 Pawn after Rook B4
I don't think you can look before you
can go Rook at six trying to put
pressure on the H4 pawn and he makes it
he goes there we see some fine technique
on display by pragnananda and if the
Rook comes to F6 we've been so fixated
on the H4 Pawn the idea King D3 King C3
take take you just are helping your past
Pawns helping your past pawns shouldn't
your king be on G3 you're about to have
new past pawns over here on the queen
side so I do think that dingley Ren he's
finding some good ideas trying to
survive but prognanda on the other hand
is a increasing the pressure move after
move
yeah this is just looking too good for
Prague I mean what after King D3 can
white even do there
and then Lauren has been informed in
this event he won the first game against
kokesh then went on to draw against
Parham and Magnus he was the one who was
pushing against Barham as well so Prague
is playing playing an opponent who
actually has been in shape in the event
and that also speaks volumes about
prague's play today to beat ding in this
stage with the form that Ding has been
displaying is absolutely impressive
there's of course still work to be done
and the game isn't over but so far just
brilliant play by Prague King D3 the
idea comes to him Robert we've been
talking about the queen Side Pawn and he
finds it The Rook finds itself in the
ideal spot defending the H4 Pawn look at
the coordination between blacks pieces
the Knight The King and The Rook The
Rook on B4 defends the B6 Pawn the H4
Pawn the Knight r83 defends all kinds of
checks on the third Rank and now King is
marching on to C2 to pick up the B3 Pawn
just play playing it slow Rook between
the air and that's it a huge result for
pregnant as dinglerin resigns he just
throws in the towel because uh the
position is collapsing B3 is loose A4
will fall after that this Rook on before
defended everything a huge win for
prognanda this is perhaps the biggest
accomplishment of his career to this
point he has taken down Magnus Carlson
in the Champions chess Tour on several
occasions but he's just taking down the
world number two in classical chess and
with the black pieces to boot
this is massive and he's got his Waka
jacket on I can imagine a very proud
Vichy Anand right now Waka is the West
Bridge on and chess Academy from where
uh kukesh Prague Arjun they all study
there they're all students of Waka and
we can see him there just calm and
compose no no expression no excessive
excitement and that's the sign of a
champion he's just achieved one of the
biggest Milestones of his chess career
so far for the first time he played
against the world number two his first
matchup against England in classical
chess and frog with the black pieces
goes on to win that one and as you
pointed out in many ways even more
impressive than the win that we saw with
Anish giri taking down Magnus Carlsen
a great day for the teenagers you
mentioned in each curious win over
Magnus Carlson that was a highlight but
no dearbeck Abdus atarov joins
anishikiri in first place with three out
of four prognananda he LeapFrogs over
several people including Magnus to get
to a tie in third to fourth place with
Pablo caruana and well the bottom of the
standings if we look all the way down
there gukesh he is now getting into a
rhythm he lost the first two games he
has two draws in the next batch so he is
still in this tournament even if it's
going to be difficult he still has a
chance so it's good to see gookesh doing
quite well there and for you know the
other players Tony when you look at the
leaderboard here are you surprised by
anything or do you feel like it's early
and everything's normal
loving the win
the way youngsters the Young Guns the
young talents who are here making some
of them making that debut at the Tata
steel Masters we see them up ahead on
the leaderboard on the standings look at
this just take this in Robert the first
segment of the Tata steel Masters is
done tomorrow is a rest day and where do
we stand here we've got 18 year old NADA
back on second place with three points
along with Anish giri sharing full
position then we've got Fabiano and
along with Fabiano you've got 17 year
old pragnananda in joined third place
this is exactly why we love it when a
tournament has a mix of the established
Elite along with the upcoming well it's
hard to call them upcoming anymore with
this young Generations this new wave of
chess players who are really shaking up
this is the future of Chess and now we
can see not just in fast time controls
not just in speed chess but they're
making their Mark In classical play as
well they certainly are and the
teenagers have been playing each other
for several rounds in a row there is a
rest day tomorrow and then the players
will compete in round five at uh Johan
Cruyff stadium and look at this when I
look top to bottom in these pairings I
do not see teenagers playing against
each other I see that gookesh gets white
against Richard report we see that
Magnus Carlson looks to rebound and gets
white against Abdus uttarov prognanda
off a great win plays somebody else who
had a great win anishikiri that is
probably the Marquee matchups Magnus
against abusotarov prognanda against
anishikiri let's not count on our
generic icy with the white pieces
against dangly Wren who just lost this
game he's going to be upset so from top
to bottom including Levon of Roney
against Vincent kymer I think we have
great matchups in store and the
All-American Derby at the top
it is a clash of generations coming up
in round five I'm sure Robert the
players are happy to have a rest day and
you know what that means that means more
preparation that means more Innovative
opening ideas refreshed players a lot of
energetic combative chess is what we
expect out of them when they return for
the Tata steel Masters I can't wait for
the action Robert it's been so much fun
doing this for the first four rounds and
I want to just give a big shout out to
our chat as well everyone who joined us
on Twitch and on YouTube I will be off
for a vacation after this so I won't be
joining the broadcast but I'll be
following it and I'm so excited to see
these young prodigies now really go on
and prove their own in the Big Boys Club
you know everyone is going to miss you
Tanya I was gonna announce that we say
goodbye even the players say see you
later because they have a rest day
tomorrow but Tanya and I we are saying
goodbye because when the action returns
it will be Daniel nairditski and javonto
and Ivanka covering the actions so uh
Tanya it's been an absolute pleasure
round five commences on Thursday thank
you everybody who's been tuning in
watching this action with three
brilliant decisive games today and we
have two leaders and he's scary and Noir
after four rounds goodbye everybody it's
been real we'll see you soon
goodbye
[Music]
we all love to play the dinosaur chess
tournament in Vikings
part of the tradition is that you play
one round in a special location
somewhere else in the Netherlands
that are still just on tour is back and
as a tournament Ambassador I have the
privilege to take an early look at the
location it's going to be spectacular
the location for the Tata steel chest on
tour is the young craft arena in
Amsterdam
[Music]
I look forward to see you all here on
the 19th of January
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]